Die Töne, die da rauf herstanden.
Ja, eine lange Sommerpause haben wir durchlebt. Schön war es, heiß war es. Wir haben geschwitzt. Hat irgendjemand ICE gesessen?
Ich hab noch Brandspuren.
Nein, wir haben uns jegliche Transpirationsphasen für die nächste Sendung aufgespart natürlich. Ja, jetzt haben wir ganz viele tolle Themen verpasst. Das ist natürlich auch gut. Über was wir alles nicht reden können, müssen. Oder doch? Okay, ihr schaut mich gerade alle wieder so an mit ich muss doch jetzt mal das erste Thema vorgeben und so. Also wir hätten jetzt die Wahl, dass wir irgendwie mit Produkten anfangen, dass wir so einfach drüber herziehen, was wir uns alles tolles gekauft haben. Oder wir fangen oder wir oder wir bringen es gleich hinter uns. Die Sache mit dem Telefon.
Ja, sonst zieht sich das hinten nicht so aus.
Zähl mir doch erstmal durch. Wer hat ein iPhone 4? Ich.
Ich nicht.
Max hat keins.
Ich hab keins.
Warum nicht, Max?
Weil, bis mein iPhone 3 erst kaputt gegangen ist, hat mir das eigentlich sehr gut gereicht. Das ist der Grund, dass es kaputt gegangen ist. Das ist ein Verschleiß-Effekt. Ach so.
Ich hab ja diese Nass geschwitzt.
Dieser kleine Schalter, mit dem man hier den Ton ausschaltet, der hat einen Wackelkontakt.
Ja, das ist aber bei ganz vielen so.
Ja, das ist aber scheiße.
Ja, das ist zwar eigentlich bei Apple immer auf dem Tisch.
Ja, das werde ich auch noch tun, aber da ich bis dahin halt gerne noch ein Telefon hätte, habe ich dann gesagt, ja okay. Und weil sich die Gelegenheit ergab, ein iPhone 4 zu kriegen, dann hole ich mir halt doch eins. Man will ja auch den ganzen Spaß haben, so mit Facetime und Deathgrip und allem.
Der richtige Spaß eigentlich ist das bessere Display. Ich gehe abends ins Bett und gucke dann auf, dann schlafe ich ein.
Du machst vorher hoffentlich nichts anderes mehr.
Ne, aber so ist es.
Du schläfst nur davon ein, dass du dir das anguckst?
Ne, ich erfreue mich nochmal, wie geil scharf das ist.
Ja, wenigstens einmal.
Das stimmt.
Ne, aber wirklich, das Display ist so super scharf. Das finde ich das Coolste an dem iPhone 4.
Wird das im Laufe der Zeit noch besser? Also ich hab's, also die Bildqualität ist ja wirklich so, wenn man drauf guckt, ist ja wie gedruckt, aber macht das so einen Unterschied in der Praxis?
Ja.
Du kannst halt ohne Zoom Webseiten browser und kannst richtig Power Surfen.
Du hast jetzt noch nicht so schlechte Augen wie ich, aber ich bin, also für mich ist ja fast schon das alte Retina Display.
Was er meint, ist ja, dass kleinere Fonts besser sichtbar sind, aber ich finde sogar Fonts, die du vorher gesehen hast, zum Beispiel in der Toolbar unten, die immer so kommen, so wenn ein iPod zum Beispiel hier öffnet, heißt das iPod auf dem iPhone? Dann diese Toolbar unten, die hat ja auch nochmal so Untertitel, so wie Favorites oder Highlights, und das konnte man vorher einfach, du kannst das jetzt schneller lesen, also ich kann das jetzt schneller lesen, weil es schärfer ist. Und vorher war das irgendwie so, eigentlich auch schon cool, weil man ja auch schon über 160 dpi, aber wenn du mal beide nebeneinander legst, ist das alte plötzlich unscharf.
Nein, das ist ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht, ist klar.
Ja, aber das macht's aus. Das ist wahrscheinlich so, als wenn du vorher mit 64 Kilobit gehört hättest und du würdest sagen, wieso, aber ich hab doch den Text erkannt, den die da singen, und dann hörst du es nochmal in ordentlicher Qualität. Das ist ungefähr das Gleiche. Du konntest das vorher auch lesen, aber jetzt hast du irgendwie...
Habt ihr schon irgendwas, was diesen Gyroskop-Nutzer, das Ding heißt? Also ich hab ein App, das auf einem 3GS überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Also guck dir mal, da siehst du halt keine Pixel, ne?
Ja, das ist schon... Ja, also das sieht aus wie gedruckt, es sieht auch auf Fotos auch immer ein bisschen unwirklich aus, wenn man so...
Aber es sieht so aus.
Also du kannst jetzt die Schrift auch noch richtig klein machen und die bröselt halt nicht weg, sondern die bleibt einfach crisp so.
Ja, das natürlich.
Und was meint es von, ob man das noch weiter treiben kann, also ob's noch bessere Displays geben wird?
Nee, das ist, also ich nehme an, dass es, jetzt haben sie es erst mal verdoppelt, dass die nächste Stufe, die sie haben, ist ja noch mal verdoppeln und...
Also wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr Pixel macht, würde die keiner sehen können.
So sieht's aus, also ich glaub, die haben genau diese Auflösung genommen, weil mehr lohnt nicht.
Nee, ich meinte, für mich war schon das, also ich glaub meine Augen werden langsam ein bisschen schlechter, für mich war schon das alte Quasi-Rätiner-Display. Also das ist jetzt natürlich Blödsinn, aber...
Also mach doch mal beide nebeneinander und dann guck dir einfach schon die Icons an oder den Text unter den Toolbar zum Beispiel. Legt einfach nebeneinander und dann guckst du mal immer beide drauf und dann siehst du sofort. Und dann willst du es nicht mehr missen.
Also was ich halt ganz geil finde, ist, dass in diesen Foldern, dass man da das... du hast gar keine Folder.
Nee, ich steh nicht so auf Folder.
Aber ich...
Folder sind super.
Ich hab fast nur Folder.
Ihr seid ja auch tabber.
Ich bin auch tabber, aber kein Folder.
Tabber.
Ich bin...
weder noch. Obwohl, ich hab auch ein Folder hab ich, war so zum testen. Seitdem spiel ich nicht mehr, weil meine Spiele sind alle...
Ich hab ein Folder, wo die ganzen crappy Apple-Apps, die dabei sind, drin sind, nämlich hier dieses Wetter-Widget und Börse und... die, die ich nie benutze, die sind alle in einem Folder.
Naja, aber ich hatte da irgendwie viel zu viele... viel zu viele Icons. Mit den Foldern find ich's besser. Also es ist natürlich auch eine gewisse Bremse.
Das ist aber ein iOS 4.0-Feature, das hat jetzt mit dem iPhone 4 nix zu tun.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dem iPhone. Also ich hab das jetzt erst seit ein paar Tagen, von daher kann ich da noch nicht so Ich auch.... sehr viel zu sagen. Dienstag?
Sind Karte selber geschnitzt oder...
Nee, bin ich... genau, ist ja auch ein Thema. Also ich weiß nicht, ob wir jetzt schon twitchen wollen, aber kann ich ja ganz kurz schon erzählen. Ich wusste, dass es Dienstag ankommen wird, das Phone. Ich hab Montagabend getwittert, wie das nun ist mit Karte und hin und her und die haben alle so viel Zeug, die da mal unterschiedlich geantwortet haben, dass ich dachte, okay, fuck it. Also hingefahren zu O2 in der Friedrichstraße, hab gesagt, hier Mikrosim, hat er gesagt, ja alles klar, hat irgendwie was klar gemacht. Die rufen ja dann immer beim Chef irgendwie durch und sagen, hier macht mal irgendwie Aktivierung und dann hat er mir diesen Umschlag mit der Mikrosim in die Hand gedrückt und mich da weggefahren. Als sie auf Arbeit ankommen, ankamen...
Bisschen laden rein und hast das Teil in die Hand bekommen. Ah, interessant.
Und der ruft halt für dich an und schaltet frei. Sonst musst du wahrscheinlich noch selber anrufen, wenn du es per Post machst oder so. Weil wenn die da ist, musst du aktiviert werden. Und der hat mir gesagt, okay, so eine halbe Stunde oder eine Stunde ist die aktiviert, bin zur Arbeit gefahren, hab mein iPhone bekommen, hab's reingesteckt und dann ging's aus.
Hast du dir gleich eine Multisim geholt?
Nee, der Typ meinte irgendwie, geht nicht und Zeug und ganz komisch und was weiß ich nicht. Und der hatte auch nicht so...
Was, wie geht nicht?
Aber mal ehrlich, als er mir zuhörte, tut mir leid, aber du hast keinen Plan. Nee, aber der war so ein bisschen wusser, nicht? Und hab ich später noch mal gefragt und meinte, ja, aber er hat gerade keine und erst später wieder und so weiter. Und dann meinte ich, dann könnte ich mir ja später locker eine holen. Dann meinte er, ja, aber dann müssten Sie den ganzen Prozess noch mal machen. Hab ich schon gemerkt, der ist irgendwie, naja, ich nehm erstmal meine Mikrosim und geh wieder. Und meine alte, ich dachte, die ging erst. Gleichzeitig sah es so aus. So in meinem alten drei Gäste, da war ja noch die alte Karte drin. Und dachte ich, naja, vielleicht ist ja schon alles klar, weil die funktioniert noch noch, aber irgendwann hat die dann keinen Service mehr. Also die alte ist jetzt disablet, die alte Karte. Weil ich hätte schon gerne noch eine große Sim, falls ich mal mein iPhone hier irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Ganz bei Amazon für 4,95 Euro kannst du dir einen Plasterahmen kaufen, wo du eine Mikrosim reinstecken kannst, die dann...
Das ist wahrscheinlich das Beste.
Ja, das ist flexibelste. Wenn du alles auf Micro hast, dann kannst du irgendwie jede Karte überall reinstecken und wenn du noch so einen Rahmen am Start hast...
Genau, der Typ meinte nämlich auch, wenn ich noch eine zweite haben wollte, dann wäre das auch ein Micro-SIM. Aber ist es doch total egal, in welchem Formfaktor das ist, oder?
Ich hab ja auch U2 angerufen und ich hatte ja schon eine Multi-SIM-Karte. Also ich hatte schon zwei große. Die andere hab ich immer für meinen USB-Stick benutzt, den ich aber selten benutzt habe. Und du kannst ja drei dir holen bei einem U2. Das ist ja alles extrem unkompliziert bei den Jungs in gewisser Hinsicht. Und dann fragt sie so, wollen sie eine große oder eine kleine? Wissen sie irgendwie schon, die Fragen kannten sie immer nicht. Kleine hat sie dann noch mal genau nachgefragt, um sich sicher zu sein, dass ich auch verstehe, worum es geht. Naja, so mit Mikro und Multi und so. Da kommen wir ja schnell mal ins Schleudern. Also ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall haben sie mir die jetzt heute zugeschickt. Ich konnte es natürlich dann nicht erwarten. Ich hab mir beim Mac Notes dieses PDF runtergeladen, wo sie einfach mal so eine Schnippelvorlage da auf PDF gemartert haben. Und das habe ich da drauf geklebt und abgeschnitzt.
Das geht eigentlich erstaunlich easy, oder?
Naja, ich meine, das ist halt einfach nur ein bisschen Plastik weg. Du darfst halt gar nicht zu stürmisch drauf los schnippeln. Ich habe es halt so grob abgeschnitzt und dann den Rest weggefeilt.
Aber so zu diesen Sim-Karten-Adaptern, mit denen die in einen normalen Slot reingehen. Ich kenne jemanden, der hat sich damit seinen USB-Stick kaputt gemacht. Weil der hat den dann reingedrückt und hat dann wieder rausgezogen. Und dabei sind so diese Beinchen, also diese Kontaktbeinchen, haben sich dabei zwischen Mikrosim und Adapter geraten und haben sich da verklemmt und dann...
Das ist natürlich schlecht...
.hat er sich dabei kaputt gemacht. Also es ist nicht ganz ohne.
Mir wäre so eine richtige Karte am Ende wahrscheinlich auch lieber, muss man gucken. Aber der Typ meint, der ist irgendwie nicht geht und wenn dann noch eine, dann brauchen wir auch noch eine Mikrosim, also zwei Mikrosims, wenn... Und ja, muss ich mal gucken. Aber erstmal habe ich jetzt eine funktioniert und... Und er wollte 15 Euro haben. Meint, das kommt dann mit der O2-Rechnung. Wobei viele andere Leute meinten, sie hätten es umsonst bekommen. Also ich denke mal, es kommt auch immer pro Top drauf an, wie das halt so ist.
Multisims kostet eigentlich sozusagen die Ausgabe.
Ich weiß jetzt keine Multisims, war nur ein Wechsel. Ich hab ja nicht zwei, ich hab jetzt nur die eine.
Ich hab nur von Groß aufs Kleid gewechselt.
Also halt, wenn sie dir eine neue SIM-Karte geben, dann wollen sie dann irgendwie für den Verwaltungsvorgang irgendwie Geld haben. Und ich hab jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht gefragt, was, weil als ich mir die zweite Mal gekauft hatte, habe ich irgendwelche Bonuspunkte, die ich da komischerweise gesammelt hatte, für eingesetzt. Woher kommen diese Bonuspunkte her? Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Wie auch immer. Ich weiß dann auch noch eine zweite Geschichte hier. Telekom schickt einem auch gerne eine Micro-SIM zu, da lief das dann aber so, dass die Micro-SIM dann auch losgeschickt wurde und ab dem Moment, wo sie losgeschickt wurde, wurde die andere deaktiviert.
Super, oder?
Das bei unserer deutschen Post, die alle drei Tage kommt.
Genau.
So wurde dann aber...
Ja, die Telekom-Egal, weil die macht es ja nicht mehr...
.wurde dann aber relativ kuhland umgangen, indem man dann einfach zum Telekom-Laden latschen konnte, sich eine andere SIM holt und dann haben sie das sozusagen gleich umgebucht, sodass es dann auch über den Weg dann auch schneller geht. Im Laden gehen ist immer am besten.
Im Laden gehen geht wahrscheinlich einfach am besten.
Aber konnte ja vorher niemand ahnen, dass die Leute sauber werden, wenn man die Karte sofort deaktiviert und nicht erst, wenn sie angekommen ist.
Das richtet ja auch niemand. Also ich bin ja Telekom-Opfer, aber ich muss ja sagen, war alles total smooth, ja. Also irgendwie kam ja iPhone 4 raus, alle haben gesagt, oder hieß schon irgendwie vier Wochen warten und so weiter und so fort, war ich ganz entspannt. Ich bin dann in den Store rein, ist mein Vertrag auch gerade 18 Monate alt geworden, hab ich irgendwie gesagt, Klick will hier Neues haben. Hab online geklickt und dann irgendwie hab ich vor allen Leuten, die vor mir bestellt haben, eins gekriegt und auch alle, die nach mir bestellt haben, haben noch viel länger gewartet, also die ich so kannte. Also ich hatte das eine Woche später, ich hab am 28. Juni oder so bestellt und hatte es irgendwie nächste Woche im Juli. Irgendwie so total flink. Irgendwie mit Microsim angerufen, umgebucht, irgendwie war alle ein paar Minuten gegessen. Fertig.
Ich. Telekom-Opfer.
Ich telekschicke das rosa Hemd, was du da an hast.
Was hast du da für einen Vertrag?
Na noch so diesen ersten Generation M mit 120 Freiminuten.
Ach der wurde theoretisch eine Mikrosy...
Bei dem ja angeblich, laut Auskunft der Hotline, ja dann doch, dass Tethering irgendwie noch mit drin sei, aber dann eben nur... über deinen Laptop, aber eben nicht über dein iPhone.
Ne, du kriegst die zweite, du kannst ja eine zweite SIM-Karte holen, glaube ich. Das ist doch so ein Multisim-Vertrag.
Es ist total mysteriös und es ist so Banane. Vor allem, ich meine mal ehrlich, das ist ein echter Rip-Off. 20 Euro dafür zu bezahlen, dass man Daten durch das iPhone aus dem Internet beziehen kann und nicht über eine USB-Stick.
Aber sie haben doch noch eine zweite Variante, die günstiger ist, oder? Sie haben doch irgendwie so 5 Euro mit HBAR.
Ja, wir haben jetzt noch eine neue, ja.
Aber 100 MB Cap und wenn du wirklich Laptop und 3G machst, 100 MB ist einfach mal...
Ne, aber du kriegst 100 MB dazu zu dem, was du sowieso schon hast. Also wenn du einen 5 GB-Tarif hast, dann kriegst du nochmal so pro Forma hier, packen wir nochmal 100 MB drauf und dann kannst du 5,1 GB quasi nutzen.
Ja, und wenn du dann da drüber bist...
Über die 5,1 GB.
5 GB hast du beim normalen Telekom-Vertrag? Nie und nimmer.
2, aber...
Ja, irgendwie, also es ist, aber ich, also, ich bin da auch noch nie, also ich hab ja einmal...
Wie auch immer, du hast auf jeden Fall...
Also man wird nochmal abkassiert für etwas, was du sowieso schon gekauft hast, klar.
Ja, ein bisschen irgendwie einen Megabyte drüber, dann zahlst du halt pro Webseite irgendwie 20 Cent.
Und der Witz ist aber, dass du hast ja zwar nach 18 Monaten langsamer...
Nein, da wird nicht gedrosselt bei der Telekom.
Doch, bei der Telekom wird gedrosselt.
Ich hab mir das gerade durchgelesen, steht auf der Webseite.
Also ich kenne auch viele Leute, bei denen es gedrosselt wurde.
Bei aktuellen Verträgen, ich hab mir das auf der Webseite angeschaut, da steht nix von drosseln.
Ich hab halt einmal...
Da steht, du zahlst extra.
Und du zahlst da diese typische Strafgebühr von... Das ist geil, ne? Dann gehen sie so auf 10 Kilobyte runter, ne? Damit sie dann auch Centbeträge angeben können. Dafür finde ich, müsste man eigentlich mindestens das mittlere Management, wenn nicht sogar den Vorstand, einfach auch öffentlich auspeitschen.
Mit Ethernet-Kabel.
Und zwar so ein bisschen so halbnackt, so in so zerfledderten T-Shirts, auf so einem Scheiterhaufen irgendwo in Bonn. Direkt vor ihrem komischen Ton.
Bonn ist doch ein einziger Scheiterhaufen, ne?
So war man jetzt nicht. Aber stell dir doch mal dieses Bild vor, ja? Einfach so, dann kannst du die da so mit Livio übergießen und dann irgendwie so mit so Tannenzweigen, darfst du die dann so auspeitschen.
Okay, reicht jetzt. Aber sag mal, der Vertrag hat sich jetzt trotzdem um 24 Monate verlängert und zwar der alte Vertrag, der 24 Monate dauert. Insgesamt hast du jetzt trotzdem 48 am Hals. Verstehe.
Wie viel zahlst du pro Monat?
49. Wie viel hast du das iPhone dann bezahlt?
Das ist 32.
Das 32 hast du. 150? Okay, also hast du gegenüber einem, der das irgendwie für 720 in England besorgt, hast du 570 Euro eingespart.
Ich finde die Kamera total toll auch.
Ich wollte nur mal das...
Dieses ewige Telekom Ball aber gibt mir auch... Du musst ja nur mal durchrechnen. Ich rechne mal durch.
Mach dich jetzt mal schnell.
Ich will einfach ordentlich behandelt werden. Und vor allem will ich im Ausland andere Netze bedienen.
Ja, wollen wir alle, genau, super.
Also ich hab grad nochmal...
Nein, jetzt nicht die AGBs hier vorlesen.
Also es ist tatsächlich 100 Kilobyte, in 100 Kilobyte Schritten wird danach berechnet bei dem 200 Megabyte Vertrag. Also dann zahlst du für 100 Kilobyte 50 Cent. Aber maximal 100 Euro.
Tannenzweige, ich würde sagen, optional könnte man auch irgendwie diese Zeige mit Wiederhaken nehmen. Einfach, damit man auch so ein bisschen die Haut so ein bisschen blutig ritzt, finde ich.
Also 50 Cent für 100 Kilobyte, finde ich jetzt.
Google hat neulich... Ich bin schon beim nächsten Thema. Google hat neulich gesagt, dass die durchschnittliche Webseite 320 Kilobyte groß ist im Internet.
Siehst du, das sind ja gerade mal 1,50 pro Webseite.
Also ich finde es immer ganz cool, wenn man solche Tarife dann auch mal umsetzt, in was du sozusagen pro Webseite zahlst.
Der Spiegel hat 2,5 MB, wenn du den aufrufst.
Ja klar, es gibt große Seiten, aber die durchschnittliche Webseite ist bei 320 Kilobyte.
Aber wo ist denn der normale User? Der ist nicht auf den Seiten, wo keine Bilder sind. Die sind nur bei Facebook und bei Spiegel und da, wo am besten auch dynamisch die ganze Zeit nachgeladen wird. Also um ehrlich, die wollen jetzt gerade alle Kohle von Google, weil Google ja so viel verdient. Aber ohne Google und so ne riesengroßen Firmen, die so fette Seiten haben, würden die gar kein Traffic verkaufen können. Dann würden wir jetzt noch mit ihr reden.
Du bist jetzt schon voll in der Netzneutralität. Aber das ist ein Thema, das ich noch nicht weiß. Anderes Thema.
Ich werd jetzt gespielt.
Also die Kamera ist cool.
Bleiben wir nochmal beim iPhone 4.
Genau, die Kamera ist voll geil.
Hast du da schon ordentlich mit fotografiert und gefilmt?
Und? Ich hatte ja vorhin 3G und bin jetzt hier mit so einem Quantensprung konzentriert worden. Also die Zukunftstechnologie schlechthin und alles schneller, alles besser.
Du weißt, dass ein Quantensprung so ziemlich der kleinste, geringste Weg ist, die man zurücklegen kann?
Das kommt immer auf die Perspektive an.
Guck mal, Huckel ist ja auch nicht so groß.
Wollte ich nur gesagt haben. Aber ich bin, also die Kamera finde ich richtig cool und ich finde auch die Frontside-Kamera richtig cool, also dass man so hin und her switchen kann und Video aufnehmen und so.
Das rockt.
Kamera und Display.
Und Facetime.
Failtime.
Failtime. Also ich muss sagen, bisher bin ich nicht beeindruckt von der Zuverlässigkeit.
Von Facetime?
Wenn dein Netz hier auch immer im Arsch ist, da kann das ja auch nicht gehen.
Also mein Netz funktioniert jetzt an sich ja ganz gut, oder? Also ich kann ja hier nochmal probieren. Ich klick mal hier auf...
Er hat sogar das Kleingedruckte von der Telefonbank in 5 Wochen abgeladen.
Also ich hab mit meinem Telefon noch gar nichts gemacht und dann hat der Huckel mich angerufen mit einem Facetime-Call und ich musste nur abheben und ich hab nicht irgendwas eingereicht, das war einfach mal so wie telefonieren. Das war schon cool.
Es hat auf Ani funktioniert?
Ich musste nichts machen. Ich hab nur abgenommen und der Huckel war irgendwie...
Also bei mir haben die ersten Male auch spontan funktioniert, aber danach gab's auch schon echt oft so dieses Connection-Feld.
Bei unserem Anruf war glaube ich auch mittendrin einmal schräg geblieben.
Genau, mittendrin noch.
Ja, weil ich musste nichts einrichten oder sowas.
Es war eben auch total unklar, warum es dann irgendwie nicht geht. Also ich fühlte mich so ein bisschen an iChat wieder zurückerinnert. Und ich dachte, das wäre jetzt... Es macht auch die ähnliche Geräusche.
Und ich denke mal, die sind ja nicht blöd bei Apple. Das hat seinen Grund.
Na, welchen?
Das darf jeder sich selber denken. Nee, aber dass es bei iChat dann auch vielleicht das Feature kommt.
Welches Feature? Das ist wieder...
Das ist wieder nicht funktionieren.
Ja, natürlich wird es da kommen. Gar keine Frage.
Das weiß ja nicht jeder.
Dann können wir vielleicht mal kurz auch noch auf die letzte Sendung nochmal zurückgehen. Da hab ich ja groß in die Glaskugel geblickt und mal so verschiedene Vermutungen darüber angestellt, wie Facetime eigentlich funktioniert. Ihr erinnert euch?
Ja, doch. Du warst ja auch ganz sehr geschlafen. Nee, du warst geschlafen, ja.
Ja, wir haben unsere Füße an dir gewärmt, Dennis.
Ich hab mir nie an sie in die Füße gewärmt.
Doch, wir haben ihn noch in den Stuhl festgegabert.
Hab ich irgendwas verpasst?
Hab ich Karotten gebrochen?
Kann man die nachweisen?
Dann haben wir dich hier auf den Tisch gelegt als Fußwärmer. Naja, auf jeden Fall, meine Theorie damals war ja folgende, dass sie, was ja klar ist, sie lösen derzeit Gesprächsvermittlungen auf über die Telefonnummer. Sie wollen sozusagen verhindern, dass du noch einen anderen Key hinterlegen musst, außer dem, den du sowieso schon hast. Was ja an sich eine ganz pfiffige Geschichte ist. Da bin ich dann in meinem Jugendlichen Leichtsinn.
Ich wollte dafür sorgen, dass du nur einmal existierst, damit klar ist, wer wo angerufen wird.
Sie wollen es vor allem seamless machen. Sie wollen halt, du rufst jemanden an, du bist schon im Telefonat und du möchtest dann auf Video umschalten. So ist es ja implementiert. Du kannst ja jederzeit während eines Telefonats...
Weiß ich gar nicht. Ich wurde von Huckel angerufen und es war gleich FaceTime.
Ich erzähle dir jetzt erstmal, was ich damals glaubte. Und jetzt erzähle ich dir, was ich mittlerweile meine, zu wissen, wie es ist. Also, ich glaubte, dass das so funktioniert, dass es erstmal komplett IP ist, das ist es. Das heißt, es braucht nicht GSM oder so. Aber es benötigt derzeit eben noch diese Telefonnummern. Und wenn du ein iPhone 4 das erste Mal in die Hand nimmst und dann sozusagen da FaceTime willst, beziehungsweise das war glaub ich bei mir das erste Mal, wenn du dich hier nur einbuchs, macht er das schon, dann schickt dieses Gerät an der SMS vermutlich nach Britannien, an so eine britische plus 4-4-Nummer, mit irgendeinem Krypto-Klimbim, wo deine Rufnummer drin ist. Und dann kriegst du...
Ich nehme an, da wird deine Push-Notification ID gespeichert.
Das hat mit Push-Notification überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Doch, die müssen dich ja wiederfinden.
Nein.
Lass es mich einfach kurz erläutern, du darfst mir danach umfangreich wieder sprechen, aber das ist sozusagen das, was dich derzeit aus dem Web herausschälen lässt, wie es funktioniert. Dann schick dir diese Gegenstelle, schick dir eine SMS zurück. Da steht auch noch mal irgendwelche Zahlen CryptoFu drin. Sprich, das ist irgendeine kryptographische Sicherstellung, dass dieses Gerät, was du da gerade verwendest, unter dieser Nummer erreichbar ist.
Unter welcher Nummer?
Deiner eigenen.
Du wirst das später gar nicht per Nummer erreichen.
Also du prüfst sozusagen per SMS, dass dieses Telefon diese Nummer hat. Und dann weiß Apple sozusagen, oder das iOS an der Stelle, dass das sozusagen seine Richtigkeit hat, bzw. das Apple Netzwerk weiß das. Daraufhin wird ein Shadow-Jobber-Account für dich erstellt. Ich dachte damals, als ich noch nicht so richtig darüber nachgedacht habe, dass sie irgendwie Enum und DNS machen, das ist aber, das ist erstens nicht so und es gibt auch gute Gründe, warum das eigentlich kein guter Weg gewesen wäre, weil dann hast du nämlich das Problem, dass eben diese Autorisierung für Enum, das wusste ich nicht ganz genau, wie das geht, das ist irgendwie der totale Fail. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, was Apple macht ist, sie haben einen Javaserver laufen und wenn du im WLAN online bist, dann hast du sozusagen eine Presence auf diesem Javaserver. Unter deiner Rufnummer. Das heißt, du bist sozusagen deine Telefonnummer, at geheimer Javaserver bei Apple dort kommen und dort hast du dann halt die Presence, dass du eben sichtbar bist.
Und der arbeitet mit Push-Notification.
Nein. Was hat mit Push-Notification überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Aber der muss doch wissen, wenn ein Call reinkommt.
Na wenn ein Call reinkommt, dann kommt der halt einfach per IP rein. Dieses Telefon ist ja dann mit diesem Jabber-Server verbunden. Das ist dann wie Chat. Das ist dann, wenn du eine Chat-Nachricht kriegst, dann kriegst du eine Chat-Nachricht.
Und das hat jemand getestet, dass wenn man einen Facetime-Call reinkriegt, dass das nicht von der Adresse kommt, von der Push-Notifications kommen, sondern es kommt dann von diesem Jabber-Server.
Ich hab nirgendswo irgendwas gelesen von Push-Notifications. Ich kann das jetzt auch nicht total ausschließen, dass das vielleicht auch noch irgendeine Rolle spielt, aber davon weiß ich nicht. Es haben halt verschiedene Leute versucht, das Ganze zu tracen, um herauszubekommen, welche Protokolle da tatsächlich verwendet werden.
Da gibt es diesen Typ mit diesen Verschlüsseln.
Es wird alles verschlüsselt gemacht. Und es geht aber eben über so Ports wie 5223. Also so typische Jabber-Server-Ports. Daraus leitet man sozusagen das ab. Es gibt jetzt noch nicht wirklich ein Jabber-Protokoll-Level-Trace. Zumindest habe ich keinen gesehen, der jetzt genau darlegen würde, wie das Ganze ausgehandelt wird. Sprich, Apples Modell ist, sie basieren das auf Jabber. Mit anderen Worten, dieselbe Infrastruktur, die sie auch derzeit für Eye-Chat eigentlich primär verwenden. Sodass es eben sehr nahe liegt, dass es sich damit relativ leicht paaren lässt. Also Eye-Chat aufzubohren, Facetime zu machen, ist eigentlich ein No-Brainer. Das ist sozusagen dieselbe Infrastruktur. Und das macht an der Stelle auch total Sinn, wie sie es machen. Ich bin jetzt bloß gespannt, weil sie ja angekündigt haben, dass sie das als eine offene Spezifikation pushen wollen, die eben auch federationfähig ist. Na ja, dass du eben auch ein Android-Phone mit Facetime machen kannst, sodass du dann eben auch... Ich hab nur gelesen, dass Skype Interesse hat. Ob sie das wirklich tun wollen oder so, keine Ahnung. Aber ich meine, nach den ersten Erfahrungen, muss ich sagen, da funktioniert aber Skype zuverlässiger. Das hast du mich rausgebracht. Was wollte ich gerade sagen? Ach ja, genau. Das haben sie aber bisher noch nicht getan. Und ich weiß auch nicht ganz genau, wann sie das vorhaben, das zu tun. Ich vermute mal, dass sie jetzt den Release der nächsten iPod-Touch-Generationen noch abwarten werden. Und da gab es ja jetzt schon die ersten Leaks, dass in der 4.1-Software du eben auch noch für Facetime E-Mail-Adressen konfigurieren kannst. Da steht auch irgendwie E-Mail. Ich vermute allerdings, dass es sich dabei letzten Endes, also entweder handelt es sich dabei auch um Jobber-Accounts, die sozusagen derselben User-At-Server-Geschichte folgen. Oder so wie du jetzt quasi auf diesem Jobber-Server einen Alias über deine Telefonnummer auf einen Account hast, hast du quasi auch eine E-Mail-Adresse als Schlüssel auf diesen Account.
Ich würde ziemlich sicher sagen Letzteres, weil ansonsten irgendein Free-Mail-Provider, hotmail.com, dann könnte man ja damit FaceTime nicht nutzen.
Nee, ist richtig. Ich denke, dass die Leute da quasi ihre E-Mail, also Apple's Denk an der Stelle ist halt die, sie wollen halt Videotelefonie vermitteln und sie wollen als Key das benutzen, was die Leute sowieso meistens benutzen. Das ist halt bei Telefonen, das ist halt Telefonnummern. Und das nächste, was jeder hat, ist halt eine E-Mail-Adresse. Und dann ist das halt der Schlüssel. Genauso wie Gmail-Accounts ja auch sozusagen sich da mit deiner E-Mail-Adresse da assoziieren. E-Mail gibt's noch? Ja, hoffe ich zumindest. Die eine oder andere Infrastruktur von mir basiert da drauf. So, das heißt, so funktioniert FaceTime theoretisch. Praktisch habe ich aber eine ganze Menge Connection-Probleme. Jetzt hat Apple ja angekündigt, dass sie auch SRTP unterstützen wollen. Also der eigentliche Datentransfer geht offensichtlich über RTP, also Realtime-Transfer-Protokoll, mit irgendwie H264 AAC, das übliche.
Mit diesem Low Latency AAC, den die da haben, ne?
Vermutlich. Ist vorstellbar, dass sie das machen, ja. Würde auf jeden Fall Sinn machen, aber das stand da so jetzt nicht. Aber was da stand, ist, dass sie halt auch SRTP machen. Dass sie quasi secure RTP machen. Das hat aber so in The Wild bisher noch keiner gesehen. Das heißt, alle Facetime Verbindungen sind vermutlich derzeit alle unverschlüsselt und über RTP.
Hast du dich vorhin gesagt, dass alles verschlüsselt? Du meinst nur der Connection Aufbau?
Genau, also diese ganze Authentifizierungs- und Vermittlungsgeschichte, die läuft offensichtlich über einerseits HTTPS, andererseits über TLS verschlüsselte Jobber-Verbindungen.
Die kann man ja eigentlich demnächst, jetzt wo man das alles prima jailbreaken kann, könnte man ja da reingehen, dieses S mal wieder entfernen und dann machte das nur mit HTTP. So habe ich damals schon den Skyhawk Connections irgendwie einmal mitgeschnitten. Das müsste eigentlich schon jemand gemacht haben. Wenn nicht, dann Jungs ran immer, ne?
Ich denke, wir werden da auch noch mehr sehen. Und ich erwarte halt, dass jetzt, wenn der iPod Touch herauskommt, der nächste, dass sie da eben auch Fester mit drauf haben. So das Ding dann eben tatsächlich eine Kamera hat, wie es ja die Rumors sagen.
Kolportiert wird.
Und hat der auch ein Retina-Display?
Würde ich für möglich halten.
Also ich behaupte einfach ja, weil...
Das ist für Spiele der Knaller.
Genau, alles andere macht auch keinen Sinn, ne?
Sie wollen hardware-seitig genau das Gleiche haben, die werden auch den Gyroskop und sowas alles drin haben wollen.
Denk ich auch, und auch mit dem A4 und so.
Bestimmt.
Okay, zurück zum iPhone hier.
Ja, also das ist so das, was mir zu FaceTime bisher so einfällt.
Und praktischer Nutzen bisher für dich?
Na...
Hat deine Frau auch sowas? Auch ein iPhone 4.
Kannst du jetzt drüben anrufen und die Kinder zeigen?
Ich sag's ja, du brauchst ja nur die Apple-Werbung anzuschauen und du weißt, wer die Zielgruppe ist. Familien, Menschen mit Verwandtschaft, Kinder, Omas, das zieht einfach mal so dermaßen und das ist echt cool.
Ich glaube, die eigentliche Zielgruppe ist eine andere, aber die darf man vor 23 Uhr nicht im Fernsehen zeigen.
Das würde Steve nie zugeben. Meinst du, das war irgendwie so viel?
Hast du schon mal FaceTime-Calls gemacht?
Vielleicht für noch nicht entstandene Familien sozusagen.
Nee, ich meine, das ist definitiv auch für Porno cool. Und es gab ja hier auch schon so eine Chat-Rollett-Anwendung, die Apple da nicht gemacht hat.
Wo du anrufst, du kriegst einfach irgendwen. Gab es nicht von Apple eine Testnummer, wo man anrufen konnte, die jetzt aber nicht mehr geht?
Ich weiß nicht, geht die nicht mehr?
Hat irgendwo mal wer geschrieben, deswegen habe ich mich jetzt nicht drum bemüht, diese Nummer zu sorgen, aber die hatten wohl eine Nummer, wo man anrufen konnte, um Facetime zu testen, weil man ja noch keinen kennt, der ein iPhone 4 hat.
Ja, ich hab auch davon gehört, dass es diese Nummer gibt, aber ich bin bisher noch nicht dazu gekommen, darüber nachzudenken, um da mal zu rufen.
Da sitzt dann ein Apple-Mitarbeiter und winkt?
Keine Ahnung, das ist wahrscheinlich von Videoabspielen.
Angeblich haben die da wohl Leute auch hingesetzt tatsächlich.
Die haben sich dann wahrscheinlich zu viel Schwänze angucken müssen und dann es wieder sein lassen.
Ich möchte es nicht wissen.
Zu dem Antennaproblem müssen wir jetzt natürlich noch mal kurz kommen.
Jetzt Antennagate.
Also ernsthaft, ich habe das jetzt bisher einmal ausprobiert. Ich weiß, dass ich in meiner Küche immer sehr schlechten Empfang hatte. Hatte dann irgendwie zwei Balken oder so. Und habe dann auf diesen Dings da gefasst, der ja alles schlimmer machen soll. Und dann hatte ich zwei Balken mehr.
Also ich habe bisher zwei iPhone 4s in der Hand gehabt, von denen nicht eins meins ist. Und mit dem einen habe ich es wirklich nicht geschafft. Ich habe mir echt Mühe gegeben, den Empfang zu zusammenbrechen zu geben. Bei dem anderen, da habe nicht ich das gemacht, sondern der Besitzer, Tristez Deluxe.
Ha, User Error.
Und der hat wirklich so leicht mit dem Finger dran geditcht. Das war schon eindrucksvoll.
Und was brach dann was ab?
Aber so schnell geht das doch gar nicht.
Es hat so 15, 20 Sekunden gedauert.
Mit 4.0 oder 4.01?
Das war noch ein 4.0er. Aber er machte nicht so den Eindruck, als ob man irgendwo in den Bestell... Also er saß einfach da und ich konnte es ihm zeigen. Er hat es gezeigt, er hat es gehalten entsprechend und der Empfang brach zusammen. Und es ging auf einen Balk runter. Und war alles 5, 4, 0, klar. Ich frag mich, ob das an den Telefonen liegt, dass die mittlerweile die ein bisschen anders produzieren. Weil es gab ja so Gerüchte, dass da so ein Lack drüber sei oder sowas. Ich frag mich, ob das vielleicht an der chemischen Zusammensetzung seines Schweißes oder was auch immer liegt. Aber bei ihm war es hundertprozentig. Er meinte, das stört ihm im Alltag nicht die Bohne. Und dass er es nicht merkt. Aber vom Effekt her war es schon schick. Also kann ich mir vorstellen, dass da einige Leute durchticken.
Ich hab auch schon Leute das Telefon in die Hand nehmen sehen und das Signal droppen lassen und so weiter. Aber ich hab es jetzt ja ein Monat so in etwa. Und ich hatte noch keinen Dropped Call. Und overall Reception Performance war eigentlich, im Vergleich zu meinem 3G, einfach so der Eindruck, viel schneller. So 3G war viel schneller und alles höher, weiter, schneller, besser. Also wie gesagt, ich hab auch gesehen... Genau.
Mein 3GS war schon... Du meinst jetzt auch den Datenrat oder wie?
Ja, das auch.
Ja klar, das liegt aber auch an anderen Gründen, warum das schneller ist.
Nee, aber ich hab halt keine... Also ich hab selber keine Klagen über die Antenne. Ich hab... Ich kann das... Aber Leute haben mit meinem Telefon das hingekriegt. Wenn ich da ganz lange doll drauf drücke und so, dann passiert das auch. Aber ich hatte einfach noch keinen Drop Call. Und von daher ist mir das so ein bisschen...
Latte...
.ein bisschen egal. Und jetzt hab ich ja gerade diesen Gratis-Bumper, den ich da ausprobiere und dann ist es sowieso egal. Also ich glaub schon, dass sie da irgendwie so ein Problem haben, aber ich glaube, das ist halt echt einfach viel zu übertrieben so hochgepeitscht.
Also ich glaub schon auch, dass sie da ein Problem haben, aber alle Telefone geht der Empfang runter, wenn man die festhält. Ist einfach so, hab ich bei meinem 3GS auch probiert.
Ja, wobei es sind andere Ursachen, das muss man wirklich sagen.
Ja, weil man seine Hand drum hat. Das ist die eine Ursache, das haben aber alle Telefone und das hat aber speziell noch den Grund, weil man die Antenne berührt und weil man die zwei verschiedenen Antennen kurzschließt. Und dann geht es halt schon ein bisschen mehr in den Keller, glaube ich, als bei anderen Phones. Ich hab meins jetzt noch nicht lange genug, dass ich jetzt weiß, ob es wirklich schlimm ist, aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass der Empfang mit dem Phone hier besser ist als vorher. Vielleicht eher schlechter, bin ich mir aber auch noch nicht so sicher.
Wie ist denn das eigentlich, wenn man das Ding zum Beispiel mit einem Schlüssel in der Tasche hat oder sowas? Also kann man das irgendwie mit Metall so richtig böse kurzschließen?
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Müsste man, also weil... Ich hab's in der Sendung.
Aber ich hab's mit einem Kolben dabei. Können da mal ein paar Cablechen drüber leiten.
Wir können doch mal so einen Schlüssel dranhalten oder sowas, was da passiert ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Begriff kurzschließen an der Stelle, aber das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass da Strom drüber... Ist ja nicht jetzt wirklich im eigentlichen Sinne so ein Stromleiter.
Ist es nicht?
Du ärdest die damit, wenn du sie berührst und dann kann die nicht mehr...
Ja, du veränderst halt ihr Empfangsverhalten.
Ich bin jetzt noch echt kein Antennentechniker. Vermutlich nicht.
Ja doch, beim Fernseher manchmal bleibt er genauso.
Antennagate, dieses berühmte Fall, dass der Empfang so supergut wird, dass man es an der falschen Stelle versteht.
Es geht halt darum, elektromagnetische Schwingungen da irgendwie ins Metall zu kriegen und das dann irgendwie auf die Platine zu zu leiten. Nur wenn du das da jetzt anfasst, ist das ja nicht so, dass diese Funktionalität dann auf einmal komplett weg ist.
Nee, sie wird einfach schlechter.
Aber sie wird schlechter, genau.
Ja, aber dafür ist sie ja jetzt durch dieses Design auch von vornherein schon mal besser, weil es eben nicht im Gerät versteckt ist. Dieses Thema kann man auch echt hin und her schieben.
Also ich glaube, dass sie das tatsächlich noch wirklich gut in den Griff kriegen werden und dass spätestens mit der nächsten Generation da keine Sau mehr drüber redet. Weil sie werden es einfach richtig gut machen. Aber im Augenblick ist es, glaube ich, ist es einfach ein Plus-Minus-Null.
Haben sich gut angestrengt für ihre Antenne, aber...
Machen wir mal dein Mikro ein bisschen runter. Ich habe hier noch ein bisschen...
Aber als Tethering-Phone ist es voll gut, weil da berührt man die Antennen ja nicht. Und dann ist alles super. Und ich glaube, dass dieses Update auf 401, was für eine ordentliche, besser verteilte Balkenanzeige sorgt, also was einem nicht mehr vorgaukelt, dass alles voll der Superempfang ist, was bei mir zu Hause definitiv nicht der Fall ist, das fand ich eigentlich noch fast am besten an der ganzen Sache, weil jetzt zeigt es wirklich den Empfang an, den man wirklich hat.
Man hat jetzt mal eine realistische Empfangsansage. Genau.
Also zu Hause habe ich jetzt so drei Balken oder zwei Balken, weil das ist wirklich nicht so toll mit dem Empfang und das zeigt jetzt auch an. Und vorher hatte ich wirklich einfach fünf Balken und du hast es nicht gemerkt.
Das hat doch Leo vom FSC K-Log schön rausgebuddelt, dass er das, ich weiß nicht ob mit einem 3G oder mit einem 3GS, hatten sie genau die gleiche Diskussion schon mal, dass er so, das ist halt der total schlechte Empfang, das Telefon. Und da haben sie auch gesagt, das ist ein reines Softwareproblem und haben wahrscheinlich diesen fehlerhaften Algorithmus für die Signalstärken-Anzeige eingebaut und plötzlich hattest du ständig fünf Balken, wahrscheinlich nach langer Diskussion mit dem AT&T-Management, dass das nicht eingestehen wollte, dass es so einen schlechten Empfang hat überall. Und jetzt haben sie wahrscheinlich einfach ins Repository geguckt, haben den alten Code wieder reingepappt und alles ist gut.
Könnte sein. So, die 10 Sekunden von jedem sind um.
Ja.
Ich finde, das gibt auch nicht so viel her. Ich meine, was soll man da drüber reden? Man kann festhalten, dieses Telefon funktioniert. Und man kann auch nicht gerade feststellen, dass es jetzt irgendwie so eine hohe Return-Rate gibt, sondern das große Problem beim iPhone 4 ist, für Apple genug zu bauen, um der Nachfrage Herr zu werden. Also in Amerika sind die immer noch in der Hälfte der Stores in der Regel gerade mal nicht verfügbar.
In Europa sind es auch immer noch grundsätzlich drei Wochen.
Echt?
Das Ding verkauft sich einfach mal wie Hotcake.
Ja und wie gesagt, also es ist bestimmt irgendwie ein Problem, aber ich...
Es scheint Probleme beim in der Hand halten und beim Wegstecken dieses Telefons zu geben, weil ich habe die ersten Besitzer eines iPhone 4, die ich gesehen habe, die so auf der Straße, die haben alle sehr rumgestikuliert, beim in die Tasche stecken.
Das ist halt neu, die wollen es halt nicht irgendwie.
Also man muss das irgendwie sehen, wenn sie einen iPhone 4 hatten. Ja der Witz kam jetzt vor Ort.
Ja, jetzt mal Facetime angemacht, ne?
Ja, wie ist denn das mit diesem Gyroskop? Damit habt ihr noch gar nichts, oder?
Ich ruf mal Witz und so an, mal gucken.
Also ich hab nämlich, ich hab hier so ein... Ein Facetime-Call? Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hat ja irgendjemand Lust, von euch das mal auszuprobieren. Ich hab mir so ein App gekauft, das heißt 360, das soll so für Panorama-Aufnahmen ganz geil sein, dass man das dann einfach nur so rumdreht und dass es dann eine Panorama-Aufnahme macht. Das funktioniert auf meinem 3GS überhaupt nicht. Also das ist, also das macht keine Panorama-Aufnahme. Das ist ein 3GS.
Da hat das kaputt?
Naja, das muss ich halt noch einschicken. Sobald das iPhone 4 da ist, schicke ich das ein.
Das ist einfach dauerhaft auf Silence oder wie?
Nee, das ist dauerhaft auf An.
Achso, ist doch gut.
Nee, ich will ja, ich find diesen Button ja super, der da dran ist, diesen Silence-Button. Ich will den ja auch haben. Und ich sitze manchmal in Meetings, und wenn da mittendrin das Telefon losklingelt, obwohl man vorher das ausgeschaltet hat, dann ist das doof. Und wenn man schläft und dann aufwacht, dann lachen die ja hin.
Die machen Sendung.
Die haben alle Airplane-Modus, so wie sich das gehört. Das hast du jetzt davon, haben sie bei uns gehört.
Airplane-Modus sagt ja nichts darüber aus, ob so WLAN angeschaltet ist.
Bestimmt.
Die kennen wahrscheinlich den Trick nicht, dass man dann trotzdem WLAN wieder anmachen kann.
Wahrscheinlich haben die einfach eine Time Capsule.
Er hat vorhin versucht anzurufen, aber da ging es irgendwie nicht. Aber das hat ja auch ein bisschen was mit meinem fehlenden Time Capsule unter Umständen zu tun. Die ist irgendwie braun. Das ist Antennagate hier. Aber echt.
Haben sie eigentlich die Garantiezeit jetzt massiv verlängert?
Irgendwann?
Bei der Time Capsule? Nicht offiziell, aber sie sind da sehr...
Ich dachte, sie hätten es irgendwann mal offiziell gemacht.
Wie sagt man so schön? Sie sind da, ja, weiß ich nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall, meine Time Capsule hat hier kurz vor der Sendung noch mal einen Schlappen gemacht, nachdem sie das vor zwei Wochen schon mal gemacht hat und ich dachte, sie hätte sich gefangen, aber das Ding ist irgendwie unstable. Ich glaube, das muss mal ein bisschen repariert werden.
Tja, ja, die Hardware.
Da kauft man sich so viel schickes Zeug und dann funktioniert es irgendwie nicht. Das freut doch den Anti-Apple-Fanboy. Solche gibt es ja auch, ne?
Habt ihr gejailbragt?
Es gibt ja Leute, die das irgendwie nicht mögen.
Ich hab meins gleich auf 402 hochgebrettert.
Ich auch.
Ich will ja die Bugs nicht haben. Ich will ja nicht das andere mich jailbreaken.
Aber ein finsterer Bug, ne?
Also ein Bug ist halt, um überhaupt aufs iPhone draufzukommen, über diesen Exploit im PDF-Viewer.
Und dann waren sie an der Sendbox.
Dann bist du der Mobile-User, dann kannst du ja erst mal noch gar nichts machen. Und dann müssen sie eine sogenannte Privilege-Escalation verursachen, damit sie vom Mobile-User zur Route werden. Und das haben sie gemacht über irgendwelche Out-of-Bounds-Parameter beim IOS-Surface oder so was. Oder NS-Surface, irgendwas mit Surface. Und da wohnen sie dann in Route und dann können sie dann ihren Züdiader installieren oder was auch immer.
Unglaublich.
Ich hab's ja gemacht.
Ausgerechnet im PDF-Viewer. Also das finde ich wirklich super hart.
Naja, der lädt ja auch Lips dazu. Das war wohl, was war das? Irgendwas mit TrueType-Fonts war es doch, oder?
Ach, dass da irgendein M-Bilded-Font drin war?
War da nicht was mit TTF, wie ist das Ding? Irgendwas mit Special-Fonts. Ich wurde lauter gemacht.
Ja, du hast uns lauter gemacht.
Entschuldigung, ich verfolge gerade.
Okay, jedenfalls kann es sein, dass es gar nicht deren eigener Code war. Aber es ist eigentlich auch total wurscht, wem der Code gehört, muss man halt checken.
Aber diese Privilege-Eskalation, die ist ja dann spätestens die, ja.
Ausgerechnet im PDF-Viewer. Nun haben sie sich irgendwie monatelang darüber ausgecast, wie unsicher doch Flash ist und was doch, Akromedia wollte ich jetzt schon was sagen, was Adobe so dann an Sicherheitsfailures hat, insbesondere durch ihr Akrobat und durch Bugs im PDF. Und dann ist ausgerechnet die PDF-Routine von Apple auch im Eimer. Das finde ich schon echt hart.
Komplexer Code halt.
Komplexer Code. Aber gut, ich meine, mit der Sicherheit ist das ja immer so eine Sache, aber ich finde es schon echt peinlich. Also der Bug, das ist schon echt peinlich.
Was ich ja viel peinlicher finde, ehrlich gesagt, ist, warum sie das jetzt nicht bei den alten Telefonen fixen.
Das finde ich auch eine Schweinerei.
Welchen alten Telefonen?
Na, es gibt hier 402, aber wenn du einen 2G hast oder einen alten iPod, auf dem kein iOS 4 drauf geht, hast du halt Pech gehabt.
Es gab nur ein Update fürs iPad, ne?
Es gab fürs iPad ein und fürs...
Das finde ich schon ein bisschen lame so.
Aber der Exploit geht auch bei den alten Versionen?
Der Exploit, klar, der ist uralt, ja.
Ich glaube, jedes iPhone, was jemals rausgekommen ist. 3.01, 3.02.
Und wo war Schluss fürs iPhone 1?
Bei 3...
also 3...
ja, 3.1, genau.
3.1.3.
Und dafür gibt es keine...
Das heißt, das alte iPhone und alle nicht auf 4.0 geupdateten iPhones sind weiterhin anfällig?
Nee, wenn du kein Update machst, dass es weiterhin anfällig ist, das ist ja logisch.
Das stimmt.
Dass du als Besitzer eines alten iPhones nicht mal eine Chance hast.
Das ist nicht okay.
Also das Lustige ist ja, dass sie jetzt über Sydia einen Patch für dieses PDF-Problem bereitstellen.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch nur halbschick, weil das ist ja ganz toll, dass sie sowas machen. Das würde ich ja auch cool finden, aber damit Sydia das machen kann, müssen sie ja grundsätzlich den ganzen Code-Signing-Check für das gesamte Phone ausschalten, sonst kannst du das ja nicht machen. Das heißt, du fixst einen Bug und machst damit aber eventuell tausend andere Sachen auf. Das heißt, jeder kann dir jetzt Code einspielen, ohne dass er signiert sein muss. Okay, das haben die jetzt ja auch umgangen, das ist ja nicht, aber ihr hättet trotzdem weiter gerne...
Man sollte sich das schon bewusst machen, dass dieses Code-Signing schon eigentlich einer der großen Fortschritte im Bereich Sicherheit. Aber gerade deswegen finde ich eben diesen...
Ob es nicht so groß wie sein sollte.
Ja, finde ich haarsträumend. Also, dass es wirklich da möglich ist. Was macht denn dieser PDF-Exploit eigentlich genau? Welche Tür macht denn der auf? Dadurch haben sie Code-Injection und dadurch lassen sie quasi im Webbrowser...
Kommen sie, kriegen sie eine Shell mit...
Das heißt aber im Webbrowser ist das Ding nochmal extra in so einem Jail drin.
Naja, nicht ganz. Ist der Mobile-User dann...
Also, ich meine, Entschuldigung, nicht Jail, Sandbox. Und da kommen sie auch nochmal raus.
Über den nächsten Bug. Sie nutzen ja zwei Bugs aus. Eigentlich noch einen dritten, ich weiß nicht, warum der nicht erwähnt wird, weil eigentlich dann, wenn sie jetzt Zydia installieren, also das geht ja so, aber Zydia legt ja dann erst den eigentlichen Unlock runter, der dann auch nochmal wahrscheinlich das Code Signing ausschaltet, oder? Und dann erst können sie das Unlocking abschalten, also das Quatsch, das Simlock sozusagen abschalten.
Achso, der Simlock ist ja eine ganz andere Nummer.
Ja, das muss ja auch erstmal möglich sein.
Ja, okay, das ist...
Das geht aber jetzt auch mit dem aktuellen Jailbreak-Media-Teil?
Na, der aktuelle Jailbreak-Media macht erstmal sozusagen auf, dann kannst du diese Zydia installieren, und über den Zydia installierst du den Unlock-Code. Ja, wahrscheinlich so. Da muss auch nochmal irgendein Bug sein. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob Apple den jetzt auch schon gleich mitgefixert eigentlich müssten.
Also im iPhone 3G sind sie wohl wieder drinnen, und ich glaube auch mit Unlock. Also auch bei 402 funktioniert noch, da funktioniert zwar dieser PDF-Exploit nicht mehr, aber der Jailbreak, der schon bei 401 funktioniert hat, funktioniert auch bei 402 noch. Also insofern vermute ich mal eher nicht. Also ich hab das ja auf dem 3GS gemacht mit dem Jailbreak. Das war sehr beeindruckend, muss ich sagen. Also man geht auf diese Seite drauf, hat dann diesen echt schick gemacht, so diesen Viso, als ob man hier einen Unlock macht, diesen Entriegelregler hat man dann für Jailbreak. Und das macht man und dann geht ein Fenster auf und dann steht ein Ladebalken drinnen.
Kannst du immer noch hingehen, dir geht noch die Seite.
Und wenn der Ladebalken voll ist, dann hast du, ohne Neustart, ohne alles, hast du dieses Sudia-Icon plötzlich und kannst loslegen. Also das ist schon gut ab. Beim iPad war ich nicht ganz so glücklich am Anfang. Also das iPad ist mir am Anfang ständig abgestürzt. Bis ich dann irgendwo erfahren habe, ja, weil das war noch Beta und weiss der Teufel was. Und ich dann auch dachte, schreib es doch irgendwo hin. Überall auf allen Webseiten steht, dass es mit allen Geräten geht. Und dann probier ich es mit dem iPad aus. Und erst durch kompliziertes Nachfragen und dadurch, dass ich ein paar tausend Follower habe, kriege ich raus, dass es beim iPad nur Beta ist. Ein paar Tage später ging es dann aber auch da genauso unproblematisch. Und jetzt habe ich die beiden Geräte getrailed-broken.
Okay, also wir raten weiterhin nicht zum Jailbrecken, es sei denn...
Ach, kann man schon mal machen.
Es gibt gute Gründe, die dafür sprechen.
Kann man machen.
Ist schon lustig.
Ja, was noch passiert? Es gab einen Shitload von neuer Hardware.
Und du hast schon fertig mit dem iPhone?
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, also war noch was? Also ich meine, wir müssen uns jetzt nicht nochmal hier über irgendwie Glas-Oberflächen und so weiter unterhalten und alle Specs runterrasseln, oder? Also ich hab jetzt nicht so richtig viele neue Erkenntnisse. Und es ist eigentlich schon so, also wer ein 3GS hat und überlegt jetzt einen Upgrade zu machen, das muss nicht unbedingt sein. Also es ist nicht so, dass man jetzt nicht mit einem 3GS auch arbeiten kann. Also jetzt vom Speed her ist es nicht so ein Schritt wie seinerzeit von 3G.
Aber ist schon nochmal ein Stück schneller.
Aber es hat natürlich auch mehr zu tun durch die höhere Auflösung. Ja, also unterm Strich würde ich sagen, ich stelle jetzt keinen nennenswerten Unterschied fest.
Jetzt mal eine blöde Frage. Rein nominell soll das ja exakt genauso schnell sein wie ein iPad. Das ist ja der selbe Prozessor, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Ich glaube, der ist nicht so hochgetaktet.
Ach so, der ist einfach ein bisschen niedlich. Also ist nicht so schnell wie ein iPad.
Ich hab jetzt noch nicht wirklich Benchmarks gemacht.
Dadurch muss er ja nicht so eine riesen Bildschirmfläche bearbeiten.
Na ja, aber da hat er doch andere Pixel. So viel mehr sind es ja auch nicht beim iPad.
Na, das iPhone hat irgendwie 78% der Pixel, die du hast.
Das ist in etwa absolut vergleichbar.
Also ich hab keine Ahnung, wie die Konstanzen sind. Ich meine, die Elektronik ist im iPhone natürlich viel, viel kleiner als im iPad. Da haben sie einfach mehr Platz. Aber ich hab jetzt auch noch keine wirklichen Vergleiche gemacht. Aber gefühlt bewegt sich das jetzt nicht in einem anderen Bereich.
Ich hab den Mandelbrot auf meinem 3GS gebenchmarkt und das iPhone 4 war ein bisschen schneller. Muss aber auch eigentlich viermal so viele Pixel berechnen. Also das ist schon flotter.
Ist das denn nicht tatsächlich die Grafik-Hardware, die da die andere ist?
Du musst trotzdem Dateien laden und Busse belegen.
Ja, und vor allem größere Dateien.
Und das ist das, was Computer heutzutage schnell macht. Also große Pipelines zu haben, um einfach auch die Daten schnell durchzukriegen. Das sind wirklich die Bottlenecks heutzutage. An der Stelle ist der A4 natürlich auch ein wichtiger Schritt für Apple gewesen, weil sie eben einfach sehr viel mehr auf einem Chip zusammenkriegen können, so wie sie es eben genau brauchen. Schon cool.
Wie seid ihr denn mit der Verarbeitung zufrieden?
Also ist es tatsächlich dieser große Schritt gegenüber dem 3GS oder ist es so?
Ich fand diesen Handschmeichler eigentlich ganz cool vorher. Vor allem jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr automatisch, ob es richtig rum ist. Ich ziehe es raus und jetzt muss ich immer erstmal diese Taste suchen. Und vorher wusste ich... Also es gibt 4 Stellen, wo es sein kann und ich muss halt erstmal das ganze Ding...
Aber der Homebutton ist geil. Der Homebutton ist so viel toller als bei dem alten.
Der ist clickiger, ja.
Der liegt doch ein bisschen flächiger auf, oder?
Das sind natürlich immer Produktionstoleranzen, aber das liegt jetzt gerade auf dem Tisch. Display, Kamera und Homebutton. Also sowieso die Buttons finde ich extrem cool. Kamera habe ich jetzt noch nicht so getestet, aber wir wollten ja eigentlich das Schluss machen mit dem iPhone, oder?
Nee, ich meine, wir werden uns noch was zu einfällig machen. Ich habe jetzt noch nicht so viel damit rumgespielt, aber das ist natürlich das Feature, dass du damit HD aufnehmen kannst. Jetzt erübrigt sich eigentlich jegliches mitnehmen, noch irgendeiner anderen Kamera.
Na ja, das ist jetzt echt super qualitär. Das eine ist ja so die Auflösung, mit der du aufnimmst, und das andere ist ja nochmal die Optik und der Chip und so weiter, was da überhaupt drankommt.
Ja gut, aber für mich ist jetzt, sagen wir mal...
Ich habe mir gleich mal ein Blu-ray-Movie in native iPhone-Auflösung gerippt und es rockenruhig.
Was kann das Teil eigentlich abspielen? Kann das auch 1080p abspielen?
Habe ich nicht probiert. Das ist jetzt ein 69x400-Gund.
Also ich habe gehört, dass es irgendwo im Nebensatz, weil es ja Gerüchte gibt, dass dieses ITV das nicht könne HD, dass das iPhone 4 HD könne. 1080.
Das ITV, das Gerät, von dem noch keiner weiß, ob es überhaupt jemals kommt, kann gucken, was es noch nie konnte?
Was das Alte konnte?
27p soll es können? Das heißt ja nicht, den Film mit 27p abzutreten?
Nee, kann kein 1080p, aber dass das iPhone 1080p könne.
Achso, ja, das iPhone kann das eigentlich. Stimmt, das kann das, aber ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Wer hätt ja auch auf Löse ist dann 720p.
1280 mal 720?
1280, also den ehemaligen Ruby hab ich ja auf 960 gerippt, damit es genau die Breite vom iPhone hat. Weil 1280 müsste ja dann schon wieder das runterrechnen. Aber da könnte man wahrscheinlich reinzoomen, dass das so ein Pfulskrieg ist. Ah gut, rippe ich nochmal.
Kann man da eigentlich ein Beamer so nicht schließen?
Also genau genommen ist das iPhone 640p, weil das ist ja die Auflösung. Also nur das ist 640p in dem Sinne so nicht...
Ja, so hab ich's jetzt gerippt, 640p.
Richtig, so direkt für den Bildschirm. Und, glaubt ihr, das war's?
Ich wollt mal gucken, sieht cool aus. 1,8 Gigabyte groß. Und es ist eine bessere Auflösung als DVD auf einem iPhone.
Tja, das iPhone. So viel dazu. Wir finden es toll, aber ich sag noch mal, wer überlegt sich eins zu kaufen und nicht zwingend an diesen Features großes Interesse hat wie tollere Kamera und Flash.
Ne, Retina Display, das entscheidet alles.
Ja, das ist gut, aber das ist nicht so, dass du das unbedingt brauchst.
Doch. Warum?
Brauchen nicht, aber...
Also klar, wenn man viel damit liest, also wenn man eh, ich meine, wenn man der totale iPhone-Junk ist, dann braucht man das eh. Aber wenn man jetzt, sagen wir mal, ein rational denkender Mensch ist, der sagt, muss ich dieses Telefon wirklich haben? Ich muss sagen, es macht jetzt...
Also wenn es darum geht, im Urlaub zu fahren oder...
Das ist so wie damals, als irgendwie Stereo erfunden wurde, hätte man auch sagen können, naja, so Stereo bringt jetzt nicht so viel Neues, außer irgendwie den Kanal zweimal.
Ne, das ist schon ein ganz anderes Hören, aber du meinst hier ist es ein ganz anderes Ding.
Also ich muss auch sagen, echt, ich kann das jetzt, das iPhone, das erste Mal ernsthaft für so browsen und so benutzen, weil das halt irgendwie mit diesem Display, siehst du halt einfach viel mehr, besser, schneller, höher, weiter.
Wobei dafür macht auch die Geschwindigkeit eine Menge aus, oder?
Aber das zusammen, so die Kombination, hat das jetzt echt mal zu einem richtigen Browsing-Device für mich gemacht, weil auf dem 3G hatte ich damit überhaupt keinen Spaß, weder mit dem Display noch mit der Performance.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und das ist schon eine richtige Browser-Maschine.
Ich muss mal sagen, die Auflösung ist jetzt da angekommen, wo sie hingehört.
Ich will sowieso drein, der PI auf allen Devices jetzt, nie wieder ohne.
Ich hätte das gerne auf dem iPad hätte ich das gerne.
Ich hätte das auch gerne auf dem Macbook Pro und auf dem iMac, also ich will keine Pixel mehr sehen.
Ob sie das bringen können auf dem iPad, was wäre das dann, 2048 x 1536.
Locker.
Das ist ja hier schon fast die Auflösung von meinem...
Von IBM gibt es 15 Zoll-Geräte mit 1920.
Das ist eine höhere Auflösung als so ein 20 Zoll-Display hat oder sowas, das ist schon...
Wenn die sehr groß sind, kriegen die das auch in jeder anderen Größe hin. Ist ja nur ein bisschen teurer.
Ah, es ist heller. Das iPhone.
Und das hat einen geilen Kontrast. Also so ein Kinofilm, wenn da schwarz ist im Kinofilm, dann siehst du nicht auf so einen grau, sondern es ist dann wirklich schwarz.
Also wer viel Film guckt, für den ist das definitiv auch ein Thema. Vor allem wenn man es so tagsüber benutzt.
Auch Bilder, die haben einfach einen viel besseren Kontrast. Also Bilder vergleichs hab ich gemacht, alte iPhone, neue iPhone, gleiche Bild nebeneinander. Das sah auf dem iPhone 4 viel besser aus.
Das von der Kamera oder einfach nur dasselbe Bild angezeigt hat?
Dasselbe Bild, sogar die Bilder wurden aufgenommen von dem 3GS, weil die waren ja alle schon drauf auf meinem Phone. Und weil ich ja das Backup aufs Vira dann rüber gespielt hab, und hab ich auf beiden betrachtet. Also es waren noch nicht mal neue Bilder mit dem neuen iPhone, sondern noch alte.
Wie habt ihr denn das Backup rüber gespielt?
Na, iTunes. Gesagt hier.
Genau, weil den hab ich nämlich auch gehört. Der ist jetzt aber auch für eine Sicherheitslücke ausgenutzt worden, oder?
Was ist denn für ein Trick?
Hab ich uns falsch gemacht?
Ja, das...
Und der SMS war alle weg?
Wenn du schonmal so ein Upgrade gemacht hast, dann ist dir vielleicht aufgefallen, nachdem du dann aufs neue Gerät umgezogen bist mit deinem Backup, dass dann aber alle deine WLAN-Passwörter weg waren. Benutzt du Encrypted Backup auf deinem Rechner?
Gerade, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaub nicht.
Dann waren deine WLAN-Passwörter weg.
Nee, die haben das jetzt gefixt bei dem iOS 4.
Nee, das hat ja gar nichts mit iOS 4 zu tun.
Also jetzt waren sie nicht weg. Soll ich gucken, ob es mit Krypto war oder ohne?
Listen. Listen. Also, was das iPhone macht, ist, die Keychain im iPhone wird mit dem Hardware-Key verschlüsselt. Das machen sie dann sozusagen auch mit ihrer eingebauten Hardware-Krypto, die sie ohnehin für alles verwenden. Das ist ja eh alles schon gekryptet und löschen des Telefons heißt einfach Key wegschmeißen. Und sie benutzen aber auch dasselbe Ding für die Keychain. Wenn du jetzt ein Backup machst, dann übertragen sie zwar die Keychain, aber... Den, äh, erstens den Schlüssel nicht und zweitens... Rechnen sie das halt auch nicht um. Wenn du allerdings auf deinem iTunes anklickst, dass das Backup entkryptet ist mit einem Passwort und du da halt noch ein neues Passwort angibst, dann tun sie das jetzt. Das heißt, dann wird die Keychain aus dem Hardware-Schlüssel raus entschlüsselt und nochmal mit diesem Backup-Passwort verschlüsselt. Und wenn du halt jetzt ein iPhone 4 kriegst und du hast vorher ein 3GS und du machst dieses Backup-Krypto an auf deinem iTunes, dann kannst du danach das ganze Backup umziehen, wie sowieso, auf das neue Gerät. Aber du behältst halt auch deine ganze Keychain und damit eben auch deine ganzen Autofill-Passwörter im Safari und deine ganzen WLAN-Passwörter.
Also ich hab dieses Backup gemacht, musste meine WLAN-Passwörter nicht neu eingeben. Und ich glaub, ich hab dieses Krypto nicht neu eingezogen. Aber ich könnte dann nachgucken.
Wenn du das Krypto nicht an hast, dann sind deine Passwörter nicht umgezogen. Sind sie nicht.
Ich könnte schwören, dass ich das irgendwann mal ausgemacht hab.
Also so als Tipp, wenn man umzieht von einem Gerät aufs andere, vorher Backup-Verschlüsselung einschalten, dann solltet ihr eure Passwörter behalten. Weil das nervt ihr schon extrem. Dass ihr jedes Mal alle WLAN-Passwörter vergesst.
Ich hab Clean-Install gemacht.
Ich würd auch gerne mal Clean-Install machen, aber dann wären meine SMS weg. Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Er macht einen Jailbreak, dann kannst du die SQLite-Datbank einspielen.
Und danach auch wieder auf ein normales Ding zurückspielen ohne Jailbreak?
Die schickst du dir alle nacheinander.
Wahrscheinlich. Warum eigentlich nicht? Du packst einfach...
Wenn ich das vom letzten Jahr fortsetzen will, brauch ich doch meine Daten.
Du wechselst die SQLite-Datbank aus, schiebst sie unten drunter, machst einen Backup, dann ist ein Backup drin, machst einen Restore danach und dann sollte eigentlich alles, dann sollte ja deine SMS da sein ohne Jailbreak.
Wenn man die denn so dann runterschieben kann, ohne...
Das geht entspannt, das hab ich, das war's früher mal.
Ohne Jailbreak dann danach.
Also ich hab ja auch schon...
Hier, Encrypt iPhone Backup, ist nicht aktiviert bei mir.
Du musstest doch eben gerade auch das WLAN-Passwort eingeben hier von Timme.
Nee, das war, als ich auf die Extreme drauf wollte. Als er dann meinte, ich soll auf die andere gehen, hat er mich nicht nochmal gefragt. Obwohl doch, musste ich. Aber du hattest ja früher hier auch eine andere Station, da hieß die doch anders. Aber mir zu Hause zum Beispiel musste ich definitiv nicht mein WLAN-Passwort eingeben.
Das Public-Passwort hast du hier nochmal eingegeben vorhin.
Ja, wie lange gibt es denn die Station schon?
Das hat sich auf jeden Fall nicht geändert.
Da hat es da vorher hier ewige Blumenkraft oder so was.
Das ist schon sehr lange her, Dennis.
Da warst du zwischendurch schon mal hier.
Aber meine Station...
Hier musst du es doch auch nicht eingeben.
Geh'r dich doch nicht dagegen, nimm es an!
Du hast dein Passwort nur eingegeben.
Nimm es an, du hast dein Passwort... Da ist noch ein Spoon. Gestern haben wir Matrix geguckt, das hilft.
Ja, später. Ich muss es nochmal checken, kann sein, dass ich dir doch eingegeben habe. Das kann natürlich sein.
Du hast es eingegeben, weil es ist einfach so, wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, dass die Keychain wird mit dem Hardware-Schlüssel. Denn, wenn es anders wäre, Dennis, dann hättest du ein Keychain-Passwort auf dem iPhone und du hast kein Keychain-Passwort. Auf dem Mac hast du sowas, aber auf dem iPhone you don't. Und damit es trotzdem verschlüsselt ist, benutzen sie halt DOS. So, jetzt können wir aber auch, glaube ich, dieses iPhone Thema...
Das heißt, ich könnte jetzt auch die einfach mal Encrypt iPhone Backup einstellen.
Ja, aber dann sind deine Passwörter nicht.
Gibt da wieder irgendwelche Leute, die dann meinen, dass sie dann theoretisch in der Lage sind?
Ich hab bei Heisei eine spannende Sache gelesen. Und zwar ist das, die haben... Es gibt jetzt eine neue Pflicht in Amerika, dass dein Autoreifen muss einen kleinen Sender eingebaut haben. Und zwar, der immer den Reifendruck an den Bordcomputer übermittelt. Und dieser kleine Empfänger, dieser kleine Sender, hat eine eindeutige ID. Und über die kannst du im Vorbeifahren ein Auto identifizieren. Weil er eine einmalige ID hat. Das nächste Ding ist, dass dieser Versand, also dieser Datenversand zwischen Autoreifen und Bordcomputer, ist unverschlüsselt.
Da haben sie dann die Autos geknackt.
Und der Bordcomputer, sie haben es geschafft, ihm falsche Daten unterzujubeln, dass er gedacht hat, dass der Reifendruck plötzlich weg wäre.
Was dafür sorgt, dass das Auto anhält?
Aber ich wette, dass es möglich ist, darüber einen Buffer-Overflow reinzupappen. Zumindest bei einigen Geräten. Also bestimmt nicht bei jedem Hersteller, aber bei einigen Herstellern wird das bestimmt möglich sein. Man kann von außen...
Da kannst du jetzt ja überlegen, ob du ein Auto haben willst oder nicht.
Das ist Pflicht. In Amerika ist es Pflicht und in Europa wird es ab nächsten Jahr Pflicht. Autos dürfen nicht mehr ohne das ausgeliefert werden.
Okay, aber das war jetzt totally unrelated, oder?
Ich find's einfach nur spannend wegen der Sicherheitslücken.
Okay, obwohl wir jetzt eigentlich nochmal weg wollten, ich hab noch einen Nachtrag. Und zwar... Ich hatte bei meinem 3GS übrigens ein... Ich war ja in Kanada. Und dann hatte ich einen... einen Bildschirm-Fehler auf meinem 3GS Bildschirm. Da war irgendwie so helle Stellen. Was so bei alten Displays normalerweise...
Jetzt kommt deine Apple Store-Geschichte.
Genau, und ich hab dann einfach mal ausprobiert, wie es denn so ist, weil ich hatte vorher schon eigentlich... Ich hatte noch Garantie und hab dann schon mal hier online meine Seriennummer eingetragen und dann meinte sie, ja, komm vorbei, können wir dir helfen. Was ja News ist, weil mein 3GS ist ja noch so ein Italien-Phone. Und nun ging ja diese Nachricht, dass sie das tun würden, schon länger rum und dann bin ich aber nicht dazu gekommen, nach Hamburg zu fahren, also war ich dann in Kanada. Gibt es wieder Blinkenlites? Nein, gibt es keinen Blinkenlites.
Komm, irgendwas läuft noch da hinten. Das wirkt schon raus.
Ich kann dazu keine näheren Angaben machen. Auf jeden Fall bin ich da rein und hab mich, ich hab mal wieder den Apple Store Test gemacht, weil, das war wirklich unglaublich. Ich hab, genau, ich muss nämlich noch was zum Mobile erzählen, aber jetzt erstmal zu dieser Reparaturgeschichte. Sie haben mir einfach das Display auch in Kanada getauscht. Das heißt, du kannst mit deinem iPhone jetzt worldwide Service machen. Ich hab ihn explizit gefragt, seit wann sich das geändert hat und da meinte er vor einem Monat, also jetzt vor zweien. Sprich, wer ein iPhone hat, das aus einem anderen Land kommt, kann davon ausgehen, jetzt bei jedem Apple Store weltweit sich das Ding fixen zu lassen, solange er noch Garantie oder Apple Care drauf hat. Schon mal eine gute Nachricht ist. Da war ich in diesem Laden und das ist ein relativ kleiner Apple Store, aber das war einfach mal unfassbar, was in diesem Laden los war. Also da standen dann an jedem Tisch so gefühlt 30 Leute, die alle nur kaufen, kaufen, kaufen, quer übers Gesicht geschrieben hatten. Also das ist einfach unfassbar, was dafür eine Kaufthermik herrschte. Und auch jeder andere Apple Store, den ich noch gesehen habe, war irgendwie ähnlich. Und da dachte ich mir so mal gucken, ob man die Leute hier auch mal so ein bisschen, ob ich denn nicht mal ein Problem haben könnte, oder vielmehr ein, dass ich ein Problem habe. Weil ich hab nämlich jetzt nochmal Mobile Me gekauft, nachdem ich das schon mal getan hatte und ein bisschen enttäuscht, weil ich es nicht benutzen konnte, weggegangen bin.
Von Mobile Me.
Und jetzt hab ich das aber nochmal gemacht, weil Apple nämlich jetzt endlich das Feature angekündigt hat, was ich schon seit Langem haben wollte, dass du nämlich Kalender sharen kannst mit anderen Leuten und zwar Read-Freit und nicht nur Read-Only. Brauche ich einfach, um Planungen zu machen. Familienplanung. Und kann man dann so eintragen, wo die Kinder kommen und so. Haha.
Kommt noch eins?
Nein. Das war ein Witz, Entschuldigung. Ich mach jetzt keine Witze mehr.
Schaffst eh nicht. Und wenn nicht, dann machen wir die.
Jaja, da warte ich ja drauf.
Also, erstmal diese Kalender-Beta bietet dir das Feature, deswegen hab ich das gekauft. So, dann hab ich angefangen, meine Rechner miteinander zu sinken. Und es war die Hölle. Das hat einfach mal auf einem Level nicht funktioniert, dass ich wahnsinnig geworden wurde. Also, das fing damit an, dass er mir dann irgendwie wahllos größere Teilmengen meines Adressbuchs dupliziert hat. Also, manche Einträge waren einfach nur einmal da, wie sich das gehört. Manche waren fünfmal da und manche waren dreißigmal da.
Der Kalender ist kaputt. Bei mir auch.
Im Kalender hatte ich das auch.
Im Mai und Juni für jeden Tag habe ich so ein Pünktchen und wenn ich klicke, dann ist da nichts. Aber nur im Mai und im Juni. Ich dachte schon, das wären die iPhone, iOS 4-Betas.
Benutzst du auch Bobami oder was?
Ich rede aber jetzt von Bobami.
Ja, und Kalendern aber.
Naja, und dem SYNCHEN.
Aber das wären gerade Adressbucheinträge.
Okay. Es war ja an sich alles in Ordnung. Nur in dem Moment, wo ich angefangen habe, meinen Rechner untereinander zu SYNCHEN. Und dann bin ich halt wirklich in diesen Apple Store reingegangen, hab gesagt, okay, jetzt weiß ich nicht weiter, weil ich hab das irgendwie alles nicht mehr in den Griff gekriegt. Und jetzt lass ich mir mal so helfen. Wie so ein Mensch, der nicht mehr weiter weiß und der nicht weiß, wie er das so richtig bedienen und klicken soll, weil ich war einfach überfordert. Genau, in Kanada. Und ich muss sagen, das war unglaublich. Also ich bin an diesem Genius Bar dann relativ schnell rangekommen, obwohl da so viel los war. Und der Typ saß mit mir geschlagene zwei Stunden. Ich saß zwei Stunden an diesem Bar und der hat irgendwie mit mir dieses Problem durchgegangen. Und wir haben irgendwie das ganze iPhone noch mal neu aufgesetzt und irgendwie Backups eingespielt und wieder drauf und restore und nochmal ausprobiert und mit clean und dann nochmal ausprobiert und nochmal ausprobiert. So wie so eine längere Reparatur-Hug-Session so im Club, wie man das so machen würde.
Und das Backup immer auf deinen Rechner oder wie?
Jaja, alles nur mit meinem Rechner anzuhauen. Aber sozusagen alle Szenarien, wie kriegt man die? Ich hab das Telefon einfach nicht gesynkt bekommen. Der hat echt schon so größere Probleme gewittert. Es ging dann am Ende. Aber in der Folge war es der totale Terror. Also wenn man wirklich mehrere Rechner miteinander synkt, dann ist das alles nicht astrein. Man muss auf jeden Fall gut drauf achten, was man da tut. Sonst führt das zum Desaster. Ich kann Mobile Mi immer noch nicht so richtig empfehlen, obwohl dieses Find My iPhone ist ja cool. Was ich mich aber gefragt habe in dem Zusammenhang ist, warum gibt es eigentlich nicht Find My Laptop?
Die umgekehrte Variante?
Nee, einfach warum kann er nicht mein Laptop finden? Also du kannst das iPad finden, du kannst das iPhone finden. Wahrscheinlich kannst du auch iPod Touches finden, das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert. Aber warum gibt es das nicht auch für Laptops?
Interessante Frage.
Ich meine, die haben doch jetzt alle Core Location und so?
Apple.
Und es gibt jetzt drei große BSSID zu Geolocation und Cell Tower Datenbanken in der Welt, da wird es aber möglich sein.
Was ist die dritte, die von Apple?
Das alle?
Ich hab zu Hause auch eine.
Besteht bisher aus nur einem Gerät.
Ich meine, die machen ja nichts weiter als irgendwie Daten, aber das kann eigentlich jeder.
Wobei ich hab eine Zeit lang tatsächlich auch... Ich hab das auch selber gemacht. Ich hab selber angefangen, so eine Datenbank aufzubauen.
Das ist doch evil.
Ich hatte einen Datenschutz.
Ich wollte mal ein bisschen evil sein.
Ich finde ja das vollkommen, also ich finde es eigentlich evil, dass sie die Datenbanken nicht öffentlich zugänglich machen. Also wenn sie das schon alles sammeln und dann nur für sich behalten, das finde ich eigentlich kacke. Aber so Access Points auf Geolocations-Mappen, wenn sie das schon machen, also finde ich ja an sich gar nicht so schlecht.
Sollten wir vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären, was da überhaupt passiert ist. Also Apple hat jetzt mit iOS 4 auf eigene Server umgestellt. Und jedes iPhone... Also mit dem 3.2 sozusagen.
Jetzt nutzen sie nicht mehr die Google-Daten, nicht mehr die Skyhawk-Datenbanken. Oder wie?
Sondern ihre eigenen.
Genau, ihre eigenen.
Moment, aber beim iPad... Okay, beim iPad benutzen sie nur die, aber nur beim iPhone wird doch gesammelt, oder?
Was heißt gesammelt?
Naja, zur Ordnung... Nur das iPhone hat GPS. Ach nee, stimmt nicht.
Das 3G hat GPS.
Das ist doch auch GPS.
Die Frage ist, ob sie vorher auch schon gesammelt haben, um ihre Datenbank aufzubauen. Oder haben sie die von Skyhawk genommen und irgendwie...
Ich nehme an, dass sie aufgebaut haben werden.
Ich vermute mal, dass sie da schon...
Ich dachte ja damals schon mal, dass sie sowieso an Skyhawk Wireless kein Cent bezahlen, sondern denen sagen, hört mal zu, gebt uns mal eure Datenbank und wir geben euch noch mehr Daten und bessere Daten dafür.
Speichern die aber auch zwischen.
Ja klar, aber so haben sie erstmal das Ding...
Skyhawk hat ja am Anfang die Ballungsräume in den USA halt noch mit Auto abgefahren. Und als die ihr erstes iPhone rausgebracht haben, mit ohne GPS und halt aber natürlich Location-Service haben wollten, kam die halt so auf den Plan, hallo, wir können euer Location-Problem lösen.
Aber ich war im Club, hab mein 2G-iPhone gehabt, hab das gescheitert und der hat sofort gewusst, wo ich bin.
Aber du hast ja dein iPhone auch irgendwie viel später noch erst gehabt, also nach dem Launch.
Ja schon, aber da war Skyhawk, war ja das bestimmt nicht durch Berlin gefahren.
Nee, natürlich nicht, aber die hatten dann ja schon irgendwie erstmal sozusagen Start-Setup und dann selbstlernt die Cloud hier irgendwie den Rest machen lassen. Also da fährt jetzt keiner mehr mit dem Auto rum.
Ich hab mir sagen lassen, dass Google so mit dem Auto rumgefahren ist.
Wenn du schon unterwegs bist, Fotos zu machen, dann kannst du natürlich auch Access Points machen, aber das korrigiert sich automatisch. Also ich meine, wir haben jetzt irgendwie von einem Büro ins andere ein Access Point getragen, und haben jetzt mal Spaß und teilweise geguckt.
Wie lange das dauert.
Was macht denn jetzt hier Core Location und so weiter oder Google besser gesagt in dem Fall. Und die merken dann halt irgendwie im Moment, da stimmt irgendwas, und nehmen dann halt irgendwie Cell Towers oder so und malen dich dann halt mit einem größeren Radius an die richtige Stelle und...
Was war denn das? Irgendeinen Lokalisierungsdienst, entweder war es Firefox, ich weiß nicht welche Datenbank die benutzen oder es war hier Core Location, hat mein MacBook mal falsch lokalisiert, weil der Hotspot umgezogen ist. Also die haben mich beim alten Hotspot, bei der alten Location vermutet nicht bei einer neuen.
Aber wie gesagt...
Aber auch ein Dreivierteljahr nach Umzug.
Aber die schlafen ja auch nicht, die Jungs, die werden da auch einfach so das Maximum was geht, mit den Self-Healing-Capabilities und so. Also das ist halt die...
Jaja, klar.
Du hast einfach Millionen und Abermillionen Reporter von Access-Point-IDs und Cell-Tower-IDs.
Was ich ja daran so krass finde, dass die Netzwerk-Provider, also die Telcos, die hatten ja diese Daten, wo sich ihre Masten befinden, schon immer. Und die haben sie ja verkloppt, wenn du wolltest. Und die haben, ich glaube, pro Anfrage 20 Cent genommen, das war so in dem Dreh. Also es war wirklich absurde Gelder, die dafür durchgegangen sind. Und hätten die das mal billig gemacht für solche Läden, dann wäre vermutlich nie eine Konkurrenz entstanden. Aber wer solche Preise nimmt, ich glaube, wahrscheinlich haben sie niemals ernsthaft Geld damit verdient, mit diesen Lokalisierungsdaten.
Ja, also ich finde es jetzt nochmal wertvoll, zusammenzufassen, damit wir nicht auch immer so Gespräche führen, indem wir alles wissen, schon voraussetzen, was jetzt eigentlich derzeit tatsächlich getan wird mit dem iPhone. Also dieses Gerät übermittelt permanent, anonym, die Informationen, welche WLANs an welchem Ort gesehen werden.
Dein Mac garantiert auch mit Call Location.
Wobei Call Location bringt nicht so unglaublich viel, weil er hat kein GPS.
Ist doch egal, du hast ja trotzdem irgendwie fünf Basestations, die du kennst, die du im System hast. Dann kommt vielleicht einer dazu und so. Du sendest ja jemanden, hier hast du 20 Access Points in deiner Liste, ja. Und natürlich schickt er die einfach mit, wenn er da fragt.
Du schickst immer die ganze Liste hoch, und der Server sagt, wo du bist, und wenn ein neuer kommt, wirst du mit hochgeschickt. Und dann weiß er schon, wo der neue jetzt lokalisiert ist.
Ja, aber ich nehme an, das wird ja eher unscharfer. Also hin und wieder musst du ja mal ein GPS-Signal dazwischen packen, weil ansonsten, wenn sich die ganze Infrastruktur so ein bisschen verschiebt.
Das machen ja die iPhones, die jetzt hier liegen. Unsere iPhones schicken die gleichen Stationen hoch, und dadurch wissen sie...
Aber dein Rechner, die nehmen sie auch mit auf, weil wenn irgendwie fünf Leute Axis Point A gesehen haben und fünf Leute auch als plötzlich Axis Point B gesehen haben, der aber vor einem halben Jahr woanders stand, dann werden sie da schon irgendwelche Heuristiken drüber bilden.
Ich frag mich ja bis heute, warum ich in Spotlight mich danach suchen kann, wo ich ein Dokument geschrieben habe. Warum ist das nicht als Funktion gibt das? Ich meine, die Information haben sie ja mittlerweile. Mit Call Location bräuchten sie bloß ein Dokument mit Aktualisierungsdatum reinzupappen, wo ist das geschrieben worden? Ja, aber ich hätte es gerne auf der Tilesystem-Ebene.
Natürlich, mehr Metadaten. Naja, ich glaube trotzdem, dass das, was sie jetzt mit dem iPhone sammeln, für sie noch mal eine sehr viel wertvollere Information ist. Weil sie natürlich da auch alles in Perspektive kriegen können. Weil mit dem WLAN, ich glaube, da kann man mathematisch sicherlich eine Menge rausholen, aber irgendwo bleibt es unscharfer Brei. Und wenn du halt da so ein paar ganz stabile Zuordnungen hast, mit genau an dieser Stelle habe ich geguckt und habe das gesehen.
Ja, aber wenn du halt sagst, hier zum Beispiel 20 Leute haben...
Keyframe ist das sozusagen.
Ja, genau, aber wenn 20 iPhone-User jetzt hier deine Blumebene, äh Metaebene hier mit GPS-Fix und so weiter gesehen haben und jetzt kommen noch 23 Laptops dazu und so weiter, das kommt dann halt irgendwie schon alles zusammen so. Das machen die schon.
Jetzt weißt du auch, warum sie diese Datenbank nicht erfüllen.
Weil?
Weil du dann einfach mal nach Netzwerknamen suchen kannst und dann sofort weißt, wo die sind.
Die Netzwerke sind doch scheißegal, wo die sind. Aber die wissen sogar, wo Huckel ist.
Nach SSR.
Durch sein Telefon.
Und durch meinen Rechner.
Ja, Apple, aber dann nicht jeder.
Und willst du die Daten auch draußen haben?
Nee, also die Reporter-Client soll natürlich schön anonym da drin bleiben, aber die Access Points und Geolocations, warum nicht? Jeder soll hier Open Source Apps mit geiler Geolokalisierung machen, auch ohne GPS und so weiter.
Aber das ist wirklich eine gute Idee.
Das kannst du auf dem Streetmap machen, dann musst du einfach in den Pool schreiben.
Aber der Datenschutz.
Aber in der Stadt ist halt zum Beispiel...
Alles mitmachen.
Er, dein Teilnehmer. In der Stadt ist auch zum Beispiel über BSS-IDs oft viel genauer als mit GPS, weil man ist halt nicht die ganze Zeit unter freiem Himmel. Also es reicht ja schon, wenn du im Café unter einem Sonnenschaum sitzt und schon ist dein GPS fix hier irgendwie way off. Und mit BSS-IDs kriegst du manchmal super präzise hin. Also im Club haben wir das ja auch eine Zeit lang ausprobiert und er pointet dich nur mit WLAN einfach direkt auf dem Hinterhof.
Also ich hab das ja beim iPhone 2G, hatte ich ja noch lange genug keinen GPS und die Lokalisierung war zwischen oh Gott, was ist das für eine Scheiße, bis hin zu krass, das ist ja auf dem Meter genau. Also da kann man schon gute Ergebnisse mit drüber erzählen. Das stimmt schon.
Das war damals schon ganz schön scary, als das rauskam.
Ja, das war schon echt okay.
Also als ich startete so ein Gerät, klickst du so lokalisieren und dann sagst du dir plötzlich wo du bist und dann denkst du so wer guckt mir jetzt hier? Wo ist der Typ, der mich hier sieht? Das war schon witzig. Heutzutage, ja, hat man sich halt rangewöhnt.
Heutzutage kriegt man sich auch immer erst ein bisschen dran gewöhnen.
Ja, so viel dazu.
So viel dazu.
Ich hab noch ein kleines App von dem heute, so ein kleines Mac-Programm, was mir sehr gefallen hat, als ich es das erste Mal gesehen habe. Und heute ist die Public Beta rausgekommen.
Wir dürfen jetzt beim machen, also Werbung?
Ja, ich mach jetzt einfach Werbung. Also ich hab da jetzt zwar von nichts. Ich fand das App wirklich sehr schick gemacht einfach. Das heißt alarms.app.com und das ist so... Fürs iPhone. Nee, fürs Mac. Nur fürs Mac. Nicht fürs iPhone.
Das gab's doch vorher auch schon für was anderes.
Nein, dann sprechen wir von was anderem.
Nee, das gibt's vorher.
Dann sprechen wir von was anderem.
Das hast du heute doch erst entdeckt, Leute.
Das ist heute erst rausgekommen. Das ist heute erst raus.
Bitte nicht immer alle durcheinander.
Also das ist sowieso kompliziert zu erklären. Also wenn man so ein Mensch ist, der gerne ein bisschen vor sich hin prokrastiniert, wie wir das glaube ich alle tun, dann doch lieber 20 Minuten später machen und so, dass man, also man weiß, ich müsste jetzt eigentlich jetzt an diesem Dokument arbeiten, aber ich mach das erst mal in 20 Minuten, dann nimmt man das Dokument, zieht das auf so eine eigene Menüleiste oben drauf und dann fährt so eine Leiste raus, so eine Zeitleiste.
Ist das von einem Schweizer?
Genau.
Hab ich doch schon seit zwei Wochen. Das heißt jetzt Alarms, das hieß aber dann noch anders.
Das hieß irgendwie Timeline oder so was. Jaja, das heißt jetzt Alarms. Und dann schmeißt du es einfach rein an der richtigen Stelle, sozusagen in 20 Minuten und dann gibt er dir 20 Minuten Ruhe und dann meldet er sich wieder. Ich finde den Effekt so geil, wie der gesamte Bildschirm runterfährt und dann nur oben dieses Fenster drin ist.
Ja, der macht schon schicke, gulle Geschichten.
Der ganze Bildschirm?
Ja, es ist so ein bisschen so wie bei Front Row.
Da hast du es ja schon. Achso, es ist jetzt schon richtig rausgekommen heute, ja?
Nee, es ist so als Beta.
Preview heißt es da. Don't miss it.
Und dann macht man einen neuen Eintrag da oben.
The thing started with Alarms soll ich machen und jetzt?
Jetzt hast du gelöscht. Da klickst du irgendwo rein, musst du rechts klicken oder irgendwas machen, damit du einen neuen Eintrag erzeugst. Genau, da schreibst du irgendwas rein, was du machen willst.
Genau, Max unterbrechen.
Schiebst du es in 5 Minuten irgendwie hin, kannst du es jetzt seitwärts gegen schieben, wann es sein soll, genau.
Ah, Max unterbrechen jetzt in 2 Minuten, in 7 Minuten, 6 Minuten. Was ist denn das für eine komische Auflösung? Achso, der macht das relativ zu meiner Maus-Cursor-Größe. Pfiffig und ist auch genauso scheiße aufgelöst wie mein Maus-Cursor.
Das ist dein Maus-Cursor. Wahrscheinlich denn, wenn du klebst das an dein Maus-Cursor, ist ja furchtbar.
Ich mach jetzt mal in einer Minute, damit ich auch sehe, was da passiert.
Und du kannst ja auch, also du kannst entweder so eine Nutrize anlegen oder du schmeißt einfach ein Dokument oder eine Mail oder eine WWW-Adresse rein und die gehen dann auch per Klick auf wieder, wenn es soweit ist.
Dabei hab ich mir gesagt, da sollen wir eigentlich die Pause-Funktion in Timelock einbauen. Timelock ist das andere Tool, was hat übrigens. Man kann also nicht Timelock hießen haben, die vorige Version von Timeline.
Timeline, sagt er.
Ich weiß allerdings nicht mehr, wie es hieß. Jetzt heißt es auf jeden Fall Alarms.
Und Timelock ist so für Leute, die so auf Stundenbasis arbeiten oder was?
Minutensklaverei.
Machst du das? Echt, du rechnest nach Minuten ab? Auch für den Podcast?
Soll ich?
Nee, sag mal nicht so viel jetzt.
Ich hab ja gehört, dass wir schon voll reich sind, oder? Weil du flatterst ja.
Nee, ich bin voll reich. Wie heißen wir?
Kommt noch mal durcheinander, ich sag immer Mobile wie, wenn ich Mobile Max sagen soll und andersrum.
Ja, voll reich sind wir jetzt.
Dann will ich jetzt auch kurz Werbung machen, wenn wir schon mal dabei sind. Das war ein Kuppel von mir.
Sind wir fertig mit dem Tool? Aber es hat ja noch gar nichts getan.
Das Tool ist fertig.
Du kannst ja einfach ändern auf Dennis unterbrechen, dann haust du auch hin mit der Minute.
Das hat oben geblinkt, du hast nicht richtig geguckt.
Das ist in roter Kreise.
Ne, ne, 21.05 heißt es da. Das ist jetzt in 20 Sekunden.
Ich bin immer gespannt.
Ja, lass mich mal Werbung machen, schnell 20 Sekunden lang. Also ein Kuppel von mir hat so eine Spielidee gehabt, hat sich gedacht, die kann man in zwei Stunden umsetzen. Hat dann zwei Tage gebraucht, was immer noch ziemlich cool ist für das Spiel. Und das heißt Chirp Chirp mit CH. Gibt's im Store, ist erstmal for free, denn Levels muss man später nachkaufen. Und wir haben auch schon einen Hörer hier von uns, weil ich hab ja getwittert, da sind ja Mobile-Max-Hörer. Und der Broti, der jetzt bestimmt noch zuhört, hat irgendwie gerade den Rekord, weil der ist da voll angefixt. Und es ist ein kleines, easy und billiges Spiel, aber es macht eine Weile lang erstmal Spaß. Ist jetzt nicht ganz so cool vielleicht wie Doodle Jump, aber...
Und läuft auch auf dem iPhone, äh, auf dem iPad.
Ja, da läuft es, also auf dem iPhone ist es ein bisschen klein, kann man aber auch spielen, aber auf dem iPad macht es eigentlich am meisten Spaß. Und der Spaß an der Sache sieht erstmal vielleicht nicht so spannend aus, aber der Spaß ist halt, wenn man die Highscores der anderen schlagen muss.
Ist das auch so mit Highscore-Vernetzung? Über?
Ist das Ding gerade.
Der offene Find.
Der andere Kumpel hatte ein Spiel, das ist Space Heist, das wird gerade umgecoded auch auf Open Find. Das hatte vorher irgendwas, was Argon hieß oder so. Argon ist jetzt wohl nicht mehr so angesagt, jetzt ist alles Open Find.
Und das muss man jetzt machen?
Da kannst du eigentlich so eine Hilfe einschalten, und dann sagt der dir, was du machen solltest. Ansonsten musst du deine Birds groß kriegen, ohne dass du sie platzen lässt. Drücken, festhalten. Genau. Und jetzt darfst du nicht von den grünen Kugeln erwischt werden. Und du musst 66% des Bildschirms füllen. Und da ist eine Physix Engine mit bei. Hast du zu spät losgelassen.
Ach so.
Ah, okay. Sobald ich loslasse, kann er nicht mehr platzen. Also ich konnte jetzt auch einfach so...
Nee, weil du hast nur eine begrenzte Anzahl an Eggs, wie du unten links in der Ecke siehst. Eggs, Eggs, Eier. Unten links, unten links. Da steht Birds. Ja, und daneben?
Lives.
Birds sind die Eggs. Ja, ist aber ein Eiersymbol daneben, oder? So genau, weil wenn du nämlich keine Eier mehr hast, gehen danach Leben verloren. Und wenn dich der grüne, so ein grüner Punkt erwischt, geht sofort ein Leben verloren. Und du musst nur 66% füllen, dann kommt der nächste Level, dann ist eins ein grünes Ding, was auch immer dieses grüne Ding ist. So, nur noch Werbung.
Ja, ich wollte ja eigentlich noch so ein bisschen bei Apple und Hardware bleiben. Ich hab, äh... Ich bin ja jetzt relativ gut bestückt wieder mal. Ich hab jetzt irgendwie, nachdem ich so ewig, Ewigkeiten kein... Ich hab mir diese ewig lang nichts mehr gekauft gehabt. So gar nicht. Und alles war...
Du hast das iPod geholt, den iMac hat sie geholt.
Und das ist auch...
Alles ewig her.
Alles totale Produktivitätsbooster. So, aber jetzt komm ich ja sozusagen hier auch in ein modernes Gerät ran. Also unter anderem können ja jetzt die neuen iMacs und die neuen MacBook Pros und natürlich auch der neue Mac Mini, der sowieso, weil der hat ja schon einen HDMI-Ausgang.
Jetzt haben wir auch noch Audio.
Die Geräte, die Mini DisplayPort haben, ab dem 27 Zoll iMac, also seit alle Geräte, die der 27 Zoll iMac sind oder seitdem rausgekommen sind, die können halt auch Audio über HDMI übertragen.
Über den DisplayPort?
Über den DisplayPort. Und zwar gibt es da eine VESA-Spezifikation, die halt die Kompatibilität zwischen HDMI und Mini DisplayPort spezifiziert. Und es gibt Adapter auf dem Markt, die die berücksichtigen und es gibt welche, die das nicht tun. Da muss man gucken. Es gibt bei Amazon einen ganz billigen, für 6 oder 7 Euro, der das macht. Und sehe da, wenn du dann halt diesen Adapter anschließt an dein Mini DisplayPort, dann hast du halt einerseits einen HDMI-Ausgang. Kannst also dann ein normales HDMI-Kabel anschließen, das dann an so einen Fernseher ranführen. Und du hast dann eben auch automatisch noch ein HDMI-Audio-Device auf deinem Rechner. Das heißt, du musst an einem Sound-Panel, kannst du dann eben diesen auch noch als Ausgang wählen. Kannst auch sein lassen. Das heißt, du musst nicht, aber du kannst dann richtig den Sound auch über HDMI laufen lassen. Also wenn du das nicht möchtest und stattdessen den Sound an eine Anlage geben willst, dann kannst du das nach wie vor tun, wie man es bisher auch gemacht hat. Auch wenn das immer diese Probleme mit sich bringt, mit Latenz. Das ist dann halt nicht mehr der Fall. Und das funktioniert gut.
Funktioniert das auch mit 5.1, irgendwas, Getöse?
Keine Ahnung. Habe ich einfach noch überhaupt nicht. Also weder habe ich eine 5.1 Anlage, noch habe ich da irgendwie Material, von dem ich sicher weiß, dass es 5.1 macht, in der Quelle, also weiß ich nichts drüber.
Da war ich ehrlich gesagt enttäuscht, dass ich da das MacBook Micro holt habe und auch so ein Mini Display Port auf HDMI Adapter, dass der Sound nicht mehr drüber ging. Weil das will man ja schon haben.
Ja, ja. Und der neue Mac Mini hat ja jetzt richtig ein HDMI Out. Ein HDMI Out.
Gab es den schon, als wir uns das letzte Mal getroffen haben? Nee.
Und ich muss sagen, abgesehen davon, dass er jetzt nochmal 100 Euro teuer geworden ist, finde ich das Ding ziemlich cool.
Haben wir in dem Büro.
Also ich fand ihn auch ein bisschen teuer.
Und?
Sieht extrem schick aus.
Der ist jetzt so groß wie die Time Capsule, habe ich gehört.
Also ich habe neulich...
Oder? So etwa, wie das Teil da?
Ja, der ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich flach.
Wir haben da geschrieben, dass sich jetzt die Größe der Time Capsule angepasst hat, damit du dir den oben drauf stellen kannst.
Das ist auch ein schickes Format.
Ja, und das Alu-Case ist auf jeden Fall auch echt schick. Also ich hab jetzt nicht viel mitgemacht, aber war halt schnell, snappy und schick.
Und habt ihr den an HDMI irgendwie dran?
Nee, nee, nur an dem Display.
Aber das ist jetzt eigentlich der optimale Zuspielautomat für so TV-Konsumer-Zeug.
Ja, ist schon schick.
Wenn man da so seine Movies abspielen möchte.
Wobei ich muss sagen, als ich ihn auf der Apple-Seite gesehen habe, hab ich gedacht, was ist das denn für ein geiles Teil? Also wirklich so, wow, ist der schön geworden. Aber jetzt hab ich ihn im Laden mal stehen sehen und war so... Klar, tolles Gerät, ohne Frage. Naja, aber es ist irgendwie... Zu abgerundete Ecken, finde ich. Nee, ist Alukiste.
Nicht so wie die da?
Aber die Ecken sind zu abgerundet irgendwie. Die könnten ruhig ein bisschen mehr so sein wie bei dem da. Beim Macbook. Na, so wie das Macbook.
Also halt Apple, Alu, wissen schon.
Ich finde das Ding sieht einfach nur schick aus.
Also wie gesagt, auf Fotos fand ich es auch immer sehr schick und so in person fand ich so, also immer noch ein schönes Gerät ohne Frage, aber nicht so, dass ich das doch trage. Ja, will ich unbedingt haben.
Aber HDMI und Mini DisplayPort ist echt...
Aber man kann alles haben wollen. Man sollte alles haben wollen.
Ich finde für dich, du musst jetzt deine Geräte alle updaten, deswegen. Also Jungs, hier iMac ist zu verkaufen, Team.
Ich bin einfach ein großer Freund von Mini DisplayPort. Das ist irgendwie so der... Das ist so wirklich der Fortschritt in Bildschirm-Anschluss-Technologie, den ich schon immer haben wollte. Ich hab jetzt hier auch meinen iMac. Kann ich hier als Bildschirm von meinem Laptop benutzen.
Die Formel-Stecker ist schon ganz schön krass bei so einem Laptop, den immer reinstecken. Und dann ist mir mein Laptop auch noch runtergefallen. Jetzt ist das hier richtig schlimm, aber es geht noch.
Aber vor allem diese bidirektionale Funktionalität, dass ich halt hier... Ich kann halt diesen iMac als Bildschirm für meinen Laptop benutzen.
Vorher geht er bei dem auch schon.
Wie ging vorher auch schon?
Das kann doch der auch schon.
Ja, ja, aber jetzt hat er auch ein Gerät, das es da kann.
Jetzt hab ich auch ein zweites Gerät, was Mini-Digitalia heute hat.
Aber man kann jetzt auch das MacBook als Display benutzen.
Nein.
Sondern?
Du hast es eigentlich schon verstanden.
Er hat den Zuspieler jetzt für den Monitor.
Ich hatte die ganze Zeit einen iMac, der was anzeigen kann, aber ich hab nix, was dort was anzeigen wollte, außer dem iMac selbst. So, und jetzt hab ich das auch mal ausprobiert. Und es gab ja auch lange Zeit auf dem Markt überhaupt keine Kabel. Es gibt auch nach wie vor keine langen Kabel, aber es gibt von Dr. Bot ein 2-Meter-Verlängerungskabel und es gibt ein 1,5-Meter-Anschlusskabel von Beck.
Deswegen hast du hier so ein Verband unter dem Finger, weil du musstest Blut lassen.
Weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Übliche Strafgebühr halt.
30 Euro und 20 Euro. Mehr?
Interessiert dich jetzt konkret, dann schau ich nochmal nach.
Aber wie ist denn das? Muss man den iMac dafür abschalten, um ihn als Monitor zu benutzen? Wie macht man das?
Ganz im Gegenteil. Wenn du ihn abschaltest, dann kannst du ihn nicht als Monitor verwenden.
Das heißt, der Roll läuft weiter, der iMac, die ganze Zeit?
Ja.
Und wie entscheidest du?
Du musst nicht deinen Rechner runterfahren, um ihn als Bildschirm zu benutzen.
Na ja, es hätte ja sein können, dass er nur das Display einschaltet.
Und die Platte auslässt zum Beispiel.
Du benutzt ja auch nach wie vor die Tastatur zum Beispiel, um hin und her zu schalten und die Helligkeit zu regeln und so weiter.
Ah, wie geht das denn alles?
Das geht so, wie du das denkst. Mit Helligkeit regelst du die Helligkeit.
Nee, aber wie wechselt man den Monitor?
Mit Abfüll... Wo ist denn das Kabel? Hier, jetzt stecke ich das mal rein und gefährde hier mal unsere Aufnahme. Ich hoffe, das führt jetzt hier nicht alles zum Desaster. Jetzt stecke ich das rein und jetzt ist der Bildschirm hier irgendwie weg. Toll, schwarz.
Glück haben.
Du kannst jetzt auch zwischen Mör... Das ist schon ein Mörer. Nein, das ist nicht ein Mörer. Das ist ein Dual-Display. Du kannst aber auf Mörer umschalten.
Genau.
So wie sonst auch.
Genau, und jetzt kann ich hier irgendwie...
Was war das hier?
Abfüll F2 machen.
Und schon ist...
Stürzt alles ab....
von Ableton aus.
Hallo, seid ihr noch alle da?
Update-Probleme.
Was hast du jetzt im Display-Menü oben? Steht da was Spezielles? Nö, ne?
Das Live hat hier tatsächlich ein paar Screen-Refresh-Probleme, ist ja interessant. Aber ist ja auch alte Software hier.
Du hast so wieder 12.000 Seiten offen.
Also ich will mir jetzt ja, wenn es dann kommt, das Magic-Touchpad holen.
Das ist ja lustig hier.
Und zwar um mal auf meinem...
Moment, Halt Stopp, ich war ja noch gar nicht fertig.
Achso, okay.
Oder war ich fertig? Also HDMI, Mac, Tralala.
Alles Töfte.
Dann, genau. Dann hab ich, genau, da ich ja auf dieses MacBook Pro gegangen bin, ich brauchte endlich mal einen großen, hellen Bildschirm, das war einfach nicht mehr zu ertranken.
Das ist jetzt ein MacBook Pro, das ganz neu.
MacBook Pro, langsamster Prozessor, großer Bildschirm mit Spiegel.
4.
Und wie heißt das Ding? MacBook Pro 6.2, das ist ein 6.3.
Gute Frage.
Würde mich mal kurz interessieren. Aber es ist schon der, der zwischen der Grafik und dem anderen also automatisch umschalten kann.
Mit einem Intel Core i5 Professor.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Und soweit ist das Gerät eigentlich auch ganz...
Ich glaube, wir waren kurz weg.
Wir waren kurz weg.
Ja, ich hatte auch so den Eindruck...
Ja, wir hatten einen Reconnect von... Achso, hätte ich sagen sollen.
Hatten wir einen Reconnect oder war das jetzt hier, weil ich hier den Bildschirm umgeschaltet habe?
Nee, vorher schon.
Vorher schon, ja.
Achso, okay, dann hat es damit nichts zu tun. Das wäre jetzt auch...
Ich hoffe, das gefährdet jetzt nicht die Aufnahme und schon war der Stream weg.
Nee, nee, die Aufnahme läuft ja alles wunderbar weiter.
Also das war ja Zufall.
Und wir sind nicht on Air.
Reconnect, was sagt denn da dieses Gerät?
Das blinkt grün und ich bin ja auch im D-Line, oder?
Ja, wir haben ein weiteres Netz, es hat nur kurz hier gerasselt und ich bin raus und wieder rein hier überall. 21 Uhr... Wo ist mein V-Chat noch da? Nee, ist weg. Doch, ist noch da, es dauert nur lange. Es ruckelt nur. Ich habe meine Connectivität behalten, meine Connections gehen noch. Es ist nur sehr, sehr langsam.
Ich mache mal wieder iProxieren.
Ja, dieser Router ist so ein bisschen im Eimer. Da ist irgendwas braun mit dieser Type-Fiction.
Oh, gleich fertig hier.
So, wie auch immer, jetzt habe ich es euch auf jeden Fall gezeigt, Jungs. Jetzt habe ich es euch gezeigt.
Sah nicht so schlecht aus.
Ja, funktioniert einfach. Und vor allem, das ist das Tolle, es funktioniert einfach. Und vor allem dieses Kabel, dieses Mini Display-Port-Kabel, das ist einfach mal dünner als Ethernet. Das ist irgendwie eine echte Freude. Und ich habe bei mir in der Wohnung auch ein 10 Meter langes HDMI-Kabel und so weiter.
Kann ich das gerade mal kurz rausziehen?
Was?
Das Display-Port-Kabel.
Ja, kannst du rausziehen.
Kann ich mal kurz dieses Aufnahmekabel da rausziehen?
Du brauchst es auch nicht wieder reinzustecken.
Ja, ist ganz cool.
Kannst du es dir einfach anschauen. Also es hält auch gut, ich war da am Anfang so ein bisschen skeptisch, aber der Stecker überzeugt mich dann doch irgendwie.
Hm.
Will ich auch haben.
Ja, so und dann habe ich noch das getan, was ich schon immer tun wollte.
Ist der Stream eigentlich wieder da, oder?
Der Stream? Naja, also hier wird kommentiert, oder?
Also wenn der abgebrochen ist, dann eher, weil die Leitung zu dünn ist. Aber wir hatten keinen, also nichts, was irgendwie TCP-Connections killt. Weil meine Connection hier steht noch.
Ah, nee, warte mal, hier haben wir gerade ein anderes Problem. Das nimm ich hier gar kein Audio.
Auf den, aha, wieso denn das? Digital innen.
Und jetzt bin ich aber auch aus dem Irr geflogen hier.
Warte mal, ich mach hier mal stopp.
Wollen wir so lange was anderes erzählen, solange wir hier mal so unter uns sind? Also ich hab jetzt beschlossen, dass ich mir so ein Magic-Touchpad kaufe.
Wir könnten auch in der Zwischenzeit lüften.
Achso, das hatte ich jetzt gar nicht verstanden, dass der Stream nicht lief. Jetzt läuft er aber wieder.
Jetzt läuft der Stream wieder?
Ja, Stop und Start hat geholfen. Unter Umständen, warte mal, vielleicht ist das so, dass wenn man diesen Bildschirm umschaltet...
Ja, die Audio-Eingänge umschaltet, neu sortiert, shuffelt, irgendwie sowas.
Aber das wär ja bekloppt.
Tja, kannst mal sehen. Hat einfach so funktioniert.
Hat einfach so funktioniert.
Hat doch einfach so umgeschaltet.
Das ist ja ein bisschen...
Aber so richtig hab ich hier noch nicht alle Kanäle. Irgendwas ist hier noch extrem langsam.
Das muss ich nochmal ausprobieren, ob das jetzt ursächlich was miteinander zu tun hat, oder ob wir hier irgendwie noch einen anderen Fnord hatten, aber ist natürlich...
Also es geht wohl noch nicht wieder.
Naja, zumindest sende ich wieder.
Haben die eigentlich bei Bits und so auch immer so Probleme?
Ja, klar. Die haben noch viel mehr Probleme.
Ja, aber jetzt sind natürlich alle Hörer zu Bits und so abgehauen.
Nur die besten sind bei uns geblieben.
Können wir aufhören eigentlich.
Nein. Wir müssen hier bis zum Ende durchschwitzen. Du kannst gern das Fenster aufmachen, wenn ich das glücklich mache.
So nochmal, Magic Trackpad. Ich will so ein Magic...
Track die Magic Trackpad.
Ich will so ein Ding nicht, aber mich würde es schon mal interessieren, wie es so ist.
SSD, ja.
Mein altes MacBook habe ich eine SSD reingeschraubt. Das war eine Crucial Real SSD, weil mir die heiß und innig von meinem Lieblingshändler empfohlen wurde.
Ist das so eine gute SSD oder die Consumer SSD? Also es gibt ja die, die lange halten. Die teuren mit Intel und so. Also die, die Apple verkauft. Das sind ja die guten teuren. Und dann gibt es ja diese Consumer Grade, die dann halt auch ein bisschen früher...
Ich weiß, es gab da mal so... Es gab da mal irgendwie so einen Begriff. Genau, den ich auch nicht weiß und ich kann dir das nicht sagen. Ich weiß nur, dass die 270 Euro für eine 128 GB. Die hat auf jeden Fall bei der CT, glaube ich, ganz gut abgeschnitten.
Die macht 250 MB die Sekunde.
Ihr könnt Fragen stellen.
Also wenn ihr sie schon posen wollt, dann...
Aber ehrlich gesagt, an der anderen Stelle hätte ich mir auch die gleich ins neue Macbook gebaut, nicht ins alte Macbook.
Mac Surfer hat den Font umgestellt.
Das Problem ist, dass eine große Platte, die ich brauche, ist einfach mal zu teuer.
Aber ich habe von einem Einbauraum gelesen, mit dem man sich... Einbauraum? Ja, das Macbook Pro hat ja so einen breiten...
Nicht groß im Sinne von Platz, sondern groß im Sinne von RAM.
Ja, ja, schon klar.
Aber?
Da drinnen ist ja so ein optisches Laufwerk. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon mal benutzt hast. Das nimmt Platz weg und macht es ein bisschen schwerer. Und deren Gedanke war, nimmt das den Graus und packt dazu stattdessen einen SSD-Einbauraum rein.
Ja, aber eigentlich macht man es andersherum. Eigentlich macht man seine Main-Primary-Platte eine SSD und wenn es auch nur kleines für das System... Damit es der SATA ist... .und die Daten, die dann langsamer kommen können...
Klar, aber auf jeden Fall kann man dadurch einen MacBook zwei Platten einbauen. Und dann hätte man eine, das ist das, was ich gerade überlege, aus genau der Bredouille, in der du gerade steckst, eine für das System und für die allerwichtigsten Apps. Irgendwie so 128er.
Bei Mac Mini gibt es ja jetzt einen neuen SD-Card-Slot mit diesem SDHC Super Turbo Modus. Die also schon deutlich höher sind. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man da sozusagen auch eine normale SD-Karte mittlerweile als so minimal...
Als Minimalsystem? Also das ist...
Man kann ja mit mehr Daten, also größere SD-Card, benutzen, aber sind die auch schneller?
Ich glaube ja.
Also schneller als deine Festplatte wahrscheinlich schon.
Also so Dauertransferraten und so, wäre ich mir nicht so sicher. Ob das wirklich davon so unglaublich schnell bootet? Also es gibt ja... Was es ja gibt, ist ja...
Moment, erst mal um meine Geschichte zu entsprechen. Also um eure Frage zu beantworten, die nominelle Lesetransferrate sei 355 MB und Schreibtransferrate 140. Erstes ist glaube ich recht viel und zweites ist so okay.
Na, das ist halt... Es gibt ja dann immer so einmal dieses Random... Und dann gibt es ja noch mal Sustain Read und Sustain Write und das ist dann meistens so um die Hälfte oder so. Aber das war jetzt wahrscheinlich natürlich der Poser, die Poser-Werte für mal 10 KB Random Access.
Ich wollte jetzt auch nicht so sehr über so discussionswürdige Feature-Listen da reden, sondern einfach nur meine Experience. Ich hab dieses Ding da reingesteckt und es war wie... Gott, wie soll ich denn dieses Gefühl beschreiben? Also, ich hab das Gefühl, da ist einfach was umgefallen. Weil nichts ist einfach so rechnerwidrig wie so eine Festplatte. Und durch diese SSD wird auf einmal etwas linear, was noch nie linear gewesen ist. Nämlich der Zugriff auf Massendaten. Und das bremst ja alles unfassbar aus. Und jetzt ist auf einmal dieses Macbook, was mir eigentlich zu langsam war, das ist auf einmal so flüssig und so schnell und so unglaublich, also vor allem seidig. Ja, bedenke, das ist unser Backup-System.
Und da geht gleich so ein Topnetzwerk.
Brausen ist einfach so irre. Das lohnt sich dann doch enorm. Liebend gerne würde ich jetzt hier auch eine Fette reinschrauben, aber 500 MB SSD ist halt einfach unbezahlbar. Da musst du irgendwie 1300 Euro hinlegen, das geht gar nicht. Aber wer halt noch alte Hardware hat, auch so einen alten iMac oder so, wo eh nur so eine 160 GB Platte dran ist, die beste Möglichkeit, Speed reinzukriegen, ist so eine SSD.
Ja, also ich hab ja da auch schon mal echt viele Videos gesehen, wo sie Rechner daneben gehalten haben, also einer mit Platte, gleiche Rechner mit Platte, der andere Rechner mit SSD, und dann einfach hier so zehn Apps gleichzeitig starten, mit so einem Apple-Script, einfach open auf zehn Apps, und die SSD-Variante war halt so viel schneller fertig, während irgendwie, kennen wir ja alle, dann das Spinning Beachball of Death, und dann irgendwie, nachdenken, nachdenken, und jetzt öffnen wir die nächste ab und so.
Bootet auch so schnell alles.
Ja, hat mein Kumpel genau auch gestern gemacht, hat in seinen Hack'n'Tosh irgendwie so ein Vierfach-Core-Dings, irgendwie so eine 128 GB-Core-SRSD eingebaut, und also bei meinem Rechner kann ich immer sehen, wie langsam so die Eigens nachgeladen werden, wenn du so ein Finder-Fenster aufmachst, bei dem machst du auf, und es ist alles sofort da, und da bewegt sich danach nichts mehr, aber alles schon geladen wurde, und das ist schon ganz schön verdammt schnell. Oder du eine Safari aufmachst, der vorher wirklich komplett aus war, du machst den auf, und der kommt schon gleich mit der Seite, die er anzeigen sollte.
Okay, das ist schnell. Also ich hab jetzt Safari gestartet, und das war wirklich so nach einem Bounce da.
Klick mal hier in Applications einfach alles an.
Ich mach hier mal die Hölle.
Also hier kostet so eine SSD 270, aber das ist schon noch ganz schön...
Du kannst auch... Bisschen billiger geht schon noch, aber so in dem Bereich liegt's. Aber das ist halt so ein bisschen wie mit RAM.
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht der Rechner-Snappy, aber wenn du dann wieder richtige Tasks machst, die CPU brauchen, ist doch so eine Kiste trotzdem voll hinterher, oder?
Ja, aber mal ehrlich. Meistens hast du nicht Tasks, die voll CPU brauchen, sondern du hast Tasks, die einfach voll auf der Platte rumrödeln.
Naja, ich glaube eigentlich beides.
Bisher war immer so mein Mantra, willst du den Rechner schnell machen, steck viel RAM rein. Aber ich hab halt in allen Rechnern schon viel RAM. Also Max-RAM. Mehr ist irgendwie nicht zu holen.
Darüber diskutieren.
Aber in dem, auf dem du da gerade deine Hände drauflegst, da ist einfach Maximum drin und da geht nicht mehr.
Aber es sind auch Dinge schnell, die man nicht rechnet, dass sie schnell sind, wie Programme beenden.
Man muss ja auch Zeug wegschreiben.
Genau. Vor allem achte man nicht so sehr auf das Schnellsein, sondern dieses Seidige, dieses total lineare. Ja, also das finde ich einfach so charmant. Adressbuch, das macht so... Ich hab da irgendwie 2500 Adressen drin. Das ist immer ein Gehumpel und ein Geruckel und ein Schunkel, bis da irgendwie mal was angezeigt wird. Und das Ding geht so auf und so... Alles ist so ganz...
Ich hab hier News, die hier gerade frisch reinkommen. Für manche sind es... Ja, für manche sind es gute News, für manche aber auch schlechte News. Oracle hat Open Solaris eingestellt. Oh!
Oracle will wirklich das Ärmestand innerhalb von einem oder zwei Jahren komplett verschabeln.
Also die Open Solaris User sollen wohl jetzt auf die Solaris 11 Express-Version switchen, die dann demnächst mal kommt.
Und Google haben sie heute auch noch verklagt.
Aha, muss man mal demnächst bei Systemhelden reinhören.
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit ZFS aus?
Obwohl doch, es gibt eine News. ZFS, eine kleine bei FreeBest. Die haben es gerade eingecheckt, wann es dann rauskommt, ist noch so eine Sache. Obwohl bei Open Solaris kam es wahrscheinlich auch gerade erst neu. Und zwar gibt es jetzt ein ZFS-Diff-Kommando. Da kannst du zwei Snapshots angeben, oder nur einen Snapshot und die Daten, die du gerade hast. Und der sagt dir, welche Files sich denn da gerade alle geändert haben. Einfach so ZFS-Diff, damit man ein bisschen Überblick hat, was dann zwischen den Snapshots nun passiert ist. Das find ich ganz cool. Ist ganz easy.
Da hat der Huckel auch gleich noch was Tolles zu erzählen. Stimmzuckel? Ja, aber ihr springt mir irgendwie so weg. Wir sind irgendwie bei Hardware.
Wir waren bei Festplatten.
In Open Solaris ist es auch Hardware.
Aber SSD ist auf jeden Fall, will ich auch haben.
Ich finde es ja cool. Wer es teuer findet, sollte eher mal drüber nachdenken, ob man wirklich so viel Platz braucht. Oder ob man nicht einfach auch mit und an...
Das ist die 2 Festplatten-Variante. Du hast eine Boot, eine Systemplatte.
Wo mache ich die hin?
Na, statt des CD-Romlaufwerks. Also das DVD-Dopfer.
Da muss man ja so viel basteln. Aber das kann raus, dieses Ding. Ich finde es erstaunlich, dass der iMac, der neue, hat ja Platte und Platz für eine SSD. Das haben die alten nicht, ne?
Serienmäßig mit so einer Boot-SSD bestellt.
Das hätte ich gerne beim nächsten Mac Steve. Also macht es mal klar. Raus mit dem Laufwerk.
Und ich meine, dieser Rahmen, das hat der Tec hier letztens im Club auch bei Frabz gemacht. Und es war halt an einem Abend... Also die haben da irgendwie, weiß nicht, bestimmt noch...
Was gemacht?
Na, bei so einem neuen MacBook Pro das DVD-Laufwerk raus, Einbauraum mit SSD, was Max halt gesagt hat. Er hat eine Boot-SSD gehabt und hat sich dann eine 500 GB normale Platte in das DVD-Laufwerk, also in den Slot von dem DVD-Laufwerk gebaut. Das heißt, er hat jetzt eine schnelle SSD-System-Boot-Platte mit allem Pipapo und dann noch eine fette Daten-Humpe.
Ich bin da auch geneigt.
Na, richtig geil wär natürlich noch, wenn das als Betriebssystem noch unterstützen würdest. Da hättest du nach wie vor nur ein Volume. Aber wenn er irgendwie selber so das auf die Reihe kriegen würde. Mit Oracle ZFS.
Auf das Thema wollte ich übrigens nochmal kommen zum Ende. Mal so ein bisschen Glaskugeln spielen. Aber verstehen wir noch, es gibt ja noch mehr neue Hardware. Also die neuen IMAX mit SSD haben wir jetzt schon genannt.
Ich hab hier noch einen Viertelstunde Beitrag vorbereitet für das neue Apple Batterieladegerät.
Das hatte ich jetzt hier auch als nächstes auf meiner Liste.
Ey, da sind so viele Leute voll begeistert. Ich verstehe das ja noch nicht so ganz, aber ich hab auch noch nicht verstanden, dass das Blumenkübel-Meme ist. Jetzt hat das irgendwas miteinander zu tun.
Das mit der Blumenkübel können wir später machen, aber das würd ich dann auch gerne wissen.
Das Apple-Ladegerät ist wirklich der Blumenkübel des...
Gibt's einen Update?
Vielleicht haben die Leute ja keine Ahnung, und man kann's denen erklären, weil sie keinen Bock haben, irgendwie diese ganzen News-Seiten zu lesen oder was Apple da so schreibt.
Okay, das Ladegerät, komm.
Ja, also pass auf. Seit schon Jahren gibt's neue Akkus, und zwar haben die eine niedrige Selbstentladung. Also normale Nickel-Metallidrate-Akkus, die haben so, keine Ahnung, nach vier Wochen sind die auf die Hälfte runter oder so was. Was natürlich blöd ist, wenn du die in deiner Maus hast und an der Fernbedienung, weil da passiert fast die ganze Zeit nichts, aber die liegen halt lange rum, und da ist Entladung ja voll blöd. Ist ja nicht so wie so ein Hubschrauber, der seine Ladung innerhalb von einem Tag verhaut, sondern Remote, eine Maus, Tastatur und so liegt ewig rum, ist scheiße. Deswegen gibt's diese Nickel-Metallidrate-Akkus mit so einer langsamer Entladung. Die behält bis zu 90 Prozent innerhalb von einem Jahr. Also sie haben fast keine Selbstentladung mehr. Und die verbaut Apple da. Das ist technisch nichts Neues. Machen alle schon irgendwie ewig. Nur Apple macht das jetzt auch.
Muss das Ladegerät dafür auch speziell angepasst sein oder was?
Eigentlich nicht. Also es ist eigentlich ein ganz normales, dass du die Batterien mit lieferst.
Aber ich sage nur, das Ladegerät ist doch auch total mit der niedrigsten Phantom-Fuhr.
Ich hab mal geguckt, Apple gibt an 30 mW an Verbrauch, wenn das irgendwie nicht mehr lädt. Ich hab mal geguckt, wie viel die anderen verbrauchen und die liegen bei, oder Apple hat's geschrieben, glaube ich, und die lagen bei 300 mW, was immer noch 0,3 Watt sind. Und ich hab die Preisersparnis ausgerechnet und das waren 2,50 Euro pro Jahr, die das Apple-Network sparen würde. Irgendwie so.
Nach nur 10 Jahren ist es wieder raus.
Aber was kosten denn so normale Ladegeräte für so ein Nickel-Metall-Lüter?
Von Apple kostet das ja 30, glaube ich, oder? Ich hab mir eins gekauft, was BC, ich weiß nicht, BC 100, BC 400 oder irgendwie so kostet. Da passen 4 rein und das hat mich 14 Euro gekostet und das mit Display und zeigt alles an.
Und sind da auch Batterien dabei?
Da waren Batterien dabei, weil irgendwie special, weil die hatten gerade die Version ohne Batterien nicht mehr und haben mir deswegen die Version mit Batterien geschickt. Aber dann zahlt es halt nochmal 5 Mal mehr für die Batterien. Der Witz ist aber, dass irgendwer, ich glaube, FSCK-Log war es, der hat ein Foto von diesen Batterien gehabt.
Tier-of-Pictures, oder? So richtig Zerlegebilder.
Ja, genau. Und Apple hatte, ich hab geguckt auf die Batterien, Apple hatte welche mit...
Ach, bei MacFixit haben sie die gleich wieder auseinandergenommen.
Bei irgendeiner tschechischen Seite.
Kann sein, dass die von woanders verlinkt waren, wenn nicht seine eigenen Fotos. Jedenfalls hatten die nur 1950 mAh. Was?
Das ist doch voll viel.
Nee, das ist voll wenig.
Das ist voll viel. Also die Standard-Akkus, die du im Laden kaufst, die haben wir unter 1000.
Nee, die haben 3000.
Nee, die sind schon die richtig teuren.
Du vergleichst jetzt die AAA mit den AA?
Ah, nee, also die in die Mighty Mouse kommen. Oder Magic Mouse.
Also ich hab jetzt keine Akkus bei, weil die sind in meiner Maus. Dann hast du dich wirklich verguckt. Die aktuellen haben so 3000 mAh. Ich hab zu Hause welche mit 2300. Das sind aber die mit der langsamen Entladung. Genau, das muss man noch dazu sagen. Die mit der langsamen Entladung, die haben nicht ganz so viele mAh, wie die mit der schnellen Entladung. Das ist sozusagen ein kleiner Nachteil, aber wenn man die wirklich über Monate einsetzt, dann können die diesen Nachteil locker ausspielen, indem die so lange halten. Man sollte diese langsamen Entladungsdinger aber nicht nehmen für den Hubschrauber, den du an einem Tag wegbrettern willst. Dann kann man diese anderen nehmen, weil die mehr Rums haben, nämlich so inzwischen 3000. Kannst du nach googeln, wenn du willst. Also es gibt wirklich, wenn man so sieht, keinen Grund für dieses Apple-Netzteil.
So unglaublich spannende Sachen, wie Apple-Ladegeräte.
Moin, mit dem Thema ist es noch nicht durch.
Du musst es mal so sehen, es ist so langweilig, dass das Thema niemand anders behandelt hat.
Wahrscheinlich bis und zu geht es seit 3 Stunden darum. Die wollten damit einsteigen, sind aber noch nicht weiter.
Das Thema haben die verpasst. Das haben die nicht gesehen, welches Potenzial das hat.
So, sind wir bei 3000 mAh oder sind wir bei unter 1000 mAh?
Wie viel haben denn die?
1.950 waren es.
Also ich sehe hier welche mit 26.
Es gibt natürlich welche, die so hohe haben, aber die sind halt auch arschteuer.
Nein, die kosten Euro mehr.
Aber woran erkennt man denn diese niedrige Lade-Geschichte?
Na die heißen, es gibt ja eh sowieso nur 4 Batteriefirmen, auf dieser Welt alles andere sind Rebrandings. Die heißen von Sanyo, heißen die glaube ich Eneloop, von Golden Peak oder Golden Power oder wie die heißen, da habe ich den Namen vergessen, aber Eneloop sind zum Beispiel die von Sanyo.
Hier gibt es aber 2.7.
Dann sind es wahrscheinlich die mit der schnellen Entladung, wenn die so viele haben. Das ist das Lade-Geschicht, was ich habe, was da unten links ist.
Techno Line?
Ja, das wird auch auf tausend Namen irgendwie ge-rebranded, weil es so ein Standardteil ist.
Wenn du damit nicht die teuren Apple-Akkus kaputt machst.
Da kannst du 4 laden.
BC 700 heißt das Ding, ok.
27,45 Euro.
Ja, ist ein bisschen teuer da. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich mit Batterien. Eneloop, ich guck mal. Eneloop, Sanyo, genau hier.
Eneloop haben 2000.
Ja, und die gibt es auch mit ein bisschen mehr. Also die gibt es nur mit 2,3, dann hört es irgendwie auf.
Das heißt, 4 Eneloop kosten schon 13,50 Euro hier?
Ja, kann sein.
Also dann ist es jetzt nicht total überteuert, das Apple-Teil. Kann man nicht sagen.
Also nicht so normalen Apple-Fahren.
Wie viele Batterien machen dabei 6 Stück, ne?
Also es macht schon alleine die Hälfte.
Und dieses Techno-Line-Teil, hat das dann noch mal so ein externes Netzteil? Das heißt, du hast da so diesen typischen schwarzen Kasten mit so einem Pivot-Kabel da dran und dann noch so ein ekeliger Stecker, der mal rausgeht.
So ein Standard-Stecker, ja. Aber es ist cool, das Ding. Kannste einschalten, dass er erstmal entladen soll oder dass er die Batterie testen soll oder dass er Discharge, Charge, Test und noch was. Ich glaub, vier Modis konnte das irgendwie. Und ich pack's dann mal rein, sag er soll dischargen und wenn er dann Discharge hat, dann lädt er auf und hält ihn dann. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool. Du kannst gleich sehen, wie viel Power er braucht, um das Ding aufzuladen. Dann kannst du gleich die schwarzen Schafe ausfiltern.
Also nerd-kompatibel.
Ja, schon. Und das ist wirklich cool. Auch schon andere Leute haben gesagt, das ist es einfach.
Für die gehobenen Batterieanwender.
Ich hab schon seit Jahrzehnten... Nein, aber seit Jahrzehnten habe ich...
Gibt's noch ein iPhone App dafür?
Seit Jahrzehnten hab ich einen coolen Batterielader gefunden, der alles Mögliche laden kann und das Ding kann das. Also das ist auch egal, welche Größe du reinpackst, der lädt die Batterie voll, egal wie groß. Früher gab es immer nur so Ladeteile, die haben sechs Stunden mit einer bestimmten Spannung geladen und dann war deine Batterie aber noch eventuell lange nicht voll oder eine kleinere war total überladen und der passt sich da an und guckt danach.
Achso, hier 1350...
Wir sollten auf unsere Mobile-Mac-Seite Affiliate Links auf die Produkte tun. Also wenn wir schon hier so dieses Ladegerät halb lang gleich hier auf Mobile-Mac so ein Affiliate Link...
Ja, machen wir auch.
Ja, dann können wir uns auch mal eine SSD kaufen.
Wofür brauchst du denn eine SSD? Reicht doch, wenn Tim eine hat.
Ich finde, jeder sollte eine SSD haben.
Also, ja... Wir gründen mal eine Partei, oder? Jeder sollte eine SSD haben.
Ich stecke alle Spenden hier in die Schokolade.
Ja, wo ist das?
Nichts in die Werbung.
Das wusste ich vom letzten Mal noch.
Alles in den Geschmack, nichts in die Reklame.
Was?
Das letzte Mal nicht, das vorletzte Mal auch nicht.
Du bist so selten da. Jungs, wenn wir uns auf einen regelmäßigen Termin einigen können...
Immer bei den Terminen, wo wir alle nicht da sind, ist dummerweise das totale Mega-Buffet da.
Und dann beim nächsten Mal...
Wenn wir einen regelmäßigen Termin finden können, den wir hier ein paar Mal durchhalten, dann gibt es auch Buffet.
Ich kümmer mich.
Da hat's aber die Schnauze voll genommen.
Das meine ich ernst. Ich werde sogar Essen wählen, was hier nicht zu unübermäßigen Schmatzen führt.
Die Fanboys haben das Apple-Batterieladegerät gleich bei den Akkumulatoren mit geringer Selbstentladung addiert. Diese Apple Fanboys schlimm.
Wie was?
Eine solche, sag ich dir. Das Apple-BP-Artikel gleich und das Apple-Ladegerät erweitert natürlich.
Aha.
Dir Schweine!
Ähm, sind wir jetzt mit dem Thema Batterieladen durch?
Ich werd mir eins kaufen, weißt du? Also du hast gedacht! Ganz ehrlich, ich bin ja auch so ein bisschen so Tisch-ästhet. Und ich hasse einfach diese schwarzen Prolo-Geräte mit diesen ekligen Netzteilen und diesen dünnen Kabeln, die da rauskommen. Und die sich dann auch so, die so ganz, wie so Haare sind.
Als wenn der Tisch jetzt hier freier wäre von Kabeln.
Naja, also ich meine, seine Maus und seine Tastatur und Sparren sind wesentlichen eure Netzteile.
Und da würdest du das Apple-Ladegerät hier so direkt so reinploppen und dann würde es hier so...
Genau.
Ja und dann kannst du aber auch immer nur zwei laden, ne?
Na, reicht ja.
Ja stimmt, hab ich auch. Eigentlich lad ich immer nur zwei, stimmt schon. Ich brauch mir auch so ein Ding.
Hast du zwei und dann ist irgendwas wieder leer und dann schiebst du irgendwie nach.
Ja, aber weißt du, was mir im Apple immer ein bisschen fehlt? Die zeigen immer nichts an und ich bin ja schon so ein bisschen nörd und das BC700 zeigt wirklich geil.
Da ist die grüne LED dran.
Ja, toll, wie er auch lang springen kann, solange er lädt und die dann nach sechs Stunden später ausgeht. Und dann weißt du aber nicht, ob nun eine von beiden schon schwächer ist als die andere und so weiter und so fort.
Wir kriegen dann auch mit, oder?
Die gibt's dann bestimmt demnächst mit W-Laner, dann kannst du dann irgendwie mit dem Batterie-Ladegerät...
Ich fände mit iPhone-App....
ein Hilfsprogramm, da ist die schon drauf....
iPhone-App wert natürlich, ne?
Genau, so ein Power-Song hinten dran.
Ich meine, so kann Apple irgendwie Geräte rausbringen, wo sie nicht teuer in Displays investieren müssen, sondern alles irgendwie per iPhone managen können.
Und dann noch Facetime mit dem Ladegerät.
Und GPS drinnen, damit ich noch mal weiß, wo meine Batterien sind.
Für den professionellen Batterielader.
Das klingt aber schon sehr nach Vibrator, oder? Für den professionellen Batterielader.
Batterieturbo-Lader. Wieder was gelernt hier bei Mobile Macs. Wieder was gelernt.
Es soll übrigens auch neue Mac Pros geben. Ich weiß, das ist jetzt nicht so wichtig, aber...
Das ist gut, dass du das ansprichst, denn das war tatsächlich mein nächster Talking Point.
Welcher, was, wie, wo?
Na, dass es neue Mac Pros gibt. Da gibt es aber nicht so sehr viel zum Neuesten erzählen, weil eigentlich ändert sich nichts.
Wann war das letzte Mal, wo du ein Mac Pro hattest?
Ich hatte, glaube ich, noch nie...
Same here, und du?
Doch, in der Uni hatte ich Mac Pros im Einsatz.
Mac Pro?
Aber da gab es noch nie... Da gab es noch nicht so diese Klasse von iMacs.
Also ich glaube tatsächlich, dass ich das letzte Mal diesen Gehäusefaktor im Einsatz gesehen habe, da hieß das Ding noch G5.
Ich hab zu Hause nur noch meinen Dual G4 mit 500 MHz rumsteht.
G4?
Aber die hatten ja noch ein anderes Gehäuse.
Es gibt Leute, die brauchen sowas.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Also ich glaube, das ist echt ein Monster. Wie viel? 6 Kerne?
Also erstmal gibt es Leute, die brauchen die Performance.
Also 12 Kerne insgesamt.
Insbesondere halt im Sound- und 3D- und im Videobereich. Und es gibt auch Leute, die brauchen nach wie vor diese Erweiterbarkeit, allein um sich einfach mal so latest und greatest Graphics-Cut da reinzuschwurbeln. Und im Sound-Bereich genauso. Also wenn du wirklich professionell Audio machen willst. Ich hab jetzt zum Beispiel nur den iMac. Ich kann jetzt hier nicht mit super-low-latency-Audio da reingehen, sondern da ist halt irgendwie immer Latenz. Das ist für mich jetzt nicht so das Problem, weil ich das Ding eben wirklich nur als Recorder benutze. Aber eigentlich will man halt rein und wieder raus. Und sowas geht eben nur mit niedriger Latenz.
Aber jetzt ist Freitag, wa?
Dann würde ich nämlich... Ich bin verwirrt, irgendwas ist verschoben worden. Im Online-Kalender steht es noch drin, dass es eine Party gibt. Aber getwittert haben sie was anderes. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall gibt es noch Bedarf für diesen Mac Pro. Ich kenne auch jemanden, der hier um die Ecke wohnt, der sich gerade einen gekauft hat und ganz glücklich ist.
Als Bildrechner für Distributed Builds, für Xcode, wäre das auch ganz cool.
Vor allem kannst du auch viele Platten da reinstecken.
Ja, ich träume ja schon. Manchmal klinge ich ja im Apple Store und dann in den F4 und gucke. Mal.
Was kann man denn so ausgeben?
Na 18.000, 20.000 kriegst du da voll.
Wirklich?
Wenn du noch Displays dazu klickst und so, bist du da ganz schnell dabei.
Ich kauf mir mal das rechts unten Modell.
Mal gucken, was das kostet.
Kann man den 12 Kern denn schon klicken eigentlich?
Ja, kann man das liefern.
Kann man klicken? Kann man klicken.
Geht schon ab 4.800 Euro los.
Ok, ein Klickspreis. Und jetzt klick dich mal hoch.
Also Prozessor ist mal geupgraded.
Wo sind wir jetzt? Schon bei 6 irgendwo.
2,93. Da gehen schon mal 1200 drauf. 32 GB RAM.
Da gehen aber auch 64 rein, oder?
Schon bei neuneinhalb oder was?
Ist immer noch unter 10.000.
Neunhalb.
So, jetzt viermal SSD natürlich.
So, dann viermal SSD mit 512 GB.
Das ist schon mal 15.000. Find ich schon. Und jetzt ist es ja richtig geil.
Stimmt, 15.700.
Du kannst dann...
Grafikenunterstützung, wie viel was braucht man? 5.870 ist so das höchste der Gefühle derzeit.
Du willst zwei ATI natürlich.
Nee, zwei ATI-Radios, das ist nicht teurer. Zwei Laufwerke, also ich finde, man braucht schon zwei super Gewalt.
Mindestens, also wenn du...
Wie sollt ich mit dem iPhone?
Oh, es gibt noch 30 Zoll, wir haben zwei mal 24. Oder? Zwei mal 30 Zoll, die gibt's echt noch.
Eigentlich, wenn wir den 27er haben, aber da jetzt nur der 30er da ist, nehmen wir einen 30er dazu und den mal zwei.
Ich will natürlich auch eine Magic Mouse und ein Magic Trackpad. Und einmal alle Tastatur mit ein.
Und das Ladegerät natürlich.
Das Ladegerät ist ja klar.
Aber natürlich darf auch nicht die Quad-Channel 4 Gigabit Fiber Channel PCIe Express Card fehlen.
Ne, die brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
Die lassen wir weg, die hat ja zu Hause keinen Sinn.
Die brauchen wir nicht.
Und die Software lassen wir auch weg.
Die Software lassen wir auch weg.
Apple Care kannst du vielleicht noch dazuklicken.
Aber Moment, stopp, du willst natürlich noch den Mini Display Part of DVI Adapter ganz wichtig.
Stimmt, dann siehst du ja nicht.
Sonst mit den zwei LED Displays geht das ja sonst gar nicht.
Genau, und das 30 Zoll und so.
Zwei davon brauchen wir.
Und Mobile Mi, das war jetzt auch richtig teuer. Ich hab vorhin so ein...
Und wo bist du? Bist du schon mal 20.000? 111 Euro.
Tim hat gewonnen, du bist schon mal bei 19.700 irgendwas.
Das ist wie früher.
Wie wie früher?
Naja, ich weiß noch, als ich so angefangen habe, meine Zeit in Kaufhäusern zu verbringen, da stand so dieser IBM PC im Schaufenster mit 14.000 Mark.
Guter Tipp, lass uns zwei iMac 27 Zoll als Displays nehmen. Das ist billiger als so ein 30 Zoll Display.
Das ist dicker denn. Das ist dicker denn.
Ja, was hat das für ein Gerät, hat er vielleicht 1000 Mark gekostet?
Der IBM PC. Der IBM PC mit zwei 5,25 Zoll Disklaufwerken.
Also ich hab neulich mal die Rechnung von meinem ersten Powerbook G4 gesehen.
Also Floppy Disk.
Was hast du gesehen, die Rechnung?
Die Rechnung, die ich bezahlt habe für mein erstes Powerbook G4, Titanium, das waren auch 3500 Euro.
Das ist nur Mark.
Nee, nee, Euro. Ich hab da extra noch mal hingeguckt.
Die Titanium war doch 2003, so kam die. Oder 2002.
Ich hab auch nicht die erste Generation. Ich hatte schon mit DVI-Ausgang und 667 Megahertz.
Major Hertz. Na ja, also man kann bei Apple auch noch richtig Geld lassen.
Es geht, wer hätte das gedacht?
Aber so eine Maschine hätte ich schon gerne mal im Arbeitszimmer. So eine Workstation, wo man einfach mal so richtig auf... Wo man flutscht. Wo so FreeBSD-Welt bauen, einfach so...
Das ist dieses iOS für Desktops, oder? Du hast...
Mal gucken, wie lange das so heißt. Was mir an der Stelle noch ganz kurz einfällt, ist, ich hab vorhin ein Video gepostet von Microsoft. Die haben jetzt so eine neue Tastatur entwickelt. Und zwar ist die eigentlich total simpel. Das ist eine transparente Tastatur, die so über so einem kleineren TFT-Display drüber gelegt ist, sodass man die Tastaturbelegung austauschen kann. Und komplette Touch-Oberfläche. Und die Trottel schaffen es tatsächlich, die Tastatur nach unten zu packen und oben den Touch hin, anstatt einfach die Tastatur nach oben zu schieben, sodass man unten noch ein großes Trackpad dran hat. Ansonsten wär das ja echt ein geiles Teil.
Das heißt, das Trackpad ist bei dir oben, oder wie?
Sozusagen, genau. Kannst du dir auch suchen, wo deine Tastatur ist? Nein, weil es ist ja eine physische Tastatur, damit du auch noch das Tippgefühl hast.
Also ein Windows-7-Gerät, oder was?
Ich weiß, bisher gibt es das offiziell noch gar nicht, aber ein paar Studenten kriegen das, um dafür Anwendung zu entwickeln.
Dann könnten wir jetzt auch über Microsoft Surface reden, das ist genauso ein unbedeutendes Produkt.
Wie ist das denn so eine Tastatur?
Also wir reden jetzt über eine Tastatur mit einem...
Wo du beliebige Anwendungen drauf laufen kannst. Es gab ja schon mal diese Optimus-Tastatur, die habt ihr bestimmt alle gesehen.
Die gab es so richtig?
Na doch, die konnte man kaufen, die kostet bloß ein Vermögen.
Okay, irgendwann gab es die dann mal.
Und die hat jede Tastatur, hat da einen kleinen LED-Bildschirm drin. Und die machen das jetzt einfach so, die machen unten irgendein billiges 9 Zoll, oder was ist der Teufel, war das Display drunter?
Und da drückt man eine Tastatur und da scheint das dann durch.
Und da scheint das dann durch.
Und sie haben aber die Tastatur nach oben geletzt.
Wie heißt dieses Gerät?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das schon einen Namen hat. Keine Ahnung, ich hab schon gezwittert den Link.
Das hast du vorhin gezwittert?
Das hab ich schon gezwittert.
Dann machen wir hier mal einen Plug, 3, 4, 3, Max. Qualität, Zwiez, Seit?
Seit drei Jahren. Ach so, die Qualitätszeit noch gar nicht. Du schreibst viel über Blumenkübel. Ich hab einmal genau über Blumenkübel.
Hat das irgendjemand nicht mitbekommen?
Ja, es brach aus, aber ich weiß nicht, wo es herkommt und ob es noch irgendwas mehr außer Blumenkübel.
Das war schon recht lustig, aber ich finde hier dein Tweet nicht.
Warte mal, darf ich mal?
Heute hast du das Gepfiff.
Der twittert viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Also, auf den Punkt gebracht.
Hier, Tastatur.
Diese ganzen verkürzten URLs, das ist überhaupt gar nicht so richtig.
Max ist weg, wird hier gechattet.
Was? Ich bin weg, ich bin doch da.
Ist dein Kabel wackelig oder was?
Mein Kabel? Also ich höre mich doch deutlich.
Da wir dich hören, bist du da.
Ich bin da.
Du gehst auch definitiv aufs Stream, das kann ich...
Ist da.
Sag mal was, Max.
Ich bin da.
Du bist zu hören.
Wenn du nicht zu hören bist... So, was ist denn das jetzt hier für eine Flunder?
Also so sieht eine Tastatur aus mit Display unten drunter.
Ja, gibt es das auch in groß, den Bildschirm?
Sie haben unten ein paar Videos reingepackt, wo man es da in Aktion sehen kann.
Man nennt es auch CPU-Burn.
Aber es ist jetzt eine neue Flash-Version mit 3D-Hardware-Beschleunigung.
Und wurde schon von Click to Flash unterstützt?
Ich kann dir kurz erzählen, ich hab ja auf einem iPad Flash drauf. Also ich dachte, ich geb mir das mal. Es hat ja jemand das Flash von Android, von Android 2.2, aufs iPad und aufs iPhone portiert, was ich eine ganz clevere Idee finde. Und es funktioniert hervorragend, um Werbung anzuzeigen. Also es ist tatsächlich schnell und es ist, also so die dreieinhalb Beispielseiten, die dann so auch in den Videos immer angezeigt werden, die funktionieren wirklich super und auch wirklich schön schnell und alles großartig. Aber sobald es darum geht, mit dem Browser zu kommunizieren, also Videos kann man komplett knicken, also YouTube geht einfach nicht. Und das Zeug geht einfach nicht alles. Aber so diese einfachen Flash-Animationen, die sind schnell und... Naja, ich meine, das hat sich jetzt irgendwie mal zusammengehackt und wie gesagt, irgendwie aus dem Android die entsprechende Bibliothek ausgebaut und die dann aufs iPad gepackt. Da find ich schon mal beeindruckt, dass das überhaupt geht.
Hast du mal mit deinem Browser YouTube auch gebraust eigentlich? Weil die haben ja jetzt so eine iPhone-iPad-kompatible App.
Ja, ganz furchtbar.
Nee, die ist fast cooler eigentlich, als die Apple mitliefert, finde ich. Die ist noch ein bisschen flaky hier und da, aber so von den Features.
Also wenn man jetzt so Spiegel surft und die Mobile-Seite kriegt, ist der Horror voll vom Arsch. Ich klick dann immer auf, gib mir die echte Seite. Bei Wikipedia ist das okay, aber bei Spiegel find ich so wie blöd.
Gut, wo sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich abgebogen?
Ich wollte mal...
Und dann hast du mich angesprochen.
Genau, ich wollte...
Wir waren bei MacPro.
Ich wollte mal ein Thema vertiefen, was meiner Meinung nach wichtig ist und was wir hier, glaube ich, nur am Rande behandelt haben. Und ich vermute, Huckel, du hast mehr Zeit damit verbracht als ich. Homebrew ist ein neuer frischer Ansatz, wie man Unix-Software, Ports, Open-Source, Climbim auf einem Mac installieren bekommt. Das muss man ja von Zeit zu Zeit mal tun. Bisher war die Waffe der Wahl eigentlich immer MacPorts. Was so dieses etwas merkwürdige, aber an sich ganz gut funktionierende System ist, was in Tickle geschrieben ist, was aus der FreeBSD-Welt quasi gedanklich kommt und eine Weiterentwicklung des FreeBSD-Ports-Systems ist.
Also eigentlich, es gibt ja Fink, das können wir gleich mal bei Seite tun, aber am Anfang, als es so mit dem Mac OS losging, gab es natürlich sofort den Bedarf, da gab es halt Fink und Darwin-Ports, wie es damals hieß. Und Darwin-Ports, so wie ich das gesehen habe, ist das tatsächlich ein Port von FreeBSD-Ports. Nur, dass sie dann halt ihr eigenes Frontend dafür...
Nee, nee, nee, das ist...
Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch. Siehst du, wenn du da richtig tief reinguckst, ich hab mal mit Erdgeist mir so gedacht aus Spaß, lass uns mal FreeBSD-Ports nochmal so portieren.
Aber FreeBSD-Ports ist nicht in Tickle geschrieben.
Ich weiß, also dieses GUI-Frontend und so weiter, aber so im Prinzip so der... User Interface. Also das ist halt natürlich... Command Line, also C-A-I.
Die Kommandozeile.
Ja, das haben die natürlich nicht von FreeBSD übernommen, offensichtlich, ja.
Ja, die haben auch sonst nichts übernommen.
Na doch, es war am Anfang tatsächlich ein Port von den FreeBSD-Ports. Also richtig ganz am Anfang haben die FreeBSD-Ports genommen und versucht, auf dem Mac zum Laufen zu kriegen. Und davon sind sie immer weiter so in ihrer eigenen Welt.
Das ist aber jetzt sehr, sehr lange her. Man hat überhaupt nichts mit der Realität zu tun.
Naja, insofern schon, dass wir immer noch so dieses Port-Files-Konzept benutzen. So, das ist noch übrig geblieben davon. So weit so gut, genau. So, und das hat halt jetzt irgendwie jahrelang eigentlich so mittelprächtig funktioniert, war immer noch besser als Fink, aber so richtig glücklich hat das irgendwie kaum jemand gemacht. Es gab eigentlich immer die Fraktion einmal Fink, das ist eher die Minderheit, dann gab es die Magpods-Leute, die so mit naja, ist nichts toll, aber es funktioniert. Dann gab es die ganz harten, die meinten, nee, ist alles Dreck, ich compile mir alles selber. So richtig mit userlocal alles selbst verwaltet und so. Und dann kam eben vor einem Jahr, oder was weiß ich, dieses Homebrew raus mit irgendwie gerade auf dieser Git und Ruby und sonst was Halbwelle irgendwie Homebrew. So und was die halt machen ist eigentlich ganz cool. Da hast du halt deine Portfiles, die heißen da Formulas. Die sind halt auf GitHub in einem dicken Repository. Und du installierst dir halt so ein kleines Command Line Utility, was halt in diesem Repository interagiert, kriegst diese Formulas und kannst dir damit Software...
Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal kurz ein paar mehr Leute mitnehmen. Also grundsätzlich, man redet von Ports sozusagen, das Konkrete zum Laufenbringen von bestimmter Unix Software, die meistens auch unter Linux und so weiter.
Deswegen heißt es ja auch schon Ports, weil die ja portiert wurden für Linux.
Ein Port ist sozusagen eine automatisierbar zusammengefasste Beschreibung, wie man dieses Software-Paket zu übersetzen hat, damit es auf dem Mac läuft.
Die spielen teilweise noch Patches mit ein oder so was, ne?
Eigentlich noch ein bisschen anders. Eigentlich ist es ja so, wenn du dir so ein Tablet von irgendeinem Projekt runterlädst, der baut ja so eigentlich out of the box, so. Dann ist nur das Problem, wenn du das halt manuell machst, hast du meistens Dependencies und dann musst du halt irgendwie erstmal dich von Hand durch die Dependencies hangen, die Tablets von denen runterladen, genau. Musst du die bauen in der richtigen Reihenfolge. Dann musst du vielleicht noch einen Patch für deine Plattform applying und das musst du alles manuell machen. Und was dir das Portfile abnimmt, ist halt sozusagen so ein Kochrezept. Ich wäre jetzt postgereskoell mit Volltext-Suche und dann schlüsselt der dir die Dependencies auf, installiert die in der richtigen Reihenfolge, applied die Patches und du gibst ein Kommando ein und danach, in der schönen, idealen Welt hast du dann einen Postgres am Start. So. Genau. Das macht halt sozusagen so ein Port- oder Package-System. Und bei Homebrew machen sie das eben so, dass diese Rezepte erstens in Ruby geschrieben sind, zweitens sind die Rezepte alle in einem GitHub-Repository und drittens hast du halt so ein minimales kleines Command-Line-Utility, mit dem du halt diese Ports oder Packages oder Formulas installieren kannst. Und als die halt rausgekommen sind, war das halt natürlich erst mal nicht so praktikabel, weil erstens fehlte extrem viel Software. Also die hatten einfach total wenig Formulas am Start. Dann war diese Seite von diesem Projekt auch geprägt von Homebrew-Metaphern. Ja, so Bier hier, Bier da und man hatte den Eindruck, die Entwickler sind eigentlich eh die ganze Zeit völlig Sturz-Trunken und irgendwie hat mir das alles nicht so richtig gefallen. Und jetzt kürzlich habe ich mal wieder raufgeschaut und nicht nur... Moment, aber es... Also, kommen wir gleich noch zu dem Punkt. Also, die haben jetzt auf jeden Fall ihre Seite ein bisschen aufgeräumt. Die ganzen Bier-Referenzen sind weg, ja. Also ein bisschen aufs Erhöser gemacht. Und sie haben jetzt auch extrem viel Software drin. Und das Command Line Utility funktioniert scheinbar auch ganz gut. Auf jeden Fall ist halt der Vorteil, ja. Der ganz krasse Vorteil von diesem Homebrew. Normalerweise ist es halt so, und das kommt echt oft bei Mac-Ports vor, du willst halt einen Port installieren und brauchst halt eine Custom-Build-Option. Also ich wäre jetzt eben z.B. Full-Text Search bei SQLite 3 noch dazu haben. So, und jetzt hat der Erschaffer dieses Port-Files halt nicht daran gedacht, dass Leute vielleicht die Full-Text-Suche anmachen wollen und haben diese Option gar nicht für dieses Mac-Ports-Interface-Expose. Und wenn du das jetzt aber anmachen willst, hast du halt keinen richtigen offiziellen Weg, das anzuknipsen. Und was du tun kannst, ist halt mit Sudo in das Ports-Verzeichnis gehen, das Port-File editieren, die Option mit reinpflanschen an die richtige Stelle speichern, bauen und dann geht's. Aber wenn du dann das nächste Mal deine Ports aktualisierst, dann stellt er fest, oh Moment, hier stimmt eine Check-Summe von einem Port-File nicht und dann überschreibt er die. Gut, der nächste Schritt wäre dann, ok, du hast jetzt das Port-File gepatcht und schickst es dem Maintainer und sagst, hier könnten wir mal anmachen und so. Und dann meldet er sich einfach nicht. Also bei Mac-Ports wie bei FreeBSD-Ports, die kannst du da anschreiben, dann passiert irgendwie ein gefühltes halbes Jahr einfach nix. Und du schleifst die ganze Zeit dein custom gepatchtes Port-File hinterher. Und was bei Homebrew halt cool ist, da das ein Git-Repo ist, kannst du halt auf GitHub einfach sagen fork, dann hast du diese ganzen Formulas in deinem eigenen Account. Kannst da rumpatchen und was auch immer, hast die aber in Version-Control. Und wenn du halt der Meinung bist, dass deine aktualisierte Formula mit neuen Varianten und Bildoptionen so viel besser ist, als die, die im offiziellen Repo ist, schickst du halt so einen Pull-Request an den Maintainer. Und die patchen das halt mit rein, aber du bist nicht darauf angewiesen. Also du hast deine Port-Files oder deine Formulas in Version-Control, sie sind für alle verfügbar. Du kannst sagen, ich will SQLite 3 aus dem offiziellen Repo oder aus meinem Repo. Kann auch lokal auf der Platte liegen, dein ganzes Port-File-Repo und ist halt alles so schön. Und sie haben halt auch, wenn du das mal schnell fixen willst, kannst du auch sagen, brew, edit, Postgresql und dann macht er dir in deinem Lieblingseditor diese Formula gleich auf, so richtig so einladend, mach doch mal was. Oder wenn du selber ein Tarbol runterlädst, weil der nicht drin ist, haben sie halt auch so einen kleinen Quickie-Command, um aus diesem Tarbol eine Formula zu machen. Erstmal mit, ohne viel Voodoo.
Das hab ich mal ausprobiert und das hat echt funktioniert. Das hat mich total überrascht, weil hier zum Beispiel MP4, V2 gab's nicht. Ich hab da nicht geschneit, wie ich dann zurückmelde, mit diesem Forken und...
Ich hab das jetzt auch erst eine Woche wieder ausprobiert. Ich dachte mir, okay, das sieht jetzt erstmal wieder ein bisschen seriöser aus und die haben auch viel gemacht. Es ist in Ruby, ja. Ich hab's jetzt ein paar auf ein paar Systemen einfach mal knallhart probiert ohne Mac-Ports und war echt überrascht, weil das extrem gut funktioniert hat. Also alles Software, die ich wollte, war drin, war auch immer die neueste Version. Und da wo ich halt Custom-Build-Options wollte, Brew-Edit-Port, also Brew-Edit-Postgres-QL und dann mal kurz an die richtige Stelle das Configure Flag. Das hat schon Spaß gemacht.
Okay, noch kurze Zwischenfrage. Hab ja ein bisschen mal kurz gelesen am Forum und so. Ist es richtig, dass die immer noch ihr User Local auf, also wenn ich bei mir bin User Dennis, dass die User Local auf die, also, wo sie den Owner Dennis dann setzen, damit ich da ohne Sudo rein installieren kann? Das ist ja ein bisschen bekloppt, oder?
Sie machen, also, das muss man tatsächlich dazu sagen, die haben halt so diesen Film irgendwie alles ohne Sudo, alles unter eigenem Präfix und so weiter. Und was sie halt per Default machen, ist tatsächlich in deinem Home einen Punkt Homebrew oder sowas zu legen.
Das ist ja okay, das ist ja auch mein Home.
Aber sie symlinken das dann mit User Local oder so. Aber du hast halt die Variante, das ist halt so der Dumm-User-Weg. Du willst halt kein Sudo und willst sie gar nicht so mit Permissions konfrontieren, aber du hast halt jetzt auch die Wahl, das so als, so wie man es halt eigentlich macht, mit User Local und Sudo und keine Ahnung, was mit richtigem User zu installieren. Hab ich auch gemacht, weil mir das auch stinkt, dass jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn du einen Apache installierst und den startest, läuft der als dein Huckel-User oder Tim-User. Und das will ich halt zum Beispiel nicht, weil ich schon mein Setup auf einem Notebook so haben will, wie es dann letztendlich auch draußen so ein bisschen ist. Und ich jetzt nicht so darauf Wert lege, irgendwie Sudo nicht eintippen zu müssen oder sowas, aber...
Aber gerade, aber das finde ich wiederum cool. Also so ein Postgresql, aber dann auch irgendwie als ich laufen zu haben, das wirklich nur mein Setup ist. Und dann kann ich nämlich mir auch sozusagen spezielle User dafür einrichten. Also sozusagen einfach das Laufen lassen.
Dann hast du auch eine Time Machine drin und sowas, was eigentlich gar nicht so verkehrt ist.
Ja und du kannst halt, also ich hab das halt so gemacht, ich hab mir meinen Homebrew auf meine Datenpartition gelegt und hab das einfach auch nach userlocke gesümlinkt. Und das funktioniert halt. Also du kannst es dir hinschieben, wo du willst und du kannst auch andere Präfixes dir auswählen, wenn du willst, aber dieses installieren mit einer Command-Line, so hast du ja einfach nur einen Command-Curl, der lädt dir irgendeinen Bash-Script runter oder einen Ruby-Script, was das alles dir an Start bringt und du kannst es halt instantan loslegen. Und ja, also die ist schon auch extrem cool. Es ist extrem schnell, damit Software zu installieren. Und ich bin auch der Meinung, dass sie das mit dem, man kann ja bei Make sagen, dass er mehrere CPUs benutzen soll. Und Magpods hat eigentlich seit Version 1.8 sagen sie, dass sie das auch bei den Ports machen, die das unterstützen, was mittlerweile eigentlich so 80% oder so sind von Software, die dieses Multi-Kern-Bauen unterstützen. Aber ich hab halt PostgreSQL mit Magpods gebaut und PostgreSQL mit Brew. Und Brew war irgendwie dreimal so schnell. Und ich weiß, also Brew hat beide Kerne ausgelastet, weil Magpods, weiß ich nicht. Also es hat länger gedauert, keine Ahnung warum. Also ich konnte es nicht so richtig nachvollziehen. Also Homebrew, nachdem ich erst übel skeptisch dabei war, muss ich sagen, macht das doch jetzt echt einen ganz guten Eindruck. Also war mal ein echt erfrischender Ansatz, dieses Package Port-Management mal aufzudröseln.
Kann man das dann auch ohne User-Lokne machen, dass man sich sozusagen seine Ports nur in seinem Home macht?
Sie legen das ja in deinem Home und Symbolen glaube ich per Default, aber das Argument dafür, das sozusagen mit User-Local zu machen ist, dass es eben schon in deinem Pfad ist und du dann halt nicht nochmal irgendwo in deiner Shell-Konfig sagen musst, dass jetzt auch noch in meinen Pfad inkludieren. Nee, User-Local ist im Pfad. Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, ganz sicher.
Hast du selber gemacht, können wir rücken.
Also auf jeden Fall nicht S-Bin.
Aber User-Local...
Die Ordner gibt es doch nicht mehr. User-Local-Bin und User-Local-S-Bin musst du immer voneinander legen.
Aber User-Local ist da und ist auch in deinem Pfad.
User-Local-Bin ist drin, aber User-Local-S-Bin ist nicht drin. Damit ist es eigentlich auch nur halb.
Keine Ahnung, ich musste da nichts machen, das funktioniert. So, ich hab diesen Mac Mini, der frisch ankam, haben wir nichts gemacht, außer Xcode zu installieren. Vielleicht macht Xcode das ja, wenn du das installierst. Keine Ahnung. Dass er dir dann so eine User-Local schon hinlegt. Aber ich hab's nicht manuell angelegt.
Ja, ein Argument, was auch noch für Homebrew sprechen könnte, ist, dass sie ja behaupten, dass sie weniger als Mac-Ports alles neu installieren. Also wenn du irgendein Perl-Tool installieren willst, dann musst du bei Mac-Ports erst mal Perl installieren, weil er halt nicht gegen das System linken will und so weiter. Das heißt, ich glaube im Falle von Perl ist es dann auch tatsächlich so, dass bei Brew das so ist. Außerdem, was mir auch aufgefallen ist, ihr wolltet zum Beispiel mehr Kurial installieren, was ja eigentlich Python-Software ist. Und während das bei Mac-Ports halt einfach so ein Port ist und dann kommt erst mal Python und der ganze Gürlerotz, der da noch hinterher ist, sondern dann hast du eben für viele Python-Pakete auch noch Mac-Ports. Und das ist dann eben... Brew kam mir dann einfach entgegen und meinte so, du musst eigentlich nur... wie war das? Python installieren, das dann doch, das hat mich ein bisschen überrascht, weil ja Python eigentlich schon da war, aber ich glaube, die Version reichte nicht aus. Und dann soll man doch irgendwie Pip installieren und dann von da weitermachen. Also sozusagen sie verweisen dann auf die sprachspezifischen Installer. Also mir scheint das einfach sehr viel näher an diesen Subwelten. Bei Ruby ist es ja dann Jam und bei Python ist es Pip oder Easy Install. Ich blicke das immer nicht so ganz durch, was es da alles gibt, wie auch immer. Bruh scheint definitiv mehr so dieser schlanke Ansatz zu sein.
Ja, die haben auf jeden Fall genau gar keinen Bock da drauf, dass jetzt wirklich alles doppelt rumliegen muss. Also einerseits finde ich das halt total cool, dass mein ganzes Opt Local von MacPorts mit einem Delete weg ist und ich das hin und her moveen kann, umbenen, denn es ist self-contained. Das hat durchaus auch seinen Vorteil. Aber es nimmt halt auch viel Platz mit und wenn du halt eine Software schon mitgeliefert hast, die du benutzen kannst, dann spricht auch einfach in vielen Fällen nichts dagegen, die mit zu benutzen. Und Pearl ist halt gerade so ein Beispiel, wenn du frisch anfängst und du denkst, ich will jetzt mal nur eine, keine Ahnung, irgendeine kleine Popel-Software installieren, dann fängt er dir erstmal mit so einem halben Open Source-Universum, was er dir da ausfaltet. Das ist auch schon anstrengend. Vielleicht war er genau deswegen Postgres mit Brew schneller gebaut, weil er dann nicht noch mal die ganzen Dependencies holen musste. Ja, also ich glaube, die sind jetzt echt auf einem ganz guten Weg. Also es lohnt sich. Ich werde das jetzt die nächsten Wochen einfach versuchen, als Macpods Ersatzkonsequenz zu nutzen. Und dann vielleicht beim nächsten Mal kann ich euch noch mal sagen, was dann...
Ich habe das jetzt auch auf meinem alten Macbook drauf. Und da mal gucken, wie es mir so geht.
Und vor allen Dingen ist das halt auch so ein Ansatz, der natürlich auf anderen Plattformen genauso gut funktionieren könnte, theoretisch.
Dieses Git, das kommt echt überall. Du hast heute irgendwie was gepostet mit diesen GitHub-Wikis. Weißt du noch, wir haben nochmal ein CRE gemacht über Git und da haben wir auch über diesen Aspekt mit... Da könnte man doch ganz gut Wikis mitmachen.
Na im Prinzip schon, aber es gab ja schon vorher irgendwie Git-backed-Wikis, aber die GitHub-Jungs sind einfach so cool drauf. Die haben halt irgendwie ihr Wikisystem jetzt aufgebaut, eben komplett auf Git basiert. Das heißt, die History ist eine Git-History. Kannst du auch diffen? Was macht dein iPad da jetzt gerade? Wiki, aufgebohrt. Und nicht nur, dass sie das jetzt eben so cool aufgebohrt haben, sondern sie haben halt die Library, die das benutzt, eben auch gleich mal mit rausgetan, dass die Leute das halt forken können und runterladen und Fixes mal halt machen können.
Meine ich doch auch.
Frisch installiert, ist nicht da.
Und dann ist es vielleicht mit Xcode. Ich hab's nicht in den Pfad eingetragen. Gibt's so? Nein.
Also ich muss es auch jedes Mal eintragen, ich muss jedes Mal mein VJET-Kommando da reinschieben und alles erzählen und dann hast du dein Home mit übernommen und da ist es natürlich noch. Obwohl, ne, hat mit dem Home nichts zu tun.
Ich hab einen frischen Mac installiert, iMac. Und nur Xcode und dann Brew. Nix weiter. Ging. Keine Ahnung. Also ich guck noch mal nach, aber... Ich check mal.
Ihr könnt dem Huckel alle ne Mail schreiben.
Vielleicht haben wir ja irgends so ein... Ja, genau. Check, schreibt mir alle ne Mail. Also ich hab's halt lokal auf meiner Maschine und auf der dritten, wo ich's gemacht hab, hab ich's halt von Hand irgendwie mir sowieso in eine andere Location gelegt.
Also ich muss immer, wenn ich neu installiere, User Local bin und User Local erst bin, anlegen und User Local auch. Weil deswegen geht das MKD auch immer nicht, weil User Local auch nicht da ist. Deswegen muss ich immer erst User Local machen oder mit Minus-P-Option oder so.
Hast du das vor dem Xcode installieren?
Aber Xcode installiert auch gar nichts da rein. Warum sollte der den anlegen? Also da ist nichts von Xcode in User Local.
Na, weil du, wenn du Software baust, ja, dann sollte die ja nach User Local installiert werden.
Hast du vielleicht irgendwelche andere Software installiert, die irgendwie User Local braucht? Installierst du mal gleich neuste Ruby-Update oder so ein Scheiß? Wir können, ja, ihr könnt ja nicht das immer machen.
Total, aber...
Ist doch geil!
Ich könnte dir noch die religiöse Diskussion aufmachen, dass man User Local ja sowieso nicht benutzen sollte, aber da sparen wir uns jetzt lieber doch. Damit Max auch wieder mitreden darf.
Nee, das geht gar nicht. Also opt ist slash opt ist.
Aber ich dachte, gegen Ende der Sendung können wir auch noch mal so richtig krass nerdisch werden.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall hier diese Wiki-Geschichte, also GitHub ist total cool. Die sind einfach so cool. Die sind so nerd-kompatibel. Da gibt es ja auch diesen, wenn du halt bei einem Projekt kollaborierst, und das kann ja echt schnell passieren, dass du da irgendwie mal hinzugefügt wirst, oder da kriegst du ja mal so Notifications, ein neuer Issue eröffnet wurde oder irgendwas passiert ist, und dann kriegst du in deine Mailbox ganz viele Mails, die du vielleicht gar nicht haben willst. Und jetzt haben sie so eine kleine Feature hinzugefügt, dass sie den ListID-Header setzen mit dem Projektnamen. Und du kannst jetzt diese Notifications schick in deinem Mail kleinfiltern oder auf dem Server. Die machen so lauter so kleine...
Du wirst begeistert...
.was das Nerd-Herz erfreut.
So.
Bokentracker hat jetzt übrigens auch Flatter.
Wenn wir schon beim 2-0, äh, Web 2-0 sind, dann können wir...
Web 2-0.
Dann können wir jetzt aber flattern. Ich glaub, wir brauchen hier noch ein bisschen Sauerstoff.
Aber so Git hat an letzter Zeit natürlich auch mit großer, mit wachsender Begeisterung, weil das ist echt sehr schön gemacht. Also erstmal natürlich so dieses, dieses, dieses... Dieses Clone, es ist jetzt, nachdem ich langsam mal verstanden habe, dass es eine Versionskontrolle ist, ist es wirklich wesentlich angenehmer als SVN.
Versionskontrolle?
Das ist doch, also jetzt langsam kapiere ich auch den Unterschied zu SVN und die geradeige Geschwindigkeit.
Versuche nicht auch eine Versionskontrolle.
Aber gibt es eigentlich gar nicht eine Versionskontrolle? Gibt es eigentlich einen Content-Tracker? Du steckst Content rein und er gibt dir einen Hashtag dafür wieder. So und du kannst diesen Content da drin diffen und dieses Versionieren, ja, das ist also dieser Graph, den sie da drüber geklebt haben, der ist halt drüber geklebt. Also das Core-System ist echt nur ein Content-Tracker. Content reinschieben, Hasht zurück. Und dann haben sie halt dazu, also für die Versionskontroll-Applikation haben sie sozusagen diesen Graph drüber gebaut, der halt diese ganzen Hashes miteinander...
Macht vielleicht Sinn, das zu trennen. Da kann man nur sagen, dass im nächsten Xcode, wovon es ja auch für Developer schon eine Beta gibt, gibt es auch Git-Support.
Die Git hab ich schon gesehen und der ist extrem cool. Also dieses Version-Control-Interface von Xcode 4 ist extrem...
Ja, ist dann auch optisch so wie Time Machine. Du kannst dann so einen Slider, die die Version aussuchen und dann da diffen, machen, tun. Ich weiß nicht, haben die auch Merch-Support? Keine Ahnung, aber...
Also Xcode 4 sieht gut aus.
Es gibt zunächst keine Ausrede mehr.
Also ich hab mir auch mal ein paar von diesen Developer-Sessions von der WWDC angeschaut. Also Xcode 4 ist echt ein massiver Schritt nach vorne. Es gibt zwar jetzt wieder viele, die rummeckern mit ich will mein Video im Fenster wieder haben, weil sie ja jetzt Single-Window jetzt auch für Development machen, so iTunes für Programming.
Naja, das sieht wirklich nach iTunes aus.
Da muss ich nochmal gucken, ob es cool ist, kann man erst sagen, wenn man wirklich damit arbeiten muss.
Aber ich hab mir mal so angeschaut, was sie so unter der Haube gemacht haben. Und da ist ja ein alter Freund von mir gerade ganz groß umkommen. Kurz gesagt, Apple schmeißt mit iOS 4 GCC raus. Und zwar vollständig. GCC, das Compiler-Schlachtschiff der letzten 20 Jahre.
Das ist so richtig komplett weg? Oder nicht mehr Default?
Es ist nicht mehr der Default. Wenn du ein neues Projekt machst...
Vor allem einen Klang.
Genau. Das muss man vielleicht noch mal kurz erläutern. Jetzt sind wir wirklich in der totalen... Also wenn er jetzt eh schon irgendwie das zu...
Also jetzt noch zuhört, hat es nicht anders verdient.
Ja, aber ich finde das sehr interessant. Weil das ist jetzt sagen wir mal auch...
Oh, wir dürfen gar nicht über Xcode 4 reden. Alles in die Acer-Seilern-Chat.
Wir können das ja nicht unterschrieben. Wir müssen einfach nur die Klappe halten. Also ich muss...
Ich gebe nur wieder, was mir übers Internet zugetragen wurde. Ja, drauf geschissen. Also die Wahrheit ist einfach, es gibt jetzt LLVM.
Warum ist das Steve Jobs und warum hat er eine Bazooka?
Jungs, LLVM ist dieses neue Compiler Framework. Da habe ich schon mal ein CRE zugemacht. Da haben wir glaube ich auch schon mal drüber geredet. Und davon ist jetzt die neue Version rausgekommen. Das ist ja jetzt auch kein Geheimnis, sondern das ist bei LLVM Org so dabei. Und was Apple gemacht hat ist, erstens, dass sie jetzt diese neue Version reingebaut haben. Sie haben diesen Compiler, die neue Version, von diesem C lang oder Klang, wie auch immer man das aussprechen möchte, auch mit reingebaut. Ja, Klang, ich würde lieber C lang sagen, aber wie auch immer, ist auf jeden Fall dabei. Und die Neuerung, die Wesentliche ist die, dass es jetzt eben auch komplett C++ kann. Und zwar alles, und zwar mehr als GCC. Echt? Sie erfüllen alle C++-Standards. Vollständig. Und haben das auch irgendwie gepriesen. Aber das Coole ist, dass eben sie jetzt darauf, dass sie nicht nur das jetzt so dabei haben, sondern dieser Parser von diesem C lang. Also das Tool, was quasi diese erste Stufe macht. Ich nehme die ganze Syntax auseinander und verstehe überhaupt erst mal, was der Programmierer da im Code hat.
Macht das Objective-C sozusagen zu C.
Das war ganz früher so. Objective-C war eigentlich...
Makros.
Und da gab es einen Präprozess, in dem der C-Boss machte das.
Drei brechete Sprachen sozusagen.
Also ich hab irgendwie halt vor einer Weile immer noch gehört, so dass das immer noch so ein bisschen so Präprozess wird, bevor es kompiliert wird. Ja, nimmt LLVM und macht da irgendwie...
Ja, das Besondere ist, während es bei GCC ist, ist es ja so, da hast du irgendwie einen Parser in diesem GCC, dann hast du in deinem GDB, hast du nochmal einen anderen Parser. Und wenn du in deinem Development-Environment dir ein Syntax-Coloring machen willst, dann musst du halt auch nochmal deinen eigenen Parser schreiben, weil du kannst ja in so kommerzielle Ware keinen GPL-Code einbauen. Wegen frei.
Und da aber LLVM API basiert ist?
Nein, weil LLVM einfach BSD-Lizenz ist.
Und das auch, ja. Aber auch, dass es halt ein API ist, auf die jedes Programm irgendwie sauber zugreifen kann und nicht irgendwelche Command-Line durchstarten muss.
Genau, ist nämlich jetzt dieser Parser von diesem C-Compiler überall drin. Das heißt, das, was dir der Programmeditor quasi da hinpasst, während du es tippst, und du kannst da irgendwie, während du tippst, ja, irgendwie deine Fehler korrigieren lassen.
Das ist gleich der echte Parser, der auch später...
Genau, und der auch für den Debugger verwendet wird und so weiter.
Der jetzt übrigens LDB heißt.
Genau.
Das heißt, sie haben jetzt im Prinzip das ganze GNU Compiler Framework komplett abgelöst. Und könnten das jetzt eigentlich ab jetzt weglassen. Sie meinen auch, dass sie komplett kompatibel sind, also auch zu den ganzen GCC-spezifischen Sachen. Und dass sie da halt sowohl schneller compilen, als auch schnelleren Code erzeugen.
Kleineren Code.
Kleineren Code erzeugen. Also es ist...
Link-Time-Optimisation sag ich nur.
Es ist der totale Roundup. Also es ist wirklich ein schweres Geschütz, was sie da auffahren.
Ich hoffe, es kommt auch langsamer.
Wann soll das so?
Also bei Apple gibt es eine Beta 2 inzwischen. Die erste Beta war glaube ich closed für Special Groups irgendwie. Die zweite gibt es jetzt so seit zwei, drei Wochen oder so. Keine Ahnung wann es kommt. Jetzt ist jetzt August, wir wollen mal hoffen, Oktober.
Zur nächsten WWDC.
Nee, das kommt vorher. Da hättest du es nicht Beta genannt.
Und jetzt stellt sich natürlich so die Frage, was hat denn das eigentlich für Konsequenzen für das nächste Mac OS? Also ist eine Frage, die ich mir gestellt habe. Gibt es eigentlich schon irgendwelche Gerüchte?
Erschreckend ruhig, oder?
Na, nachdem die letzte WBDC komplett iPhone war oder iOS oder was auch immer.
Na, ich finde, das sollten die auch mal auftrennen, dann ist der Laden auch nicht mehr so voll, sonst haben die ja so ein Problem wie wir mit dem BCC.
Das hab ich mir auch sagen lassen.
Weil da haben die die Tage mal diese iPhone WBDC ausverkauft.
Ach gut, es gab ja in der Mac-Landschaft nicht viel Neues zu berichten, aber ich muss sagen, dass mir so ein bisschen...
Ich hab bei Apple nichts berichtet, deswegen.
Na ja gut, aber man kann ja auch mal so ein bisschen eins und eins zusammenzählen und viele Sachen haben sich ja irgendwie geradezu aufgedrängt, aber mittlerweile gehen mir so ein bisschen die Offensichtlichkeiten aus. Das Einzige, was wirklich bei mir ganz oben steht, ist die Sache mit dem Datalsystem.
Ja, das halt...
Aber da haben wir hier schon mal ausführlich drüber geklagt, das müssen wir jetzt nicht wiederholen. Das ist einfach der größte Fail eigentlich in diesem ganzen OS.
Wobei ihr habt noch nie mit NTFS gearbeitet. Offensichtlich. Ihr habt noch nie mit NTFS gearbeitet.
Ich sage ja nicht, dass nicht andere Betriebssysteme nicht dasselbe Problem haben. Also alle haben eigentlich das Problem, dass sie mit alten Filesystem-Konzepten sich rumschlagen müssen. Also ihr habt auch keinen Tipp.
Wahrscheinlich, ich habe eine Idee. Also Apple zum Beispiel, bei den iPhones und iPads, da sieht man ja, der User kommt ja gar nicht mehr ins Filesystem ran und dann wird es auch nicht mehr so Hardcore-mäßig benutzt, wie man das hier auf so einem Laptop macht, wo man irgendwie mit Command-Länder irgendwie Permissions setzen kann und Zeug man kann oder was der Geier, was du hier alles machen kannst. Und das geht ja irgendwie alles nicht mehr. Und vielleicht denkt sich Apple, Scheiße, wir brauchen ja nicht mehr so ein super cooles Filesystem.
Na doch, du brauchst ja immer noch das Filesystem drunter. Das ist ja nur die Metapher da drüber, die anders ist.
Aber so kannst du ja definitiv... definiert darauf zugreifen. Also wenn ich mir ja der User da so rumfuschen kann, sondern du machst das selber, vielleicht packen die in der Zukunft ihre Sachen mehr so in irgendwelchen DBs oder sonstiges und müssen gar nicht mehr so ein Hardcore-Filesystem haben.
Tja, das mit den DBs, das hat ja auch nicht so richtig gut funktioniert. Das hat ja Microsoft schon mal probiert.
Mit WinFS oder was? Das ist ja auch in die Hose gegangen. Ja, aber die wollten ja ein Filesystem basierend auf einer Datenbank haben.
Wenn sie was bauen, dann wollen sie das auf jeden Fall auch auf dem iPhone haben. Dann wollen sie das auf jeden Fall auch auf kleinen Devices haben. Das heißt, das muss irgendwie schlank sein. Aber es muss auch irgendwie modern sein. Es muss zumindest die wichtigsten Dinge, die wichtigsten Sachen, muss es irgendwie haben. Es muss Snapshots haben. Es muss die Möglichkeit haben, so Growing Volumes zu haben, dass man eben schnell so Rates zusammenbauen und mit den Snapshots dann halt auch so das Sinken oder meinetwegen auch das Diffen. Und auch so diese Latest-Features so mit Files gleich erkennen am Hasch. Also, blöcke, genau, dieses Deduplizieren. Dass man einfach, ja, du kopierst irgendwie 20 Gigabyte und es ist eine Sekunde später fertig, weil...
Da hat gemerkt, es ist ja der gleiche Scheiß.
Es ist der gleiche Scheiß, du musst es dann nicht nochmal...
Copy on write ist das Stichwort. Übrigens fehlt auch, sagt unser externer Reporter, dass auch nach dem Xcode installiert kein User-Loke da ist.
Hat der das jetzt extra gemacht oder was?
Glaub ich nicht, glaube ich, muss er herkommen. Muss er wohl für einen clean installten Mac OS herwarten.
Und einen original gekauften Mac OS 1060 CD4D.
Jetzt haben wir auf jeden Fall einen Titel für die Sendung.
Loser-Loke. Aber Tim, gibt es denn hier noch dieses Job-Hiring von dem Special Highly Qualified File System Engineer von Apple? Ist das noch auf der Webseite?
Weiß ich nicht.
Weil das war ja, nachdem sie ZFS abgesägt hatten, kam ja dann dieses Job-Offer damit. Wir suchen jetzt mal hier den File System-Gott für...
Aber so ein Dateisystem, kann das eigentlich noch ohne Netz funktionieren? Also ist nicht das eigentlich der nächste? Wo jetzt gerade das mit dem Hashtag, das ist ja so, ich kenne das von Dropbox halten. Wenn man bei Dropbox ist, dann ist man ganz schnell, dass das Ganze ja auch ein bisschen cloudbasiert ist. Dann ist Apple ja gerade auch schön dabei, dieses riesengigantische Rechenzentrum aufzubauen, von dem nach wie vor niemand so richtig weiß, wofür es gut ist. Und insofern würde ich sagen, Dennis, du hast recht. Das Dateisystem hat vielleicht nicht mehr so eine hohe Priorität, nicht weil der User nicht rankommt, sondern weil der Scheiß irgendwo liegt, halt in der berühmten Wolke.
Du brauchst die Daten einfach erstmal sicher auf deiner Platte.
Ja, aber das können wir doch für dich machen.
Das ist nicht das Thema für die nächsten 20 Jahre.
Vielleicht mal die Mengen, die du auf deinem Rechnerlokal hast, mit dem, was du wirklich online hast. Das steht alles in keinem Verhältnis.
Die Proportionen werden sich immer weiter ändern.
Was hast du alles lokal auf deinem Rechnerlokal? Also du hast jetzt bestimmt tausende Sachen, aber ich bei mir so gucke, alles voll mit Filmen.
Ich habe einfach meine ganzen Projekt-Orten.
Aber du bist kein normaler User mehr. Du bist ja jemand, der damit arbeitet. An so einer Leute denkt Apple doch gar nicht mehr.
Was?
Ich meine, du hast doch wirklich... Na doch, denken sie schon noch.
Das ist aber anders.
Was?
Ich bitte dich.
Aber im Wesentlichen hast du wahrscheinlich viele Audio-Aufnahmen, die sehr groß sind. Okay, das wird man vielleicht erst mal in den nächsten 5, 6 Jahren vielleicht noch nicht irgendwo haben. Aber dieses ganze, irgendwelche Textdateien, irgendwelche Zusammenfassungen, irgendwelche Entwürfe, irgendwie dieses ganze kleine Kribbel, das kannst du doch eigentlich schon jetzt. Also bei mir finde ich es immer wieder erstaunlich, wie viel von meinem Zeug eigentlich auf diese Dropbox drauf passt. Also klar, da sind eine Handvoll Filme irgendwo oder ein paar MP3s, die noch irgendwo rumfliegen. Und die Fotosammlung, die ich jetzt nicht da drauf habe, aber der ganze Rest, der passt doch problemlos in eine Dropbox rein. Mit ihren 5 GB.
Der ganze Rest.
Ja, Dropbox hin, Dropbox her. Also ich benutze Dropbox sehr gerne und viel für Kollaboration mit anderen Leuten. Aber ich benutze das nicht, um da meine eigenen Sachen zu sichern. Weil 5 GB ist ein Scheiß.
Also ich nutze das, um die Sachen auf allen Rechnern da zu haben.
Ja, aber auch 100 GB, da komme ich nirgends wohin.
Wie gesagt, lass deine ganzen Audio-Files weg und du kommst mit 100 GB, das ist auch nicht was.
Meine ganzen Projektdaten sind der Großteil und das sind locker 300 GB. 300 GB sind meine Projektdaten. Ja, also allein, was weiß ich hier, so Blinkenlight, Stereoscope, das ist einfach 70 GB, da sind Videos drauf, da sind tonnenweise Fotoarchive drauf und die will ich nicht immer irgendwo in eine komischen Festplatte in Arizona abspeichern.
Warum nicht?
Was sollen die denn da? Dann brennt da Arizona ab und dann sind meine Daten weg?
Dann werden sie noch mal in einem Rechenzentrum in...
Nix da, ich pass auf meine Daten selber auf. Ich will da nicht irgendwie da...
Ja, du, aber das ist doch was...
Die Amerikaner, die kriegen da nicht mal genug Strom für ihren Scheiß zusammen. Ja, also... Ich bitte dich.
Also ich hatte ernsthaft drüber nachgedacht, so wegen dieser ganzen SSD-Diskussion, ob ich nicht, also auch genau diese, komm ich vielleicht mit 128 GB einfach aus? Kriegst du irgendwie hingebogen, dass sich das 128 GB genug sind? Ich kaufe mir einen Flickr-Account, um die ganzen Fotos hochzuladen und so dieses ganze Zeug. Und ich glaube, es wird...
Das Gesicht von Tim müsste die jetzt dabei sehen.
So totales Unverständnis. Ich glaube, ich könnte meine Daten, zumindest ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es bei deinen Daten ist, meine Daten könnte ich so weit zusammenschrumpfen, dass ich, ja, ich bräuchte noch irgendwo eine riesengroße Festplatte und meinetwegen soll die auch in einem Rechner, in einem Server, bei mir zu Hause stehen erstmal. Aber die muss nicht zwangsläufig in dem Gerät drin sein, was ich die ganze Zeit mit mir rumschleppe.
Nein, das muss sie nicht unbedingt. Ich habe ja hier auch dieses bekloppte Drobo-Teil und denke auch immer wieder über andere Auslagerungssysteme nach.
Man möchte bloß von unterwegs auch so ein Foto greifen können.
Ja, man will es auch an mehreren Orten haben und sicher haben. Man will es auch mal ohne Internet haben können. Das ist auch sehr wichtig, weil man sieht ja wieder, wie zuverlässig das hier ist. Man fängt hier eine Radiosendung an und dann raucht einem irgendein komisches Device ab und dann war es was mit Internet.
Da kann man immer noch Telefone machen.
Super, das funktioniert bestimmt immer. Die Diskussion, von der wir kamen, ist, muss noch ein neues Dateisystem erfunden werden? Die Antwort lautet ja, auf jeden Fall.
Aber ich sage, dieses Dateisystem muss auch das Netz mit berücksichtigen.
Ja, wird es ja auch. Das kann es ja gerne tun. Das ist ja auch schon total hier. Du kannst ja Snapshots hin und her schicken.
Aber Snapshots sind der Schlüssel an der Stelle. Also wenn du Snapshots machen kannst, so wie bei ZFS, dann ist Sinken übers Netz, das ist ja bei ZFS mit drin.
Also es ist ja schon nicht mit drin. Ich möchte nicht nur Sinken, ich möchte auch, dass ich quasi, so wie für ganz schnelle Daten habe ich eine SSD, für nicht so ganz so schnelle Daten habe ich eine Festplatte und für diesen ganzen großen Rest habe ich eine Festplatte irgendwo.
Achso, dass du sozusagen so ein Volumen machst, das so gleich...
Genau. Aber das könntest du mit ZFS auch schon bauen.
Wie?
Ja schade, dass das ZFS tot ist.
Na, irgendwie deinen Cloud Storage kannst du dir als, was weiß ich, iSCSI, Volumen...
Ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum ich niemals ZFS mag, weil das so ein extremer Datalys...
Und dann packst du die alle in einen Tank und dann das ZFS macht, aber dann ist hier, du bist auf der ZFS-Platte. Wenn du eine SSD und eine Festplatte drin hast, dann kannst du auch sagen, dass die SSD fast...
Der Cache, du kannst sie als Cache nutzen. Dann werden alle Daten, die du nennst, Workset oder dafür ist es da, dass dein Workset ist, meistens nur 10 Gig groß, dann sind die immer auf dem Cache, weil der merkt, du hast da oft drauf zugegriffen, dann lagert die dir dazwischen. Und für Schreiben kann man das sogar auch machen, das ist dann das, glaube ich, ZFS Intention Log, der kann das gleiche für Sachen machen, die du schnell wegschreiben willst, das Ding nimmt das schnell an, beichert die schnell dazwischen und sagt sofort okay und das wird später alles gesünd.
Also mal abgesehen davon, ich denke mal, das kommt auf jeden Fall auch mit einfach bei dem nächsten Fallsystem, so eine Fähigkeit.
Habe ich letztens auch schon mit einem Kumpel drüber irgendwie so illusioniert, dass eigentlich so ein Rechner mit so einer 640 Gig-Platte kommen müsste und noch mit schon auf dem Board irgendwie so 16 Gig oder 32 Gig irgendwie so Ultra-Flash aufgelötet, also nicht hier als SSD kaufbar, sondern schon auf dem Board mit drauf. Und dass man das sagt, das ist jetzt irgendwie der beschleuniger Cash hier für meine Platte und alles läuft über den Flash. Oder man nutzt den Flash einfach wirklich nur, um davon zu booten und der Rest ist irgendwie die Daten.
Nein, du willst auch Ups und so und also willst schon auch Daten von dieser schnellen Platte haben und nur so diese HD-Movies dann so auf dieses 500 GB Monster da so rauf rotieren lassen.
Also ich finde die Idee mit dem Zideal auf der Grosse, das muss ich erstmal drüber nachdenken.
Aber ich wollte jetzt eigentlich meine uralte Kiste nicht mehr aufpeppen. Ich wollte ja eigentlich verschrotten und mir so ein sowas holen.
Du kannst das ja, bei deinem ist das ja auch nicht so.
Du hast ja keinen Satta, oder?
Du hast Satta, CD-Laufwerk?
Ich glaube, bei denen ist das schon auch so. Also da gab es auf jeden Fall auch diese Bauart, ich weiß jetzt nicht ab welchem Modell, aber irgendwann ging das.
Das sieht aber auch schon wieder ganz schön kamponiert aus.
Das ist runtergefallen letztens. Nochmal. Auf die Seite und irgendwann früher mal auf die Seite.
Ist halt kein Unibody, wa?
Und wie beim letzten Mal schon vor drei Jahren, ist es voll runtergekloppt, auf Kachelboden und ich klapp's auf und er lief noch. Oder er ist dann aufgewacht, weil er war im Schlafmodus. Und ist nicht mal abgekackt.
Das hab ich irgendwann mal im Flughafen gesehen, wie so ein 17-Jähriger mit seinem MacBook. Und dann hat er irgendwie das MacBook da liegen, weil er es halt aus der Tasche rausnehmen musste, wegen Sicherheitskontrolle. Und dann macht das mal eben wirklich so einen schönen Satz unten runter auf den Boden.
Geschlossen aber noch.
Und der nimmt es wirklich so komplett ungerührt, ohne auch nur eine Gese zu verziehen. Ich hätte ja in dem Moment wahrscheinlich geschrien. Nimmt er das hoch, packst es wieder ein, guckt nicht nach, ob es geht. Also ich wahrscheinlich hab das gerade 10 Minuten vorher im Geschäftsbank geklaut oder sowas. Egal, ob es geht oder nicht.
Ich bin aber froh, dass die Bombe nicht hoch geht.
Fuck, dass er doch an die Hose gehen kann. Mir ist noch was eingefallen, was ich finde, was ein echt großes Problem ist auf Mac und was eigentlich dringend mal gefixt werden muss. Und wo ich eigentlich auch alle Möglichkeiten bei Apple sehe, das mal zu lösen, wenn sie den nur wollen. Und das ist mir neulich wieder aufgefallen, als ich hier... Also ich hab das Problem, diese Installation, die ich hier gerade fahre, auf diesem Rechner, die ist einfach langsam. Und die war auf meinem Macbook langsam und ich hab die jetzt auf das neue Macbook Pro raufmigriert und es ist immer noch langsam. Pausen, fünf Sekunden... Ich hab jetzt dasselbe Verhalten mit drei verschiedenen Festplatten auf zwei verschiedenen Computern gehabt. Mit dieser Installation. Und mittlerweile bin ich total davon überzeugt, dass das einfach im Arsch ist. Das ist einfach diese... Ich weiß nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung was. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich hab einiges schon disabled. Ohne Ende. Bloß dann bin ich auch wirklich irgendwann auf den Punkt gekommen, dass ich schon gar nicht mehr wusste, was jetzt eigentlich noch dazu gehört und was nicht. Es ist wie bei Mac OS 9 damals. Schlimmer eigentlich noch. Du hast tausend Dateien in deinem System, du hast im Extensions und Tralala und Library-Foo und du hast keine Ahnung, was eigentlich zu was gehört. Skipp, Skipp, Skipp.
Auf meinem iPhone.
Nein. Ich meine, auf deinem iPhone, wenn du was deinstallierst, was machst du da? Da drückst du irgendwie eine Sekunde drauf, dann kommt das X, dann machst du X und sagst du Ja und dann ist weg.
Wenn was verdalet liegen bleibt.
Genau, siehst du es halt nur nicht.
Genau. Okay, deswegen.
Ja, aber wir wissen, das ist alles isoliert. Jedes Programm hat irgendwie seine eigene Sandbox, hat seinen eigenen Pfeilsystembereich. Die teilen sich untereinander gar nichts, sondern die ganze Kommunikation läuft nur noch über Apis. Und vor allem, das OS installiert alles und es deinstalliert alles. Auf dem Mac ist es einfach mal ein Scheiß. Da gibt es im besten Fall einen Installer, den manche dann benutzen und andere dann aber wieder nicht.
Wir sind immer die Programme lieber, die keinen benutzen. Mir auch. Da weiß ich, die machen keinen Scheiß. Zumindest nicht so viel.
Ja gut, aber auch die...
Nicht so wie Google, die da ihren Updater installieren, ohne nachzufragen.
Aber auch die Dinger, die du nur so drauf trägst. Die startest du und die gucken dann erstmal, ist denn meine Extension schon installiert? Nein, und dann installieren sie die noch. Und wenn du danach die abweg schmeißt, dann hast du deine Extension immer noch drin. Und dann hast du irgendwelche blöden Start-up-Skripte in Libraries Start-up-Skripts. Und dann andere installieren irgendwelche Launch-Demons, die du dann auch irgendwie so nicht siehst. Von denen du auch nicht weißt, dass sie da sind. Von denen du nicht weißt, wann sie sich aktivieren. Also du bist eigentlich hilflos. Und klar, wenn man jetzt sich Tag und Nacht mit seiner Installation beschäftigt, da jedes Pfeil trägt und was weiß ich, irgendwelche Diffs macht und mit diesem Pfeilsystem-Modifikationsmonitor da die ganze Zeit drauf startet, wo denn jetzt ein Installer irgendwas hinschraubt, dann kommst du so halbwegs weiter. Mir ist es jetzt in einem Jahr nicht gelungen, dieses System schnell zu kriegen. Und ich werd wahnsinnig. Was ich erwarte von Mac OS 10.7 ist SSD My S. Ich meine, damit kann ich vielleicht das Langsame beschleunigen, aber ich will das Langsame weg. Ich will nicht das Langsame schneller. Ich will kein Langsam. Das ist nicht das, was ich meine.
Mach dir einen Hackintosh.
Ich will einfach ein OS, was die Möglichkeit bietet, dass ich sagen kann, wenn hier ein Programm installiert wird, dann wird das wie in einer Sandbox gemacht. Da kommt jetzt so ein Tool, ich lad mir das runter vom Internet, dann ist das ein Installationsvorgang. Und in dem Moment, wo das irgendwie kommt und sich drauf installieren will, wird das in so eine Sandbox installiert. Und ist erstmal gekapselt.
Das ist ja wirklich unbegründet.
Du willst deine MacBook Pro jailbreaken müssen.
Ich philosophiere jetzt nur... Nee, ich will jetzt nicht so einen kompletten Kaka haben, mit alles muss signiert sein von Apple und Upstore und so weiter. Das ist nicht das, was ich meine. Und das ist auch nicht das, was ich glaube, dass sie vorhaben. Aber eine Traceability von dem, was so ein System installiert und vor allem auch ein solider Weg, wie man das Ganze deinstalliert, das ist einfach zwingend nötig. Weil mal ehrlich, ich meine, man kann den Mac mögen und toll finden, aber das ist echt nicht mehr State of the Art in der Hinsicht. Ich sage nicht, dass es irgendwas anderes gibt auf dem Desktop, was in der Hinsicht State of the Art ist. Aber schon so bestimmte Linux Package Manager funktionieren da in der Hinsicht besser, weil die zumindest wissen, was sie installieren. Und die wissen auch wieder, was Ideen sind. Nicht, dass es immer funktioniert, aber es gibt diesen Mechanismus zumindest, den gibt es auf dem Mac einfach nicht. So, und das ist nicht okay. Stattdessen muss man sich mit so Sachen wie Homebrew und MacPorts rumschlagen, weil es einfach keinerlei Möglichkeit gibt, irgendwas zu registrieren oder vielleicht auch mal irgendwas sicher zu machen. Ich möchte ja auch mal so ein Tool ausprobieren können aus dem Internet und mir irgendwie das in so eine Seifenblase...
Das ist aber nicht sonderlich stabil.
Nee, aber dann merke ich auf jeden Fall, wenn es Pop macht. Dann weiß ich, dieses Ding hat jetzt irgendwie quergeschlagen und hat außerhalb meines Homes irgendwas benutzt oder außerhalb seiner Sandbox was benutzt.
Ja, außerhalb meines Homes, nur darauf zugreifen oder schreiben. Also, geschrieben solltest du ja merken, weil irgendwann hoffentlich mal nach einem Passwort fragt.
Ja gut, aber dann weißt du immer noch nicht was.
Weißt immer noch nicht was, klar.
Ja gut, aber wenn es zum Beispiel mein Adressbuch absaugen möchte, es gibt keinerlei Möglichkeit in diesem US zu sagen, dass wenn so ein Programm aufs Adressbuch zugreift, dass ich vorher gefragt werde. Also, wie die einzige Sache, die ich kenne, wo das gemacht wird, ist dieses Call Location. Wenn ein Programm wissen möchte, wo ich bin, dann kommt da irgendwie so ein Dialog hoch. Und Keychain natürlich. Aber so könnte ich mir das eben auch vorstellen für ganz andere Sachen, insbesondere für mein Data-System und für mein System vor allem.
Also da muss ich da fürchtig, werden wir noch eine Weile darauf warten müssen, weil das haben sie nicht mehr auf dem iOS hingekriegt. Und da wär's ja wirklich ein Trivial gewesen.
Wie haben sie nicht auf dem iOS hingekriegt?
Naja, auf dem iOS kann ich auch jedes Programm dein Adressbuch absaugen, ohne dass du es merkst.
Vor allen Dingen...
Das stimmt.
Sollten sie auch nochmal einschränken.
Das ist tatsächlich so, dass du denn auch, vor allen Dingen, kriegst du auch über das Adressbuch auch raus, wer du bist, wem das Phone gehört, also welcher Adressrekord jetzt deiner ist und so.
War ja nur ein Beispiel. Klar, könnte man auch darüber nachdenken. Man muss auch aufpassen, dass man nicht in so eine Windows-Vista-Falle fällt. Ja, sozusagen jeder Zugriff auf irgendwas immer mit möchtest du ja, nein und so. Mir geht es auch mehr um diese Rückführbarkeit. Also dieses, soll mir mal sagen, was da passiert ist. Soll mir mal einfach aufzeigen, was wurde angefasst, was ja und dass ich dann die Möglichkeit habe, so die Barrieren zu setzen.
Also bei Android ist das ja so, dass bei der Installation siehst du ja genau, welche Rechte jedes App anfordert und es darf halt nicht jedes App alles. Oder um installiert zu werden, musst du ihm schon alle Rechte geben. Aber du siehst wenigstens vorher, der wird das Recht haben wollen, eine SMS zu verschicken. Und wenn dir das zu kryptisch ist, dann gibt es das eben halt nicht.
Aber der einfache Weg wäre einfach noch so, du installierst das so, stellst fest irgendwas, das ist hier Scheiße oder kannst auch das Receipt nochmal angucken und siehst irgendwie, nee will ich doch nicht. Und dann soll es halt diesen einen Delete-Button hier wie vom iPhone geben und dann soll das halt einfach alles sofort wieder...
Genau, gehen wir weg.
Klar.
Zumindest als Testmodus, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie so Programm XY hier, was weiß ich, dieses komische Alarms, was du mir da gerade vorgeschlagen hast, das hätte ich jetzt gerne runtergeladen und das Einzige, was er macht, ist mit, oh, das kommt aus dem Internet, das kann böse sein. Möchtest du wirklich ja? Und dann sag ich ja und dann bin ich irgendwie geliefert. Aber ihr könnt ja auch sagen, installier in Seifenblase oder Sandkasten.
Aber wenn du Snapshots hast, dann ist es ja halt schon, also die Network...
Now we're talking. Ja, now we're talking. Das wäre ein innovativer Ansatz, dass man halt wirklich sagt, okay, jetzt gibt es hier irgendwie, jetzt gibt es Snapshots.
Aber Snapshots reichen dafür nicht, oder?
Du kannst halt erstens mit deinem, also dass eine Verbindung nach draußen und irgendwas verschickt wird, kannst du ja sowieso schon verhindern.
Ja, klar.
Und dann irgendwie, wenn du jetzt sagst, ich hab jetzt hier einen Kaktool mir runtergeladen, das hat sich überall breit gemacht, dann will ich einfach step back.
Genau, dass du wirklich sagen kannst, ich möchte zehn Minuten zurückgehen, aber nicht wie mit Time Machine, dass ich dann irgendwie stundenlang warte, bis er mir dann von irgendeiner langsamen Festplatte irgendwie die Daten wieder zurückkopiert, sondern einfach rückgängig machen.
Aber ich möchte ja nicht nur das, sondern ich möchte ja auch, dass ich, ich möchte nicht automatisch, also bei einem Snapshot kann ich ja immer quasi nur rückwärts wieder rückgängig machen, oder? Also sozusagen, das ist ein Stapel, auf den ich draufpacke und ich kann immer nur das Oberste wieder runternehmen.
Nee, du kannst beliebig zurückgehen.
Also ich kann auch sagen, ich hab vor drei Wochen dieses Programm installiert und hab seitdem das und das und das nachinstalliert und die Datei selber angelegt und ich möchte den einen Snapshot dazwischen durch raushaben.
Das geht nicht. Da müsste man dann wiederum dieses GitHub-Modell überlegen, ob man nicht sozusagen das ganze OS und das ganze Fallsystem...
Das Git-Dateisystem. Git-FS.
Ja, nee, Git ist nicht dafür ausgelegt, für so große Dateimengen. Damit kommt das nicht klar. Aber klar, ich denke auch, dass wir aus diesem Distributed Version-Control-System und auch aus Git als Content-Storage-System und einfach diese ganzen Mechanismen, dass diese schon Leute inspirieren werden jetzt für die nächsten tollen Projekte genau in diese Richtung. Also das ist jetzt so.
Aber Max, du würdest mir doch zustimmen, es wäre ja schon ein Gewinn, dass ich jetzt so vor dem Installieren von irgendwie einem Toolsage mache jetzt einen Snapshot, dass er mir das sozusagen schon anbietet. Du installierst ein neues Programm aus dem Internet. Möchtest du einen, was auch immer, wie sie das dann nennen würden, wie würde Apple sowas nennen? Du musst da irgendwie so einen Sicherheitskurs anlegen und so weiter, sodass du danach nach 10 Minuten sagen kannst, ich hab jetzt 10 Minuten damit rumgespielt.
Also das ist besser als nichts, aber ich finde, ich hätte schon gern, dass meine Browser-History, die seitdem aufgebaut worden ist, während ich das installiert habe oder während ich das benutze, dass die dann nicht automatisch auch weg ist.
Dann wär's halt so, du Mensch, das ist ja das, was ich meine. Ich möchte das Programm in so einer Seifenblase, dass es sozusagen auch nur einen limitierten Aktionsradius hat und dieser limitierte Aktionsradius ist dann wiederum komplett rücknehmbar.
Du machst halt ein neues Volumen in deinem Tank sozusagen.
Ja, und so einen virtuellen Overlay, irgendeinen Food, dass er sich merkt, die Zugriffe, Kopien und so weiter.
Aber all das, wovon wir gerade sprechen, hat Windows und ich glaube, das will man aus guten Gründen nicht.
Ja, aber Windows hat halt keine Interface-Designer.
Die haben keine Leute, die irgendwie nachdenken.
Aber ich glaube, deren System ist auch so und das finde ich tatsächlich entspannend.
Windows hat Snapshots?
Ich weiß nicht, ob die das auf Datalsystem-Ebene machen, aber man kann da, es macht es vor größeren Installationen automatisch und ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt. Wie heißt denn das? Also es gibt auf jeden Fall schon seit Ewigkeiten, also schon im Wesentlichen aus der Notwendigkeit heraus, dass ihr Betriebssystem gerne so instabil war. NTFS hat Snapshots? Nee, das hatten sie schon vor NTFS. Das hatten sie schon zu Windows 98 Zeiten oder irgendwie sowas. Wie heißt denn das?
Nein, also aber nicht jetzt so, wie wir das gerade beschrieben haben.
Nein, natürlich nicht so schick, aber... Aber zum Beispiel diese Seifenblase, das haben die auch.
22.44 Uhr, jetzt müssen wir mal langsam zur Pottel kommen. Ja, ich hab auch Hunger.
Das hieß irgendwie Revert Point oder sowas. Es ist ganz furchtbar, will man nicht haben, aber kann es theoretisch, weil ich weiß nicht, wie es heißt.
Verdammter Stream, ich entflätter euch gleich.
Mach doch.
Stream wieder da.
Siehste, zu schnell.
Genau, das können wir in der Zukunft machen. Sobald da 20 neue Flatter drauf sind, geht der Stream wieder.
Wir sind ja eh nicht bei Spreeblick.
Aber wir haben schon 20.
Toni hat jetzt die Lampe da, wird sie jetzt kaufen, ja?
Ja, hab ich eigentlich nicht mitbekommen.
Die Lampe, die an Zeichnungen geflattert wurde?
Ich hab's getwittert, aber ich hab das Ergebnis nicht mitbekommen.
Ja, er hat dann wohl genug Flatter bekommen. Er wollte irgendwie so eine Lampe für 195 Euro kaufen und... Wenn er 195 Flatters kriegt, was nicht derselben Menge Geld ist, entspricht nicht.
Also er hat trotzdem draufgezahlt, vermutlich.
Ja, hat aber auch mehr Flatters als 195 bekommen.
Versteh ich jetzt das Konzept nicht, wer kriegt die Flatters?
Er kriegt und er kauft die Lampe.
Er kauft die Lampe, er hat halt so ein Deal gemacht mit ihr. Macht ihr so ein...
20 haben wir genau heute schon eingesammelt hier.
Wie heute?
In den letzten 24 Stunden, top 24 Stunden, wieder auf Sendung.
mobilemax.de Ach so, der Blog-Eintrag.
Die Ankündigung, dass wir wieder senden.
Ist mal wieder erstaunlich zu sehen, was da so rumflattert wird.
Haben wir denn noch so ein Mac-Thema vielleicht kurz, bevor wir hier wieder in die Webzahl zu Null-Geschichte?
Ich hab noch ein Internet-Thema, was so ein ganz Allgemeines. Und mit dem Deinstallieren, dem Elend, das wollte ich mal loswerden. Und Safari Extensions wollte ich euch noch mal fragen.
Weil der Ad-Blog weiterhin die Files runterlädt, anstatt das Aufbücchen zu blocken.
Ach so, aber das ist ja ein konzeptionelles Problem. Ja, aber dann musst du halt Glimmerblocker nehmen.
Ja, also der Ad selbst stinkt nicht, ich kenne da nichts dafür, so safari stinkt.
Ja, aber es ist doch gar nicht Safaris Aufgabe, gar nicht die Files dann runterzuladen.
Ach du meinst, weil das API...
Nee, aber es ist Safaris Aufgabe, die API zur Verfügung zu stellen, dass die Blogs nicht verhindern können, was bei Google Chrome zum Beispiel geht. Und bei Firefox sowieso.
Wie, bei Chrome laden sie nicht runter?
Mehr als 50 Prozent.
Und die obere Grenze, bitte noch mal. Weil eigentlich ist halt genau dieser Punkt, es gibt halt Glimmerblocker für den Mac, das ist so ein Proxy, der adblockt. Ja, und der macht das halt für alle deine Sachen, die diesen Proxy natürlich dann benutzen. Das heißt, du kannst halt Browser-Updates installieren und musst nicht deine Extensions mitinstallieren. Glimmerblocker blockt das halt schon direkt an der Eingangstür. Eigentlich total schick so. Und jetzt sagt Dennis halt irgendwie, der Adblocker von Safari Extension lädt die halt runter und blockt die dann halt erst im JavaScript oder CSS.
Und zeigt die halt nur nicht an, aber er lädt sie.
Aber das machen meiner Meinung nach halt eigentlich alle Adblocks.
Aber ich meine, so ein Adblocker könnte doch auf zwei Arten arbeiten. Entweder er kriegt mit alles klar, das ist das, was in der Seite drinne und das blende ich einfach mal aus, was da drinne ist, so kann er vorgehen. Oder er kann die URL vorher umschreiben, bevor sie geladen wird.
Ja, also ich meine, im Prinzip ist es ja sowieso so, die gucken halt in ihre URL-Listen. Eben.
Hast du das API mal angeguckt?
Ich hab's mir leider nie genauer angeguckt.
Sonst jemand?
Ich kenne nur das Chrome-API, aber auch nur in älteren Versionen. Und ich glaube...
Also mir war jetzt dann der Typ, der Adblock schreibt, dass der geschrieben hat, bei Chrome würde das gehen, weil die haben dann speziell was zur Verfügung gestellt, dass er das machen kann. Und bei Safari geht das eben nicht.
Weil Glimmerblock hat auch so einen kleinen Nachteil für IPv6-Enthusiasten. Darum benutze ich das leider auch nicht mehr.
Aber ich bin jetzt auf Chrome gewechselt. Ich war ja früher mal so ein Firefox-Fanatiker.
Du warst ja schon immer ein bisschen anders.
Wie bleibt gerade einer das Gegenteil?
Safari 5 war mir zu instabil.
Das Gegenteil von was?
Und zu langsam.
Das ist ja doch nicht runtergeladen.
So that resources can be prevented from downloading. Ah ja, ne, ist andersrum. Chrome macht es nicht und Safari macht es so. Moment, das ist aber nur ein Zitat. Quelle?
Irgendeiner im Internet.
Achso, das ist der Typ, der Adblock geschrieben hat. Ja, also ist das genau andersrum.
Hast du die ganze Zeit mit einer Lüge gelebt.
Ja, von mehr als 50 Prozent, so kann man sich irren.
Ich finde tatsächlich, Chrome ist mittlerweile der schönere, also der deutlich schönere Browser als Safari. Vom User-Interface her und so finde ich es tatsächlich.
Und den Google-Update.
Chrome ist wesentlich Apple-Versier als das Safari ist. Machst du das fest? Ich finde das Chrome-Interface sehr schön aufgeräumt. Ich finde die Tabs da oben sehr gut gelöst.
Ich finde es scheiße, dass die mir einfach einen fucking Updater installieren und einen Launch-Demon ohne dass sie irgendwie was davon erzählen und dass man den nicht deinstallieren kann.
Das ist in der Tat echt.
Macht das Chrome auch? Ich weiß es nicht.
Man kann den installieren, aber Google Earth installiert den immer wieder.
Und dein Chrome meckert auch, wenn er nicht installiert ist.
Also es gibt doch bei Chrome diesen Button, möchtest du das für alle Benutzer installieren oder sowas, jedes Update-Möglichkeit.
Aber Macintosh, also wie kannst du behaupten, dass das User-Interface Macintosh-artiger wäre? Also wenn ich mir allein die Scrolling-Preferenz-Panes anschaue?
Man kopiert den restlichen Browser an. Wien interessieren die Scrolling?
Das ist das User-Interface mein Freund.
Die Einstellung?
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Gehen die mit Apfelkomma hoch?
Apfelkomma ist das erste, was ich drücke, wenn ich ein Programm ausprobiere.
Also zum Beispiel hat das unten keine Status-Leiste, die die ganze Zeit eingeblendet ist, sondern wenn ich mit der Maus rüber gehe, dann erscheint der Link in so einem... Also ich kann das ganze Fenster nutzen, finde ich wesentlich besser gemacht als bei Safari, wo ich die Wahl habe, entweder gar keine Status-Leiste einzublenden und nie zu sehen, auf welchen Link ich klicke oder nur mal diese 20 Pixel dazu haben. Ich weiß, stimmt, gibt es eine Extension für...
Ne, mal ehrlich, ich finde das nicht so... Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wo der Chrome meckiger sei als...
Ne, oben die Titel-Leiste allein, die sieht...
Ja, das finde ich ja gerade nicht besonders meckig hier. Da gibt es ja noch nicht mal eine Toolbar, die man ausklappen kann, wo man tool... Du kannst ja überhaupt nicht... Das ist ja gar keine richtige Toolbar. Ich kann das hier nicht anklicken. Ich kann das nicht rausziehen.
Das kannst du ja auch großartig anklicken und rausziehen.
Was ich denn nervöre, wenn ich das in allen Programmen mache?
Unglaublich viele Toolbars, die man nie braucht.
Was, die brauch ich alle?
Warum sind sie ja auch da?
Deswegen sind sie ja da. Was heißt, ich brauch die nicht, mein Freund? Das ist größer und kleiner.
Das ist für den nicht ein Reload-Button.
Das ist der Reload-Button.
Das ist auch eine Extension übrigens.
Damit ich nicht hier hinten... Das ist AdBlock, das brauch ich tatsächlich nicht unbedingt hier an der Stelle. Das ist dieser großartige Sessions. Das wollte ich euch mal empfehlen. Tolle Safari Extensions wollte ich jetzt mal hören.
Kann ich hier so einiges brauchen?
AdBlock ist voll toll, wenn die Ressourcen doch nicht runterladen.
Das ist wichtig irgendwie. Also Sessions finde ich sehr praktisch. Das benutze ich nicht wirklich, das habe ich hier nur gehabt. Na ja, One Password ist ja sowieso ein Dauerthema.
Password gibt es immer noch eine schöne Erinnerung für Chrome.
Also es kann auf jeden Fall sein, dass Chrome schneller ist und ein toller Render und vielleicht, obwohl das stimmt gar nicht, dass die mehr html...
Das ist bei diesem Web-Kit, das ist alles egal, ist alles gleich.
Aber...
Na, die können höchstens um einen Monat auseinander liegen. Anders kann es doch gar nicht sein.
Na, die haben komplett andere JavaScript-Engine.
Und die ist schneller momentan.
Schleller als Web-Kit? Das schwankt doch aber auch als Sauer.
Das hängt davon ab, welchen Benchmark du einlust.
Und Chrome ist jetzt meine Ding. Ist mir auch egal, wenn die vorne sind, aber irgendwie diese Cocoa-Gui ist mir tatsächlich auch... Und vor allen Dingen, wie gesagt, diese wirklich Schweinerei, dass sie mir diesen Updater unterschieben und den nicht weglassen können und nicht...
Den hast du bei Apple auch.
Ja, das ist aber immer ein anderer Lieger, wenn der Third Party mir irgendwelche Demons installiert, die dann im Hintergrund irgendwelche Daten funken.
Also ich weiß das von Google Earth, ich weiß es aber nicht von Chrome. Also bei Chrome...
Jaja, alle Google-Programme. Alle Google-Programme installieren den oder nutzen ihn. Installieren den oder nutzen ihn. Und er sagt dir noch nicht mal, wenn er dir eine neue Version installiert hast. Das Chrome aktualisiert sich auf deinem Scheißrechner automatisch und sie sagen es dir nicht mal.
Das wird Firefox wahrscheinlich auch so machen in der nächsten... Also mit Firefox-Fieber das auch kommen. Ja, um Sicherheitsupdates reinzukriegen.
Haben sie das ja so angesagt, dass es so sein wird. Also die größeren Updates...
Jetzt mehr geheimes Krimmerei.
Also bei Chrome kriege ich mit, wenn ich eine neue Version habe. Und zwar daran, dass er mir sagt, mach mal einen Neustart, ich hab eine neue Version für dich installiert.
Also weil er immer läuft.
Weil er immer läuft. Aber es gibt bei Chrome tatsächlich explizit diesen Button installiert, die Update-Möglichkeit so, dass er auch läuft, wenn ich gerade nicht laufe oder irgendwie sowas.
Darf ich trotzdem noch tolle Safari Extensions vornehmen?
Nur wenn es die auch für Chrome gibt.
Ich darf nicht mehr in der Rauch.
Wir sind ja gleich fertig, aber du hast gefragt, ob ich noch Mac-spezifische Themen habe. Ich hab Mac-spezifische Themen.
Ich klaue sie auch noch von der anderen.
Es gibt das schöne JavaScript-Blacklist, damit kannst du dir bestimmte Merkwürdigkeiten, die manche Webseiten haben, wie JavaScripte, die dir das kopieren, von Texten verhindern oder dir dann noch irgendwelche URLs mit reinklicken, kannst du damit bremsen und kannst du bestimmte Button, wie snap.com, Browser, Previews, was du nicht brauchst, kannst du einfach reinschreiben. Wenn du den Flatter nicht magst, dann kannst du da apiflatter.com eintragen. Da wird halt einfach Kommunikation von JavaScript mit bestimmten Domains einfach nicht möglich. Dann, was ich auch noch sehr nett fand, ist dieses To Prowl. Also Prowl auf einem iPhone ist ja quasi das Growl fürs iPhone mit Push-Notifications. Und was kommt dann an? Wenn du im Safari eine Webseite hast, die du auf dem iPhone öffnen möchtest, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann hast du einfach da oben einen Button und sagst einfach dahin und dann geht das als Push in die Prowl-Applikation auf deinem iPhone rein und da siehst du dann die Url und kannst sie anklicken und den Safari aufmachen.
Prowl bietet dafür eine Unterstützung, das URLs zu öffnen? Wusste ich gar nicht.
Ja.
Sowas vermisse ich nämlich schon eine ganze Weile. Ich dachte, Prowl könnte immer nur Notifications anzeigen und dann hat sich der Salat.
Nö, also das ist genau das, was ich hier mache. Zwei Prowl heißt das. To Prowl. Und das ist halt einfach eine Safari-Exception.
Kenboy.
Ja Max, du bist eine Bereicherung. Das ist nicht gut. Nein, das war nicht ernsthaft. Ich mein, sonst würden wir nicht über Windows-Microsoft-Tastaturen reden.
Die ich gar nicht so schlecht finde. Von Apple würde ich nie kommen.
Wir kommen langsam zu Ende, oder? Ihr merkt es alle. Soll ich noch das Internet-Thema anstoßen? Also mir geht es einfach so ein bisschen. Okay, Bewusstseinsschaffung. Vor kurzem wurde gefeiert, dass die sogenannte Route-Zone, DNS-Route-Zone, also die Route-DNS-Server des Internets gesigned wurden.
Der letzte.
Der letzte, also jetzt alle gesigned sind. Das heißt... Vom Internet. Na gut, ich meine, das sind halt die Route-Server. Derer gibt es halt 13 oder so. Da kannst du dich sozusagen versichern, dass es die gibt. Und die sind jetzt halt auch noch kryptographisch signiert. Die sind halt bekannt. Wo vorher halt nur IP-Adressen bekannt waren, kannst du jetzt eben auch das Ergebnis sicherstellen, dass es auch wirklich von denen kam. Und nicht von einem Rechner, der behauptet hat, diese IP-Adresse zu sein.
Seit 2010.
Man in the Middle Attacke. Genau. So, jetzt ist das so eine Sache, die jetzt von Subdomain zu Subdomain weitergereicht werden muss, um wirklich sinnvoll zu sein. Das heißt, alle Top-Level-Domains, a la DE und COM und so weiter werden halt in den nächsten Jahren schrittweise auch sozusagen selbst signiert sein.
Wenn die Schlüssel nicht ablaufen.
Wenn die Schlüssel nicht abfallen oder sonst irgendwas Schlimmes passiert. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was ist da eigentlich so toll da dran und wozu braucht man das?
Hat Google das schon?
Mit ihrem 8888?
Weiß ich nicht. Das hat auch damit erstmal nichts zu tun, mit dem DNS-Servern, sondern das hat was damit zu tun.
Mit den Zonen.
Mit den Zonen selbst, inwieweit, wie die aufgesetzt sind. Ob du da einfach signierten Key hast. Also wenn du halt, also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass DE auch signiert sei, was glaube ich zum heutigen Tag noch nicht ist, aber das wird stattfinden. Und du hast halt jetzt, was weiß ich hier, mobilemax.de. Dann könnten wir halt mobilemax.de auch signieren. Sodass halt jeder, der in mobilemax.de etwas abfragt, sich sicher sein kann, dass das auch nicht gespufft ist.
Also Google würde dann nur durchreichen, die müssen ja selber gar nichts machen.
Das ist einfach normal DNS. Ich bin mir gerade jetzt nicht so sicher, inwieweit DNS-Tech auf das Protokoll noch einen Einfluss hat, aber ich glaube eigentlich ist das nur eine Content-Frage. Da bewege ich mich auf dünnen Eis. Darauf wollte ich auch gar nicht hinaus. Aber angenommen, das wäre jetzt so. mobilemax.de ist sozusagen signiert. Das heißt, das steht drin. Diese Zone ist irgendwie von DE, weil das ist halt mit DE signiert und DE ist vom Root signiert und deswegen weiß man, dass das stimmt. Was man jetzt nämlich machen kann, ist, dass man HTTPS, diese Zertifikate, diese Keys, die man braucht, sich nicht mehr kaufen muss, sondern man generiert die einfach selbst und legt die Keys in seine Zone rein. Und man kann ohne Geld dafür zu bezahlen sicheres Internet machen. Du kannst auch deine GPG-Keys da reinlegen.
Ist das jetzt von dir so ein Zukunftding, was du dir so überlegt hast, oder machen das schon welche?
Na ja, an Betracht der Tatsache, dass jetzt gerade mal die Root-Zone signiert ist und das noch nie ist.
Das kann ja nicht im Sinne von Veri sein.
Also die Leute, die DNSSEC gepusht haben, hatten das von Anfang an im Sinn, das zu tun. Das heißt, durch DNSSEC wird dieses Zertifikatsystem aufgebrochen, was ja an sich schon gebrochen ist, weil das Business-Modell, das du nämlich da in einem konkurrierenden Markt Dienstleistungen günstiger anbietest, der eigentlichen Sicherheit, die du erzeugen willst, gegenläufig ist. Weil du kannst immer noch eine Bude finden, die dir noch weniger Aufwand treibt, die Echtheit desjenigen, der da einen Zertifikat hat, zu überprüfen, um es billiger zu machen. Und da gehen natürlich dann die meisten hin. Das heißt, offener Markt widerspricht vollständig dem eigentlichen Sinn und Zweck. Wenn du aber jetzt mit DNSSEC arbeitest, dann ist das eben sehr wohl möglich. Und du kannst dann eben deine ganzen Public Keys in deine eigene Zone reinwerfen und damit eben öffentlich abfragbar machen, ohne dass man irgendjemand irgendwas bezahlen muss.
Ja und wie kriegst du denn Key bei dem DE Root Server rein?
Na du hast doch deine Domain gekauft. Du zahlst doch für deine Domain.
Ja dann zahlst du bei denen dann ab sofort. Dafür, dass sie dein Key da reinmachen.
Na zahlst einmalig.
Naja, du zahlst halt deine Domain Gebühr.
Du hast das mit der Domain, hast du den Key.
Und dann bekommst du halt auch eine gesignete Domain.
Und die Zone kannst du dir auf deinen eigenen DNS-Domain delegieren.
Aber du kannst ab dann für deine gesamten Subdomains selber signen. Du musst nirgendwo mehr hingehen. Und das ist ja auch ein echtes Problem heutzutage. Du kannst ja nicht mal eben sagen, gib mir mal für meine Domain ein SSL-Zertifikat und dann mach ich mit diesem Zertifikat mir meine eigenen Domains für meine Subkeys. Das geht zwar theoretisch, aber du musst dann mehr zahlen und dann geben sie dir irgendwelche Sternpunkt-Tralala-Sachen und das ist dann nicht so sicher und das ist irgendwie alles total furchtbar und broken. Und es funktioniert halt nicht so, wie das Internet funktioniert. Und mit DNS-Tags funktioniert das eben auf einmal so, wie das Internet funktioniert. Naja, ich hab das mir aufgeschrieben, weil mir das selber klar geworden ist, als ich mir das mal in Kanada von jemanden habe erklären lassen, der auch aktiv an diesem Rollhaut beteiligt war. Das ist sicherlich ein Thema, aber es ist noch keine geplante Sendung, wenn du das meinst.
Also doch, Blickenleit.
Hust, hust, hust. Ihr seid durch, ne? Dabei könnten wir jetzt noch Wave irgendwie Goodbye sagen und so. Okay, aber jetzt nochmal ein ernst gemeintes Wort.
Habt ihr den Java-Google-Hack gelesen, warum Google Java auf dem Android einsetzen kann, was sie eigentlich so nicht dürften? Stand bei dem John Gruber vorhin, den hab ich kurz mal reingelesen. Und zwar weil die nicht den original Java-Bytecode nehmen, sondern ihren eigenen Bytecode haben.
Ja, die Dalvik vor allem.
Genau. Schon ein ganz schön krasser Hack, oder?
Ja, aber das ist auch Pain für die Entwickler so ein bisschen gewesen am Anfang, weil es ja nicht kompatibel ist.
Na eben, aber auch ein Stunt, finde ich.
Na mal sehen, in welcher Sack kannst du sich damit noch manövrieren? Sie haben jetzt C und C++ irgendwie. Ne, .NET und C++ aktiviert für ihr SDK. Also fertig. Geht jetzt wohl auch, dass C++ abspawnt.
Haben sie eingesehen, dass Java doch zu langsam ist?
Java ist nicht wirklich langsam.
Also sind wir jetzt leider überhaupt nicht zugekommen. Ich hatte mir extra mal Nexus One ausgeliehen, weil ich mich mal wieder so...
Aber gibt es das denn noch?
Das Nexus One als Developer-Gerät. Also du kannst es nicht mehr über diese amerikanische Website kaufen. Und ich glaube, bei Vodafone gibt es das auch nicht mehr, aber...
Wann kam das Device raus?
Wann war ich hier nicht gleich bei einem...
Also du kannst dich nach wie vor als Developer anmelden, dann kannst du es kaufen als Unlocked-Gerät. Und darum hatte ich mir das von T ausgeliehen, der bei der Seabase sich ein bisschen um Android kümmert und da so ein Android-Stammtisch aufziehen will. Und der hat bei Google mal nachgefragt, ob er nicht ein paar Androids haben kann. Und dann haben die ihm ein paar Androids zugeschickt. Nein, Nexus One, genau. Android, Telefone, das Nexus One. Und das hat er mir dann mal, nachdem ich ihm gesagt habe, ich brauch mal wieder Argumente gegen Tim, dass auch Android gar nicht so schlecht ist, hat er gesagt, das ist wichtig und schob so ein Ding rüber. Dann hatte ich das für einen Monat und hab das so mitgenommen. Und das allererst, was ich gemacht habe, ist da Android 2.2 drauf zu installieren, weil vorher war nur 2.1 drauf. Was ich echt scheiße fand, war das Display, leider. Die Größe ist so iPhone Nest, hat eine etwas höhere Auflösung. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, welche Auflösung, ist halt so ein OLED-Teil.
Ach, das Ding war das, verstehe.
Und das säuft halt bei Sonne unglaublich ab, das glaubt man gar nicht. Also muss nicht mal direkte Sonnenentstrahlung sein, sondern auch wenn da Wolken am Himmel sind oder sowas. Du kennst da nur noch, na nix mehr nicht, aber deutlich schlechter und deutlich schlechter als auf dem iPhone. Und die Software kriegen sie.
Das kam nur jetzt dieses Jahr raus, oder?
Das Nexus One, nee, das kam, wohl stimmt, das kam Ende, also auf dem Kongress waren da so die allerersten, so füchthalb. Februar kam es raus, ja.
Und jetzt gibt es das schon nicht mehr, krass. Was haben die denn für Cycles da, die Jungs?
Ich glaube, das liefert vielleicht gut. Na ja, das ist, gut, dieses Nexus One ist ja nun auch eigentlich ein Telefon, was im Wesentlichen von Google mehr so ein Marketing-Instrument war als, also so ein Developer-Marketing-Instrument war, als jetzt wirklich ein ernst gemeinder Ansatz.
Aber da gab es auch schon noch Android-Geräte, hätte man sich doch sparen können.
Ja, die sind alle gebrandet und alle irgendwie...
Das ist ja dieses Kernproblem bei Android, dass halt jeder das nimmt und machen kann, damit was er will. So, was jetzt, gab es ja hier vor Kurzem, dieses Update da von Vodafone, ja, die haben dir dann irgendwie so ein Betriebssystem-Update dafür dein Android-Phone gepusht, wo dann irgendwelche Vodafone-Ups drauf sind, die du wieder nicht löschen konntest und so weiter. Und dann hast du irgendwie alles in so einem Vodafone-Style. Und dann lief es aber auch nicht so gut, weil das halt auch nicht so durchgetestet war. Nicht wahr? Das ist halt eine andere Denke an der Stelle.
Und bei dem Nexus One kriegst du dann halt so das Vanilla-Google-Android mit, hier kannst du alles machen.
Wo auch immer die Update schön schnell kommen und sowas.
Das war im Prinzip Googles Versuch, allen mal zu zeigen, wie sie sich das eigentlich vorstellen, weil sie das mit ihren Partnern so gar nicht tun können.
Und wenn du das Developer-Gerät gekauft hast, konntest du es auch routen. Also dann hattest du auch volle Route-Rechte und brauchst es da nicht ein Jailbreak zu machen oder ähnliches, sondern dann hattest du einen vollen Zugriff auf das Ding.
Und das haben sie einfach verschenkt.
In rauen Mengen.
Nicht nur, dass sie an Android schon kein Geld verdienen, sondern an diesem Gerätepark, den haben sie dann auch noch im Prinzip frei finanziert.
Da möchte ich echt mal wissen, wie viele die da rausgeblasen haben. Allein auf Berliner Veranstaltungen, was die da für Devices rausge...
Jede Veranstaltung, von der ich gehört habe, die Google und Android war, kam sie irgendwie mit ganzen Ladungen.
Sie wollen halt in diesen Markt rein. Ich meine, was Microsoft jetzt, was die Entwickler zahlen, damit sie ihre Apps von iPhone auf Windows-Mobile portieren und so. Also Windows Phone 7. Die gehen halt in eine andere Strategie, aber einen anderen Weg. Aber die werden auch anfangen, Telefone zu verschenken.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, sie haben auch Erfolg. Also Android ist jetzt zahlenmäßig halt auf dem Weg, die Plattform Nummer 1 zu sein.
Also es ist auch ein gutes OS. Es ist nicht so halb so polych wie das iPhone oder sowas.
Das ist nicht scheiße. Und das ist auf jeden Fall auch schon mal eine signifikante, generelle, qualitative Verbesserung des Computermarktes an sich. Habe ich ja auch schon ein paar Mal hier.
Es gibt Telefone, die nicht scheiße sind.
Vor 10 Jahren hatten wir noch dieses ganze Elend. Microsoft dominiert alles.
Und so irgendwie ein Verlangsam.
Ich rede gar nicht von Telefon. Ich rede eher von Computing an sich, weil dieser Mobilfond, das ist ja auch beyond Telefon. Ich meine, jetzt kommen diese ganzen Tablets, jetzt kommen alle möglichen Devices. Weiß der Geier, wohin iOS noch überall hin expandiert wird? Das ist eigentlich die zukünftige Computing-Plattform. Und Android ist jetzt dabei.
iOS-Geräte, mit denen man so aufklappen kann, wo hier so eine Tastatur drin ist.
Android ist dabei, das Windows der nächsten 10 Jahre zu werden.
Ja, die Chance besteht sehr gut.
Nur, dass der Marktanteil zwischen Apple und dem neuen Windows nicht 95 zu 5% betragen wird.
Doch, das wird er noch werden.
Na ja, aber schon gar nicht. Du meinst jetzt von Zahlen her, da sehe ich viele Möglichkeiten für Apple noch zu expandieren. Zumal ja in diesen Statistiken......
dieses Unlocking-Problem lösen würden.
Das haben sie aber jetzt weitgehend gelöst.
Außer in den größten Ländern, wo es am wichtigsten ist. Deutschland und Avi-Land.
Jungs, Fake Steve macht ja in letzter Zeit nicht mehr so viele coole Posts, aber letztens war er wieder einer, der ein Signal auf den Kopf getroffen hat, dem ist das scheißegal, wie viel Marktanteil sie haben, solange sie irgendwie shitloads of money davon raustragen.
Genau, da wollte ich jetzt auch noch drauf hinaus. Hast du diese Tabelle gesehen? Die Tabelle, Smartphone-Markt, also jetzt nur der Smartphone international, weltweit, alle Einnahmen, nein, Entschuldigung, Gewinne, alle Gewinne. Wie verhält sich der Gewinn, den Apple in diesem Markt macht, zu dem Gewinn von allen anderen?
Na, Apple macht alle Platz, also, die tragen Goldschubkarren daraus.
Apple verdient im Smartphone-Markt, weltweit, doppelt so viel wie alle anderen zusammen.
An Gewinn?
Der Gewinn von Nokia, der Gewinn von Motorola, der Gewinn von allen beträgt in der Summe die Hälfte von dem, das Apple verdient.
Aber ich glaube, natürlich sind die glücklich. Ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt auf so eine Situation hinauslaufen muss, wie das sozusagen Android-Apple platt macht und das Apple kurz vor der Pleite steht. Das heißt, es nicht zwangsläufig.
Nicht die Bohne.
Aber ich glaube, dass das Android tatsächlich irgendwie 95 Prozent haben wird, weil all diese Leute, die eigentlich gar kein Smartphone haben wollen, sondern eigentlich nur ein Feature-Phone wollen, werden in Zukunft mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit irgendwann Android haben. Das ist ein Bereich, in den Apple wahrscheinlich gar nicht rein will.
Man hat diese ganzen Fennig-Telefone, die sie eben nachschmeißen. Die werden früher alle so ein bisschen...
Und auch so für irgendwelche Märkte, die für Apple nicht so spannend sind, weil sie nicht genügend Geld hergeben, aus genau den Gründen, die du beschreibst, die werden auch von Android überrollt werden. Und damit wird es so sein, dass...
Also die Märkte, wo man kein Geld verdient...
.dass tatsächlich hier in Deutschland, Amerika oder sowas Apple einen sehr hohen Marktanteil haben wird, der deutlich höher ist als das, was sie haben. Aber so dieses Ganze, diese Schwellenländer und so, ich glaub, da wird Apple keinen, oder nur einen sehr kleinen Fuß in die Tür kriegen und der Rest wird Android sein.
Der Markt interessiert ja auch nicht, aus Business-Sicht wahrscheinlich.
Aber wenn du Software dafür entwickelst und so, dann ist das natürlich schon wieder interessant.
Die Leute haben eh kein Geld, um dir das zu bezahlen.
Ach komm, wenn hier 100 Leute für ein Euro was kaufen, ist mir das mehr wert, als wenn einer 20 Euro zahlt.
Die Afrikade, die haben gar keinen Dollar.
Geld verdienen tut aber keiner im Android-Markt.
Also das muss man echt sagen bei Android, das ist total scheiße, dieser Market ist unter aller Sorge.
Ja, aber keiner verdient Geld. Google verdient kein Geld.
Und die Entwickler auch noch nicht.
Also die Telefonhersteller, die verdienen noch Geld mit dem Verkauf von Telefonen.
Sehr, sehr wenig.
Wahrscheinlich eher mit den Verträgen, ja.
Ja, aber sie verdienen zumindest Geld und sie verdienen indirekt damit sozusagen mit Android-Geld, weil sie eben nicht Windows-Lizenzen kaufen müssen. Das ist im Wesentlichen für sie eigentlich nur eine Ersparnis. Klar, Android ist eine Marketing-Kampagne von Google. Nutzt unsere Dienste, mehr denn je.
Ja, also, aber so, das ist wirklich einer dieser Market. Und ich glaub, ich glaub, das weiß, also ich, das muss jemand bei Google wissen. Dieser Market ist unter aller Sau, der ist bei Apple um so vieles besser. Also schon allein angefangen damit, dass in diesem Android-Market, dass ich sehe immer die Währung, also ich muss immer in der Währung bezahlen, in der die, die der Autor reingestellt hat. Also wenn er einen Pfund das irgendwie hat, dann steht da ein Preis von einem Pfund 38. Dann kann ich erst mal nachrechnen, was der Umrechnungskurs ist.
Es gibt auch keine richtigen Landing-Pages für so Apps, ne? Also du kannst halt nur über deinen, also es gab eine ganze Zeit lang, konntest du nur über dein Telefon so richtig in diesen Market auch rein und so, ne?
Die Top-Downloads sind, glaube ich, so lange, wie ich diesen Market kenne. Und ich hatte den HTC Meldring, hatte ich mal. Das ist so ein Backgrounds-Up, ist immer mit da vorne dabei. Jetzt natürlich so eine Sachen wie Flash und Acrobat Reader. Aber da ist so unglaublich wenig Bewegung drin in den Top-Listen. Also es macht so wahnsinnig viel mehr Spaß, auf diesem, im iTunes-Store irgendwie rumzuwühlen und einfach nur mal zu gucken, was da so ist, weil es ist besser präsentiert und sowas.
Die Auswertungen für Leute, die Apps gemacht haben, sind halt auch total für den Fuß. Also du siehst halt irgendwie nur so einen Bruchteil von irgendwelchen relevanten Statistiken. Die tun ja auch extrem wenig raus für die Publisher sozusagen.
Und die sind noch schlimmer als YouTube-Kommentatoren, quasi das, was die Leute so von sich geben. Wobei das im App-Store auch furchtbar ist, muss man ja auch sagen. Und es sind halt wahnsinnig viele Schrott-Apps dabei. Ich meine, ich zweifel nicht mal daran, dass es die im App-Store auch gibt, aber die sind irgendwie besser versteckt. Ich weiß nicht, wie sie es machen, aber die stechen nicht so ins Auge.
Es hat einfach auch eine Kandidatur, dass es gar keine Möglichkeit gibt, überhaupt irgendwas zu verkaufen. Also hier gibt es diese schöne Zusammenfassung. Den Android-Market gibt es derzeit nur in 46 Ländern. Davon kannst du aber nur in 13 wirklich was kaufen. In allen anderen, in den anderen 33, kannst du nur kostenlose Software runterladen.
Also ich glaube, wenn der Markt gut wäre...
Jetzt wird es noch besser. Nur, es gibt auch noch die Limitierung, dass du auch noch in einem bestimmten Land wohnen musst, um überhaupt was einstellen zu dürfen. Und das sind nur 9.
Also ich glaube, wenn der Markt gut wäre und wenn es da echt coole Apps wären, dann wäre das schade, aber dann wäre das kein großes Problem. Das Problem ist einfach, dass ich glaube, die meisten Leute, wenn sie den Markt einmal aufmachen, werden sie den kriegen und werden mit Grausen sich davon abwenden.
Aber macht nicht das Auto das Telefon aus? Also wen interessiert denn auch so ein Android auf Dauer, wenn es da keine coolen Apps gibt? Wenn der eine irgendwie sein iPhone hat und da lauter Games am Zocken ist und der andere hat seinen Android und guckt der ganze Zeit drüber, ich will auch zocken und es geht nicht, dann brauche ich doch das iPhone.
Also Spiele vielleicht, wobei ich jetzt für mich... Es gibt ja gute Apps. Es ist ja nicht so, als ob es keine guten Apps geben würde. Man muss sich anders mit beschäftigen. Es gibt nicht die große Auswahl. Sie sind nicht ganz so gut wie auf dem iPhone. Aber es gibt gute Apps für das Ding.
Wie findet man die denn?
Indem man entsprechende Blogs liest und so was, indem man auf Empfehlungen hört. Du wirst halt nicht mehr den Store finden.
Das Hauptproblem ist wahrscheinlich, ich vermute einfach, dass das Hauptproblem sein wird, dass es eine Milliarde unterschiedlicher Devices gibt, mit einer Milliarde unterschiedlicher Vendor-gebrandeter OS. Mit einer Milliarde unterschiedlicher GUIs. Es gibt ja jetzt schon die Tendenzen, dass wir immer mehr unterschiedliche GUIs machen und dass du dann halt am Ende einfach zwar eine coole App hast, sondern aber läuft die oder läuft die nicht, oder läuft die nicht richtig. Das ist ja auch für Entwickler in totaler Hesse. Also ich krieg das ja mit, weil bei uns in der Firma wird ja Android entwickelt. Und die schmerzen die da manchmal schon durch Leid oder der Mehraufwand, der da entsteht, durch irgendwie okay, jetzt kommt noch einer mit irgendeinem komischen, custom-gebrandeten HTC Desire 2. Hast du nicht gesehen? Dann ist irgendwas da drauf anders, was auf allen anderen HTC Desires aber eigentlich funktioniert hat.
Also kann ich jetzt nichts zu sagen, weil ich wollte ja unbedingt das Nexus One haben, wegen Pure Google. Ich wollte da nicht irgendeine Samsung-Oberfläche oder eine HTC-Sense-Oberfläche drauf haben. Ich wollte auch die Chance haben, tatsächlich dieses Android-Frojo, oder wie es ausgesprochen wird, also dieses 2.2, diese aktuelle Version zu haben.
Das latest Update, was keiner hat.
Das latest Update, was du halt nur auf den Nexus One hast im Augenblick.
Immer noch.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es das mittlerweile auf... Ich glaube auf hier...
Ich glaube auf diesem HTC-Droid oder so.
Nein, das ist ein Motorola-Droid. Das ist ein Motorola-Droid.
Niemand weiß überhaupt Bescheid.
Also das finde ich... Google hat ja irgendwann die Bestimmungen gemacht, die du bringen musst, um den Android-Market auf deinem Gerät installieren zu dürfen. Also es gibt ja da Lizenzbestimmungen. Das darf ja nicht jeder. Die meisten Tablets haben nämlich gar keins, weil du musst nämlich bestimmte Tasten haben. Ansonsten darfst du diesen Android-Market nicht installieren. Lizenzrechtlich. Und nicht die ganzen anderen Google-Apps. Ich finde, das hätten sie viel mehr daran festmachen sollen.
Diese fest eingebrannten Tasten.
Die sind dafür wichtig, ja. Sie hätten einen Zyklus, sie hätten in den Lizenzvertrag reinschreiben sollen, wenn wir ein Betriebssystem-Update rausbringen, dann müssen wir das innerhalb von einem Monat drauf haben. Das wäre was gewesen, was, glaube ich, diesen Markt voranbringt. Und ich bin mal sehr gespannt...
Nicht nur den Markt, ja.
Also dieses OS. Und ich bin mal echt drauf... Wo ich am meisten Angst habe, was Android angeht, ist, was ist, wenn die jetzt so einen PDF-Fuck-Up haben, wie es iOS das hat. Und es wird kommen. Und sie haben eine Sicherheitslücke, die seit Version 1.0 durchklafft. Und...
Das kriegen die nie geupdatet.
Das kriegen die nie geupdatet. Das wird richtig, richtig scheiße sein.
Da war das ja eigentlich auch so. Also ich meine, die meisten Nokia-Telefone...
Ja, aber das Telefon konnte auch nicht genug, um ernsthaft Schaden anzurichten.
Ich glaube, die meisten Nokia-Telefone werden nie geupdatet. Ja, ich hab's mal probiert.
Ich hab meine Nokia immer geupdatet. Einmal im Laden, einmal bei Dollar Telefon Nerd.
Ich hab das mal auch mit Dollar Telefon Nerd probiert. Und der damals auch noch Special Zugang hatte irgendwie. Und selbst dann hat es noch drei Stunden gedauert mit mehreren internalen Support-Anrufen und drei verschiedenen Versuchen mit Software auf Windows zu installieren und so.
Bei mir ging es gleich super durch.
Volker Weber hat ja so, wie er sein E71 probiert hat, zu aktualisieren. Also dann so wie es bei, kurz Android, du hast ein Button, neues System ist da, drück drauf. Du hast Apple, ok, musst du anschließen, drückst ein Button, ist drauf. Und dann so zuerst Backup machen.
Dieser Vergleich zwischen den beiden.
Und so Backup machen und dann das und das. Und dann auch wirklich so, ja, dann fahre ich das Ding hoch und hab irgendein Programm drauf, was ich nicht möchte. Und das kann ich aber auch nicht deinstallieren. Dann muss er erstmal, damit ich überhaupt die Software installieren kann...
Nokia Connection Suit stand da, stimmt's?
Irgendwie so. Damit er die Software installieren konnte, mit der er sein Backup wieder einspielen kann, musste er die über ein OviStore installieren. Der OviStore brauchte aber selber erstmal ein Update auf einem frisch aktualisierten System. Dieses Update konnte er selber nicht über WLAN runterladen, sondern nur über 3G, weil er hat aus irgendwelchen Gründen keine andere Ausfall angeboten. Und die ganze Geschichte endet damit, dass das Backup nicht wieder eingespielt werden konnte. Und offensichtlich korrupt war. Also klar, kein Wunder, dass niemand Nokia aktualisiert. Das ist bei Android besser.
Das Team ist durch, glaub ich.
Ja, ich bin auch durch.
Wer hat denn so eigentlich bis zum Ende durchgehalten?
Ich.
Ihr habt so rein Hörer-technisch. Ich hab kaum Schlattern heute.
Wir fallen so viel Internet-Fuck ab, ich glaube, das Stream ist auch schon lange weg.
Meinst du?
Bei mir ging es hier an und aus, das war nur noch am Flattern.
Am Flattern? Schauen wir mal. Nö, das sieht ganz gut aus. Ich würde sogar sagen, das sind stabile Zuhörerzahlen hier.
Ich bin mal rein und raus irgendwie ausmörkt, da hab ich irgendwann ausgemacht.
Ja, ihr seid toll.
Das sind wahrscheinlich alle, die sind alle von ihren Rechnern eingeschlafen.
Das ist so die Werbung. Ich wollte das jetzt am Schluss einfach nochmal sagen. Wir sind dankbar für unsere Hörer. Und ich finde das auch mit diesem Flatter-Support ganz großartig, weil das ist wirklich echt mal Motivation und ermöglicht wirklich auch mal Investition. Das ist einfach toll. Das wird dieses ganze Podcasting enorm nach vorne bringen.
Flattert überhaupt. Wir haben gerade alle bis auf Dennis wirklich eine Laola gemacht.
Ich auch, hast du noch nicht gesehen?
Das war eine Nähle, Olaf.
Der ist halt nur so kurze Arme.
Weil wir sie wieder festgebunden haben.
So, nachdem es auf dieser Welle dann auch mit ohne Google Welle noch Wellen gibt.
Stimmt, wir brauchen ein neues Tool, um unsere T-Listen zu bearbeiten.
Ja, das bespreche ich mal in der nächsten Runde.
Jetzt sind wir da durch und danke für's Zuhören.
Ach, ich will raus hier, frische Luft. Meine Ohren glühen von den Kopfhörern.
Okay, dann sagen wir jetzt brav.
Tschüssi.
Tschüss.